is cable television companies providing
unbiased coverage of public affairs
events from the nation's capital and
around the world
[Music]
me
ladies and
gentlemen observe that smoking is no
longer permitted to connect with your
seat of right and return the table just
locked the station thank you
welcome back to vietnam revisited those
of you who have joined us in the past
recognize this shot possibly as the
beginning flight from bangkok thailand
back on april the 18th
by the c-span crew of five
to hanoi
to follow the m-i-a-p-o-w select
committee of the senate
as they look throughout the vietnam
countryside for living americans either
pows or mias some 2270
that are reported still missing in
action
we'll continue this series throughout
the rest of the week
the next few minutes we'll watch as this
thai air
airbus
which is a european airplane
not only
flies over the countryside of vietnam
but begins soon to land in hanoi
we'll come back in a moment or two and
talk about the schedule
for the rest of this day and the rest of
this week which includes visits from
pows from world war ii
jim webb former secretary of the navy
reid irvine with accuracy and media
senator john kerry
francis swinig who is the chief of staff
for the select committee on mis and pows
representatives from the different
family groups
and a gentleman who's written a book the
name of bruce franklin who thinks that
there are no mias and pows left let's
watch as this plane continues its flight
into hanoi in april of this year as we
continue with c-span's vietnam revisited
um
okay
so
[Music]
now
[Music]
welcoming everyone to
hanoi vietnam you can see off there in
the distance about a minute or so
the pools of water on the ground where
many of the bombs reportedly were
dropped back
long ago during the vietnam war also the
sights of
some hillsides or mountains off in the
distance around hanoi it was hot that
time of year back in april in hanoi it
was in the 90s and hundreds
down south and
i want to show you a parade magazine
some of you may have seen this
two sundays ago that's uh trump von tron
who will join us tomorrow and jim webb
will be with us on thursday former
secretary of the navy both went back to
vietnam and they told their story in
this magazine some of you may have read
it
we're going to show you the schedule for
the rest of today and give you some
sense of where we're headed also for the
rest of the week as we look at some
video shot
at night
upon our arrival that first night with a
c-span crew
in hanoi and you'll notice that there
are very few automobiles
those are cyclos
that we're riding in actually they're a
little fancier than some of us that
glows in town those are the new ones
they have over at the metropole hotel
where we did not stay but we walked over
and i think for a buck you could rent
those for
a good long time and ride through the
city of hanoi on that night of april the
18th as we watch that let's take a look
at today's schedule
coming up in about 25 minutes by the way
those of you who've been watching and
want to get two cents in on this the
telephone numbers
here will be on the screen you can dial
now and we'll have open phones for about
a half an hour the number in the east is
202-628-2525
and that also covers the central time
zone and in the west in both the
mountain and pacific time zones and on
to hawaii and alaska it's 202
783-2727 in the east that's 202-628-2525
in the west
202-783-2727 sure many of you
will have some thoughts about what
you've been watching in the last 24
hours if you saw it first when we ran
this originally over labor day
or when we started yesterday
at noon on monday east coast time
senator john mccain a former prisoner of
war five and a half years in north
vietnam will be with us at 12 30 via
videotape that we recorded before the
first time we showed this
we'll have two former prisoners of war
in world war ii chuck williams and bill
roland coming up at 1 25 east coast time
to take your calls and to talk about
what it's like to be a pow
the senate pow mia committee staff
director francis swinig will be with us
at two o'clock
to bring us up to date on where
everything is with that committee that
special committee of 12 senators that
are trying to conclude
this issue of mia pows by the end of
this year
that'll be followed
live call-in show at three o'clock
and we'll have
mary backley from the national league of
families
bruce franklin an author
who's written mia
or myth making in america he believes
there's no such thing as a living
missing in action or pow and tom
ashworth a pow researcher
that'll be in that three o'clock hour
east coast time until about 4 20.
then via satellite from boston senator
john kerry at 4 30 he's the chairman of
the mia pow's select committee in the
senate
followed at five o'clock again with
phones open alan patak
who is a defense department
specialist on mia pow affairs who will
give us the administration's view
of this issue
and that should be it mostly for this
day again watching a ride through hanoi
in the early evening
on
april the 18th there in the background
as we look at wednesday wednesday we
talk a lot about hoshi man and take a
visit to the ho chi minh mausoleum where
he is
there for viewing as is lenin in red
square the tutu hospital
obstetrics hospital which talked about
yesterday with katie kelly where
a lot of babies are born every year 750
beds
we'll visit there to take a look at
some of the alleged effects of agent
orange there's no proof as we'll learn
tomorrow
that agent orange has
brought about some of these defects but
we discussed that issue
also our guest
to fill in some of the blanks that we
had last time around and some of the
differences of opinion or reed irvine
will be here from acronym media
fred downs will return a former
lieutenant colonel in the army
who is a
expert at the veterans administration on
prosthetics
with the vietnam war and also has
written three books and tran van kai as
we just showed you on the cover of that
parade magazine that's the august 23rd
edition this year if you want to get it
in advance and then open phones
later
on thursday
james clad from the carnegie endowment
a man who has spent a lot of time both
here in the united states and in
southeast asia and has citizenship with
new zealand but is based in washington
now here to talk about
that whole area of the world southeast
asia including places like indonesia
malaysia singapore
thailand vietnam
u.s vietnam relations
later on in that day former secretary of
the navy james webb who's both an author
and also on the cover that parade
magazine and talks about his trip back
through the countryside from hanoi all
the way down to the mekong delta
and of course as we have every day
during this vietnam revisited
again so to speak we'll have open phones
finally then on friday
the high point of that day for most
people probably will be
watching the committee the mia pow
committee the united states senate tour
vietnam
including a three-stop trip to the
mekong delta
a number of those bases back in april
the first time any american had visited
there since the
mid 70s
and that will conclude
this special vietnam revisited which we
are bringing to you at your request
after many of you saw it over labor day
i'm sorry over memorial day and wanted
to take another look at it
for the time being though as we continue
to watch
hanoi at night let's take a call from
lexington kentucky
you're on the air go ahead please hi my
name is dan lucas and i do live in
lexington kentucky i just got off work
off a 12-hour shift
and i know
maybe time is brief and things are short
but uh i just watch your i'm first time
caller and i just watch this from time
to time another thing i want to mention
is the budget deficit it's way over get
out and vote vote libertarian and the
founding fathers warned against
political parties they dominate the
government create a deadlock and that's
where we are now they foresaw it and
get out and vote and thank c-span and
thank you
mr lam thanks for calling mike ask our
audience to try to keep their calls that
they could today on this vietnam
revisited special and we're anxious to
hear some of your own experiences until
we go to uh senator john mccain at the
bottom of the hour metairie louisiana go
ahead please
hello it's been a couple of years since
i called vietnam that's 67.68
yes sir where were you there i was at
long ben which was the only u.s military
installation to come under full-scale
ground attack during the tet offensive
located where it was located
approximately 18 miles outside of saigon
and what is your feeling about the
situation over there now
the situation over there now is pretty
much just what we expected we were
trying to protect the people from
communism i keep hearing people calling
in and they really don't understand what
happened i hear them defending ho chi
minh in some cases ho chi minh was a
communist since 1921 i believe was the
date when he was in russia and actually
took on russian citizenship and a lot of
people aren't even aware of this you
constantly hear the media referring to
the ted offensive as the turning point
and those who believe that
we lost the ted offensive that that's
perpetuated
everybody's going to accept it exactly
as they believe in instead of changing
it and saying this is when the united
states really defeated them i know
because when the battalion-sized forces
attacked i was in a squad of six men
laying on the ground between the
attackers and our own parameter saw them
die
all right sir thank you flushing new
york go ahead please all right uh brian
yeah first of all i want to say thank
you so much uh
for a tremendous
you know a beautiful program that i
watched last night with katie kelly
uh this is so beautiful it touched every
moment
of
my heart last night and
i was in vietnam before well i was in
vietnam a few months ago you were yes
doing what
uh just visit my family and i hope that
you'll be able to watch the video tip of
my family reunion this is
very emotional um did you did you uh
bring it back with you
yes i i i have it with me right now yes
oh interesting and and and when did when
did you leave vietnam originally in 1980
and how did you leave i uh skipped my
boat and um this was a a very incredible
night
uh about four o'clock in the morning my
mom woke me up and said ty
you have to go honey
and at that time i was only 13 years old
you're how old
15 years old at times 15 years old
and and your your mother knew that you
were going to leave
yes
and then you know
when i got back there she's not there
anymore you know and it's just
incredible for me to take
and
you know
as i you know grew up in the state and
be able to get a solid education
and
you know
i uh
you know i'm so proud to be american but
at the same time i
i i've missed a topic from home when you
went back did you say that your mother
was not there when you went back she
died already yes
you know
she went to a prison camp for you know
arranging my escape from vietnam and she
was captured and during her stay in the
prison camp
her diabetes you know blossomed from
their hands she couldn't take it anymore
she died a year after that who else is
here with you anybody else from the
family yes i have my one my older
brother but
you know he's
you know he's uh
he doesn't go to school and you know he
has to work to make money what are you
doing for a living
me i'm a lecturer for mathematics and
economics in the city university of new
york
and
i
you know
to be honest uh right after my
bachelor in mathematics and economics i
send out my application
to
intend to devote myself to many
humanitarian purposes
but i think
they send back to me
many letters and say that you are over
or qualified for
these jobs and
you know um last night
i saw katy kelly which is the person i
intend to talk to many many times but i
couldn't reach her in new york
because she touched to you know
many kids live in ho chi minh city
especially those uh admiration have you
read her book
uh no i have not i took it back from
vietnam a few days ago
uh but uh unless i watched your program
before i left vietnam in
april about the issue of mia and pow but
also
a tremendous issue that i want to talk
about you know i really want to have a
time to sit down and talk with you
because these things are so beautiful
and and so touching you know as a human
being and want to be able to understand
what this war is all about
all right sir thank you drop me a note
please if you would here at the c-span
offices which are located in washington
and i'd like to hear from you and like
to hear more of what your experience has
been especially your trip back we have a
call waiting from el centro california
go ahead please
hello hi you're on the air how are you
doing good my name is jim stewart from
el centro and i was in vietnam from
1966
to 1970. are you the same jim stewart
that uh
the gentleman at the transit center
yesterday was talking about yes i am you
think that's your son yes i do you
really do i really do um in 1970 there
was a
a young man a young boy born to me and
when he came on the air and said that it
was jim stewart
my wife just sort of stood up and she
knows about my search and said did you
hear what he just said and i i was
flabbergasted i mean my legs got rubbery
but the comment i want to make
is
i haven't had much success in dealing
with the search through the american
government system
and if it wasn't for people
private individuals like katie kelly
and judy lizinski and and some other
people i could name it would almost be a
fruitless
search
i also have two daughters i was a
civilian there for two years and i was
there two years in the military police
were your daughters
i do i don't know
katie kelly was gracious enough to go
back to vietnam with pictures and
photographs and things like that and and
and try to help me but the comment i
want to make is yesterday i did get a
chance to talk to mr fleming and i don't
i don't mean any disrespect but just
talking to him briefly over the
telephone
the comments i got from him were
well you know there are a lot of jim
stewart's and the boy didn't look
admiration
and i the last thing he said to me is i
don't know what i can do for you
and i i sort of felt a little frustrated
that here's a man sitting in washington
who
supposedly is there to help and all i
wanted to say without people like katie
kelly
you know i wouldn't be able to to do
anything what do you plan to do about
this you have a way to follow up with
the this of course this when we took
those pictures was back in april right i
called katie last night and left a
message on her answering machine because
i do have correspondence and things from
him and i have other private uh
individuals who who have gone back and
are looking i'm also working with the
admiration center out of garden grove
california and i went up there and
worked with the children
well they're not children anymore i
shouldn't say that
with with the young adults showing them
pictures of pre-communist vietnam
and things that they never
got to enjoy
because in 1975 they were all very very
young and didn't remember pre-communism
so i have worked with her what is uh
this i'm sure a sensitive thing what
does your wife today think about you
looking for these kids uh she's she's
very supportive she's uh
completely understanding and and you
know without her backing me up you know
i wouldn't even do it are you gonna what
attempts are you gonna make to try to
find the young man jim stewart
well you know right now my legs are
still rubbery as a matter of fact i
watched the show again last night it was
on later in the evening and i couldn't
get my vcr to work to tape it because i
wanted to take this photograph but my
legs are still rubbery because i
with the boy i never had any thought
that there would ever be uh
i could ever find him and all of a
sudden i may be looking at him and i do
see a little bit
of him in me uh
maybe it's just the fact that he said
the name jim stewart in 1970 he's 22
years old uh it runs in the stewart
family that we all needed glasses when
we were very young and he has glasses
the interesting thing was that when we
ran this back over the memorial day
weekend there was another fellow in
indiana that thought that that also was
his son but the stewart name didn't
track so it didn't work out that time
yeah well it it like i say it could it
could could not be but just when the
fact that he said jim stewart and the uh
the other i think it was you was that
you that was interviewing it was and you
said jim stewart also i went oh my god
this this can't be let me make a
suggestion if we can help you give us a
call at our main number which is
202-737-3220
and ask for
uh either jim mills our producer who is
busy and tied up at the moment and i
talked to him yesterday briefly okay and
we'll try to get a picture for you
some way or another so that you can
check it out sure okay thanks i'm sorry
i thought he was finished i'm thanks a
lot jim stewart for calling hannibal
missouri thanks for waiting go ahead
please yes good morning brian morning
i'd like to thank you for your program i
listen to you every day and i really
thank a lot of the show
what i'm concerned with is a powmia
issue
and i'm wondering when uh senator mccann
and the rest of the committee will be
looking under the tomb of ho chi minh
because i'm one that firmly believes
that the vietnamese has
our men under the tomb or in some kind
of cave or tunnel okay thanks for the
question we'll ask him john kerry later
today or francis winig because i know we
were there at ho chi minh mausoleum and
walked all around it and then the grass
hut and i mean the house on stilts and
all that stuff so it's a good question
and there have been stories on that in
the last couple months
we'll come back in just a moment we want
to back during that memorial day weekend
we had a response line that you could
call we took a lot of calls some 3000
during that weekend and we want to play
back to you some of the things that you
said when you watched this special back
then
i'm having a difficult time
understanding how these vietnam vets can
forgive our government
for what they did to them
during before and after the war
yes i'm a vietnam veteran i'd like to
know why we are not prosecuting
the
government leaders who set policy that
left americans behind
after 1973
why are we not asking
about these people instead of focusing
our attention on the vietnamese
government
we need to look at our own ineptness in
government when senator smith was on
last night he said the covenant now
knows for certain that many men were
left behind in southeast asia after the
war when brian lam interviewed bill bell
he quoted him second hand saying he
knows the vietnamese are holding live
americans he just doesn't know where
they're being hidden these men are
hostages or if they're dead they were
hostages when iran was holding our
embassy personnel hostage nobody
suggested we disregard those hostages
because there's a lot of money to be
made in iranian oil
well i think the accounting should be
with uh people like mr sullivan and mr
kessinger and mr nixon
and mr rockefeller
uh who
were the great proponents of the vietnam
war
and uh all this hoopla that they're
putting out now is a bunch of crap
as you can see there are a lot of
varying opinions on this strongly held
opinions and we're going to air as many
as we can as the week goes on you were
watching some video by the way in the
streets of hanoi back in april let's
take a call before we get a couple
before we go to senator john mccain's
story about his experiences at pow
greensboro north carolina go ahead
please yes sir
sir i have a question to
senator mccain and everybody
i wholly sympathize
with
the families of american
mis and pows
and support all the efforts of this
committee
to locate them or they remain
however
i have one question
since
1945
president harry truman
helped the french imperialist
to go back and reconquer the colonies of
indochina
why did
the world's strongest democracy
helped the french imperialist
against ho chi minh
who was trying to gain independence for
his country all right thank you for the
call berkeley california go ahead please
okay
my name is fubui from berkeley
california
uh i think suspension include the uh the
issues of human rights in vietnam and
the political prisoners there are
hundreds of them still being detained by
the vietnamese communists especially
like dr nankwei professor danville
and a lot of
religious leaders like father chanting
further attending to
buddhist monk like
and many more are you are you vietnamese
yes i'm vietnamese are you american now
yeah i'm america now how long have you
been in this country i've been here
since 1975. and are you still in touch
with people over there that tell you
about the political prisoners that the
communist government are holding now yes
actually i'm the member of the editorial
board staff of the indochina journal
we issues every three months and a lot
of the writings and documents about
puerto business in vietnam
how bad is it now compared to the way it
was 15 years ago
do you mean 15 years ago in other words
it's a lot better because the hanoi
already released the people uh the
former
military men and uh officers and
officers of the south vietnamese
government but we still believe that
there are hundreds of them still in the
camp without a trial or without having a
fair
trial what is your sense about the on
the mia pow issue do you think there are
any living americans who are still over
there is missing in action i think so i
i think still i know still uh holding
some people there try to get some ransom
from the us government thank you for
your call sir augusta georgia this is
probably our last call maybe we have
time for one more after this one go
ahead yes i'm calling from augusta
georgia how are you doing today i'm fine
how are you i'm fine i am the daughter
of a prisoner of war missing in action
still serving in southeast asia who has
been unaccounted for for some 27 years
our family and a lot of other people
that we deal with on a day-to-day basis
also believe that we did leave men alive
in 74 in southeast asia we are very
appreciative to the select senate
committee for what they are doing in the
investigation work in c-span when they
show it on tv
uh most of the family's feelings is that
we should not normalize relationships
with vietnam until we have a full
accounting for all of our men no matter
what the case i firmly believe my father
was alive up into 74 and maybe even
later i would like to know the truth
about the matter now as well as many
other families i'm sure would also
we don't get a lot of help with certain
things when we ask questions we're told
that we're still hysterical family
members and that we should let the war
go and this is in the past and it's very
hard to when you're 11 years old and
your father goes missing in a place
called vietnam that you don't even know
anything about so by watching c-span and
seeing vietnam revisited i'm allowed to
explain to my 13-year-old daughter now
what vietnam was a lot about
why we were over there why i feel we
were over there my father was a great
patriarch he loved his country and his
family and he believed what he was doing
was right we hear a lot of people who
say vietnam was wrong
that we didn't belong over there and
that we should give back to vietnam what
they have lost vietnam in turn should
give back to us
the american people what they have lost
all right augusta thanks a lot for the
call
we've got some videotape that we shot
over there in april showing what the u.s
embassy in
saigon looks like today as we take our
last call for this segment from
jacksonville north carolina go ahead
please uh yes i'm retired marine gunnery
sergeant richard ray and i was in
vietnam from 66 through 69.
and i would like to say a couple things
first off we that fought there didn't
lose that words the politicians on
capitol hill that lost it and we've seen
a result of that loss for the past 17
years
and secondly
on the
powmi issue which is very emotional and
i've read a lot about it including just
boys goodbye which came out a year or
two ago uh it's disgusting and
dispiriting to see what the government
has done with respect to those people
who have been left behind and i kind of
can honestly
see how senator mccain has revisited the
hanoi hilton
can look those people in the face after
what they did to him and his fellow
servicemen it's just hard to believe
that he could do something like that all
right jacksonville north carolina thank
you for your call and later on in a few
minutes probably about 55 minutes chuck
williams and bill roland will be here
they are both
pows from world war ii and you're
looking through the front gate
those of you who were there during that
time
are seeing the front gate of the u.s
embassy and there's one of the guards on
the street
right in front of the embassy which was
stormed back during ted of 1968 where
five marines were killed that's a shot
from
down the street a bit looking back and
the helipad is on the top of that
building that
we've seen many times in pictures
thanks for joining us for this vietnam
revisit it'll continue for the next five
and a half hours today and through the
next three days beyond wednesday
thursday and friday but for the moment
taped last april i'm sorry last may
right before the memorial day is here's
senator john mccain talking about his
experience as a pow in vietnam during
the war
october 1967
on the lake of chukbak
the people
and the
civil militia arrested a major american
major john mccain
who was shot down with the american
planes a4 b-1
it was shut down near the electricity
near the power plant in
during the day 10 american
planes were shut down
during the same day
john again when he came here
he erected this monument
[Music]
that is a
picture from hanoi and the voices of mr
hung who was a c-span minder while we
were there the whole
uh four days in hanoi but that is a
monument to john mccain or on behalf of
john mccain but john mccain's here with
us you tell us what is that what are we
looking at i've never understood that
brian and i visited it when i went to uh
hanoi sometime in the 70s i think around
the middle 70s that was built and i'm
not
sure exactly why
but i have gone to visit it and
they
of course there's a few mistakes there
like usaf i was in the navy
and they called me a major and i was
lieutenant commander but
why they erected it and what significant
it has to them i have never really quite
figured out i complained a couple times
when i heard that the grass was
overgrown and there might have been some
bird droppings
around it and
and they thought i was serious so i
didn't complain anymore were you shot
down right around that lake i went down
right in that lake and as he mentioned
the thermal power plant the electricity
plant we were bombing and i was hit
right over the target in fact i was in
the dive so when i ejected i landed
right in that lake and
that's obviously why they they put it up
there and as you know i was badly
injured and
they swam out and pulled me in and
i can tell you the natives were less
than friendly
upon my arrival because and
understandably so we had just finished
bombing their their city you know i
don't hold any grudge against them
because of that but
sometime in the 70s they built that that
particular
memorial and
frankly i'm very glad to say i don't
have any other memorials anywhere else
how many times have you been back there
just twice i went back once in 1985 with
walter cronkite and cbs film crew
on the 10th anniversary of the fall of
saigon i was there for like two days and
then last march phil graham and i
march a year ago
phil graham and i went back for a few
days and we visited it
again and
we also went down to saigon everybody
calls it saigon as you know from vienna
is it hard to go back no
no
you know
brian it was a long time ago
i
have many vietnamese friends who
who were on the other side in other
words on our side there's no reason for
me to hold a grudge or anger there's
certainly some individual vietnamese
some of the guards that were very cruel
and inflicted a lot of pain on me and
others but
there's no sense in me hating vietnamese
when as you know from and all of us know
who visited vietnam the vietnamese
people are very basically
decent gentle people you know and
a victim throughout history
partially due to geography of oppression
and
wars that have gone on for a couple of
thousand years either or being occupied
by another country such as the chinese
and then the french japanese french then
of course so
i hold no ill will towards them i don't
admire the communist system i don't like
it i think they are going to fall sooner
or later just as you know the rest of
communism is falling throughout the
world
but overall i hold no personal grudges
let's go over some of the just the
statistics statistics uh you were
in the navy for how many years uh total
of 22 years from when to win from 19 i
graduated from naval academy in 1958 and
i left the navy in early 1981. when did
the plane go down
october 26 1967 i was hit by a
surface-to-air missile over the city of
hanoi as i mentioned we were bombing
thermal power plants the first time we
had
bombed a target inside of hanoi and
as many of our listener viewers will
remember
they were very heavily defended the city
of hanoi they had rings of
surface-to-air missiles i counted eight
surfaced air missiles in the air headed
roughly in my direction and one of them
one of them hit me how badly were you
injured
broke uh both arms and my leg on
ejection because i was in the dive when
i was hit by the surface-to-air missile
and then
when i was pulled out my shoulder was
badly damaged by a rifle bud and i was
banned at it a couple of times as i
mentioned they were quite
quite restless fortunately for me that
the army came up and picked me up put me
in a truck and took me it was a very it
was a five minute ride to the prison and
when i say that that's another example
of waste of the taxpayers dollars i'd
gone to four different escape and
evasion schools and here i was shot down
the center of hanoi in a five-minute
ride to the prison so
it was all that training went uh was for
naught again how many years were you in
the five and a half years and how many
years and how many different prisons
i was
in three different prisons one was the
uh that we called the plantation that
that you have are taking have taken
films of and the other was the old
french prison which we're also i think
we're going to see
later on called wallow which means in
english rough translation furnace of
fire i understand which was built by the
french in 1943 and that's a real prison
and then we were taken out to a
punishment camp for about nine months
in 1970
because we had uh
had uh
we actually want to have church services
in the vietnamese to take about 24 of us
then we were taken back and
again back to wallow prison where i
stayed until we were released and
remember that in 1969 and 70
particularly in 1970 the treatment of
the vietnamese of the prisoners changed
dramatically and we could there's a lot
of theories as to why but we went from
basically solitary confinement or two or
three to a cell to large sales of 45 or
50 in each it was a dramatic and by the
way wonderful change in the treatment
how many prisoners of war are there in
the united states congress and there is
none in the senate there are two others
in the house pete peterson and sam
johnson sam johnson from texas pete
peterson from florida did you know
either one very well both yep by sam
johnson much better than pete peterson
but i knew them near them both yes is
sam johnson i mean pete peterson's a
democrat yes and sam johnson republican
is there anything about being in prison
that makes you a republican or a
democrat
i i think that um
that there was some resentment back in
1968 when lyndon johnson stopped the
bombing
we assumed that there would be some
accommodation made for the pows because
you know we were up there bombing were
captured then he stopped the bombing and
uh there was resentment about that uh
and also i think there was
in the 1971 72 period there was
much more encouragement and help to the
families by the nixon administration
than there had been before now we could
go into the reasons for that but there
was clearly more
help for the families at that time so
i but also as you know uh military
people have a tendency to be more
conservative
we have a map here
and this map shows indochina and uh and
vietnam of course just so we can get a
rough overview of where you where were
they where was the carrier that you were
flying from here we were actually we
were further north than that we would be
most very not too far from high funk and
you see haifang there are sure it's
right in there we would stay up fairly
close in fact some of our raids uh
bombing missions we would go on
would be 45-minute missions take off
from the ship 15 minutes to the shore
but drop in and return so because there
was really no real threat to the ships
out in the tunkin gulf we sometimes
stayed fairly close to the north
vietnamese coast i want to show the
audience too so for perspective where
this is if you go right up here you're
talking about being in china right there
and right in there and you come down and
you're into the north vietnam or the
hanoi area high phone being right there
and then on the other side of course is
laos yes and if you move over to
thailand thailand right here you'll see
that the air force bases were up near
the vietnamese border
yes and
places like uh eudorn and
ubon some others and
the air force would fly out of those
bases into and also some from south
vietnam into hanoi and haifang and you
can see that they were very long
missions that the air force had to fly
as compared with ours where the ships
would be right right off the coast and
for a long time during the war vietnam
was basically divided in a line north
south basically about through hanoi and
the air force had the responsibility for
those to the
on the thailand side on the western side
and the navy
a lot on the eastern side although later
in the war we went on coordinated
strikes with the air force 17th parallel
about right there yes which meant that
this was north and this was south yes
we've got some videotape uh senator
mccain of a b-52 christ site that has
kind of become a mini tourist area over
in hanoi not many americans have been
there have you been there by the way
this is the neighborhood i have not been
there i've seen pictures of it before
remember that the b-52s did not fly
north until the christmas bombing of
1972 and there were
a number of b-52s i think 10 or 12 that
were shot down
during that christmas period but it was
an incredible display of firepower and
basically had taken out the vietnamese
ability to defend themselves at least as
far as airstrikes are concerned we show
this because we wanted to show you the
neighborhood and you see pictures of
this from time to time this is a day in
april that was about 100 degrees
and this in the middle of that swamp
there with houses around it is
wreckage from a b-52
that they
as a matter of fact you've got to pay a
little money to get back down
right
it's a free enterprise system at work uh
yeah
take a little car back in this area but
they let us shoot this it didn't cost
much i can tell you that
any reaction when you see a
chunk of american b-52 well
not particularly except to hope that the
crew obviously would had gotten out
and
also i must say that
you could make an argument that the
b-52s were not used correctly during the
vietnam war they bombed the jungles and
the ho chi minh trail whereas once they
were sent north they had a devastating
effect brian i mean they just literally
took out the the air defenses of of
north vietnam where we had been using
tactical air not totally very
successfully in the past b-52 is
is an awesome weapon
of war and i noted with some interest
that
that some of them were used even the
persian gulf effort and what was the
difference in the size of your plane say
in the size of this plane
i think uh of course it was like 1 50th
the size but perhaps more importantly
than that the bomb load
of a a4 that i was flying was generally
about seven or eight bombs and of course
i don't know how many hundreds go come
off of a b-52 the firepower that a b-52
could bring to bear is very impressive
and the first few nights it was very
dangerous for the b-52s until they took
out the air defenses a number of them
were shot down as you know this is in
the middle of hanoi if you've just
joined us our guest is senator john
mccain republican of arizona who was a
prisoner of war for five and a half
years we're going to show some videotape
in a moment from the prison cell where
actually two of the three places where
he was located while he was there
and this is in um
a neighborhood that's fairly easy to get
to but i i guess one of the things that
people want to know is if we actually
build bomb civilians during the war you
know we didn't brian and it's coming up
more and more that we did not there was
a famous incident of a so-called back my
hospital which was a hospital in hanoi
which supposedly struck with all these
casualties and it turned out that was
not the case there was precision bombing
and the civilian casualties were minimal
and the vietnamese will even admit that
now but at the same time i we've got
i've got to add that whenever you're in
a war civilians are going to be hurt if
civilians were not injured and there
were civilian casualties war would be a
much more attractive kind of a business
and so
uh the the casualties were minimal but
unfortunately innocent civilians were
killed you have any idea how much this
b-52 cost i know and they've been in
session they've been in service for how
long
you know they've been in since the 50s
and they have turned out to be an
incredible workhorse because they were
originally designed to a large degree as
a strategic bombers you know to carry
just nuclear weapons and they turned
into a conventional
carrier
i do not know the cost but i would say
to duplicate something like you know
that which is the b2
you're talking about a billion dollars a
copy i think that the b2
b-52 was a very worthwhile investment
and i have great admiration for the
crews that flew the b-52s because you
know they flew straight and level and
dependent on their electronic
countermeasures whereas at least in a
tactical airplane you can
dodge that's a plaque by the way on the
wall there you can see right down there
the lower left hand corner where it says
52 which
fairly obvious what it is that's a
plaque on the wall right near the site
where you can go and tourists can go in
hanoi they seem to ignore us when we
were there uh didn't seem to pay much
attention to us didn't we were not in
at least in this area an oddity although
we saw no other
tourist that came to this area are you
surprised that they would keep something
like this would we do the same thing
here
i don't think we would uh but i think at
least for a period of time they wanted
to have those visible symbols of their
victory particularly you know this
picture is kind of interesting look at
how terrible those conditions are and
the problem
the problem in vietnam today as you know
is that they've made these enormous
sacrifices and yet nothing has come of
it and that's
that's a bitter bitter pill for the
people of vietnam to swallow why do you
think they've not been able to do better
their system as you know their system
of socialism of central government
control of the economy etc and as you we
may get into later on or at least at
some other program the
the economy of saigon or ho chi minh
city but everybody calls it second is
much more thriving as you know because
there is capitalism and free enterprise
and now even in north vietnam it's it's
improving a little bit because they have
loosened
the controls but their system is such
like any other socialist country
communist country they can't improve
unless they allow the free enterprise
system to to function and as you know
the people that still run north vietnam
are the old ho chi minh 70 80s
80 year old generation who even the
though even they recognize they've got a
change
you said that you were mistreated
yes uh is that endemic to the south
vietnamese people i mean the vietnamese
people not the south vietnamese nor
vietnamese people or
what the vietnamese used viewed us
understandably as an enemy they viewed
us as they call us air pirates we had
bombed their cities towns etc and they
believed that and i understand why they
believe that as you know they're
very
naive people
and i understand why they would dislike
us and i would understand even why they
would mistreat a captured pilot to get
military information the resentment that
i hold towards the vietnamese at least
those individuals was when they
attempted as they did for years to
exploit us for propaganda reasons those
are that's not uh it's not in keeping
with the geneva conventions and
frankly
they were trying to use us as an
extension of the battlefield
because they knew very well that
militarily they would never prevail but
they could prevail as ho chi minh said
in the streets of washington dc detroit
chicago and san francisco so
most of the mistreatment was to make
tapes to confess crimes uh et cetera et
cetera
you're senator john s mccain iii yes
yes
this is a leading question because i
know i you know i know you knew your
father because when i was in the navy
was the first admiral i ever met when i
was in
the basic class at little creek in
virginia going into the navy uh he was
john s mccain jr who was he and what
role did he play in this war with you
you know you ended over in prison
both my father and grandfather were navy
admirals in fact it's my information
there the first father and son who were
both four-star admirals in the navy
my fa my grandfather was early naval
aviator and was the commander of the
carriers in the pacific under admiral
halsey in world war ii my father was a
submarine officer during world war ii
and worked and was promoted and was the
commander-in-chief in the pacific during
the vietnam war during the time that i
was in prison which was
as you can understand a very difficult
period for him much more difficult in my
view on him than it was on me and what
year did he die he died in 1980.
did he see you elected to the united
states senate he did not did he know you
were going to run no
he did not and before you know you said
you spent what 21 22 years in the navy
yes you got out at what rank at as a
captain and what was your last job in
the navy i was the navy liaison officer
to the senate
have anything to do with getting
interested in being one of them yes
exactly it did it got i was it
made me very interested in political
life not because i found that
particularly attractive but it's
certainly when i saw
what a person can achieve as a member of
congress i it became very attractive to
me again if you've just joined us we're
continuing our
many hour special vietnam revisited our
guest is senator john s mccain iii
and he is here to talk about his
experience five and a half years as a
prisoner of war during the vietnam war
and we now have some video that will
take us we just drove around
what is called i guess are they all
called hanoi hiltons you know the the
the media called them all hanoi hilton
the we had different names for them the
plantation
uh was one the hilton we knew of was the
old french prison which i think we're
going to see later on
and there was another large prison also
but we gave the only one we called the
hilton itself specifically was the old
french prison the one we're driving
around now we called the plantation
all right this is a complete around the
block of a prison that the plantation
that's inside of all this does this look
familiar to you the outside does not
because i never saw it from the outside
uh whenever we were taken someplace we
were always blindfolded and
handcuffed and
taken at night so i never saw the
outside
when you went back there in 1985 with
walter cronkite what was the purpose uh
they asked me because it was uh the 10th
anniversary of the fall of saigon sort
of a review of the whole us involvement
and i must tell you it was a great
thrill for me to spend time with a man
like walter cronkite who is an
incredible
individual i don't have to tell you how
knowledgeable he is and what a fine man
he
and how long again were you inside this
prison
well this particular prison i was there
about two
two and a half years what's your
strongest memory of this one
i think my strongest memory is
is the heat
when i think about all of the all of the
parts of it if starting in about march
or april it get very hot
in hanoi as you noticed when you were
there
and
our rooms were not ventilated all of the
windows and everything were blocked off
because they didn't want us to see each
other they kept us isolated and it used
to get incredibly hot in those rooms and
of course we didn't have any hygiene or
anything you get oils you get dysentery
you get it would be a very difficult
period from then until the rains would
start which would usually be sometime
around july or august
now when you went back this time to
remember when you went back in 85 did
you go back to this prison
yes i did go back to this prison i tried
to go to wallow prison the one we're
going to see later on but that's still
being used as a prison
i think we couldn't get it yeah that is
a that is a real prison that you know
there were stocks on the on the on the
wooden beds there were you know that
that was a the french i don't know how
the french did architecturally in other
ways but they built a pretty good prison
did you hear much of this noise that
we're hearing now when you were inside
the prison we used to hear a lot of
noise outside in the street yes and
there's also a railroad that runs by
next to the prison or we i don't know if
we're going to see that or not someone
said in some articles somewhere that uh
they were anxious to go back here so
that they could find out what noises
they were hearing every day and they
found out that some of them belonged to
the vendors of the different products
that would come along and it was there
it was kind of like their uh what's the
uh
oh they the creamsicle people this type
of popsicle yeah
the bells are ringing yeah yeah yeah i
remember the hearing those two
the good humor man
and what they did was uh uh
when the first americans were shot down
they kept them all in the old french
prison i was talking about wallow then
as the prison population increased then
they branched out into basically two
others this one that we're about to see
and one other
that they kept the the pilots in
uh they brought people were here with
you in that camp there was about
50 to 60 people
for some reasons we never understood
very well the vietnamese would move us
around from time to time and we never
understood the rhyme
or reason for for why they did that did
they feed you uh generally speaking it
was soup and a piece of bread uh three
kinds of soup four months each and a
piece of bread again in the last year
and a year and a half the food improved
significantly
again as part of this change in
treatment
and none of us have quite understood
except
for a combination of things including
international pressures to treat us uh
better and the efforts of millions of
americans on our behalf you were there
in 1985 what other time have you been
back
a year ago last april yes and that would
have been april of 1991 1991 are you you
are a member of the select committee on
powmmi affairs yes
are you one that believes are still mias
or pows living in vietnam
i assume that there's americans alive
until we have as full accounting as
possible we have still not got that full
accounting but brian i have not yet seen
hard evidence that there's americans
alive and i am somewhat pleased at the
progress that has been made in the last
six months to a year what are the
politics of it who are those most
anxious to lift the embargo and those
who don't want to lift business in
america is very interested in having the
embargo lifted
the those that are opposed to it are
those that feel that the vietnamese have
still not been totally forthcoming in
their efforts to resolve the m.i.a.p.o.w
issue
that i think it is generally agreed that
the vietnamese have complied with our
demands that they move forward with the
peace process in cambodia as well as
their withdrawal but i think the mia pow
issue still remains a very significant
issue to many many americans would you
have been elected to the united states
senate had you not gone through all this
i don't know the answer to that
i think that
clearly my service gave me some
advantage
at the same time many many former
military and many former pows have have
run for office i think the american
people express their gratitude for past
service but i think most of them elect
their pop their elected officials on
what they think they're going to do for
them in the future so i think it i think
it helped but i don't think i think it
helped me frankly being elected the
house i don't think it had that much
effect on on my election
were you in a cell with anyone else and
this one we're going to see right now i
was by myself in the cell could you talk
to anyone
no but i tapped on i could tap on the
walls and also the one next door to me
on one side one side was empty there's
that we developed a method of talking by
putting a cup against the wall and
wrapping it in a shirt we could talk to
each other yes who is nexting the guy
named bob crainer who was was now
deceased who was a air force major later
colonel wonderful most wonderful man
i've ever known
he's the most wonderful guy i've ever
known they're talking to you on the
beeper
let's uh we've got a lot more to talk
about i hope we have some time
because this is being taped for the
audience that wonders why
here over a holiday weekend uh let's
look at it's about nine minutes and 43
seconds long you're going to see a
gentleman by the name of famwa who is a
head of the uh this is a film studio he
says and you'll see this there was a
film studio before and a film studio
afterward he agreed to allow us to go to
your prison cell if we would watch a
film
after it was over and you can you know
he wouldn't let us
tape the film
said we had to pay for it but the film
was i suspect
we did sit and watch the film was 30
minutes long and it was black and white
film of the
probably best way to describe it of how
the vietnamese have been so helpful in
letting americans come into the country
dig up remains and try to get to the
bottom of this would you agree with that
that basic message
i think in the last six months to a year
they have been helpful maybe not as
helpful as they could be but much more
helpful than they have in the past and a
particular signal event was a setting up
of an office in hanoi staffed by
americans
and
allow americans to go any place in the
country and look where they want to
that's been a significant change but the
issue is still not resolved by the way
when do you think that the embargo will
be lifted
i would think if progress continues in
the way that it has that you could see
it sometime after the elections but i
think there's a lot of things that could
be need to be resolved yeah particularly
in the money power which nationally
recognized group is the loudest opposed
to it in the veterans groups
there are various organizations as you
know
some that are more quote
mainstream such as the national league
of families and then there's others that
are
what were viewed by some as as splinter
groups i think those that are the
less mainstream were very reluctant i
think the league of families has a
position that they are opposed until
there's a full accounting and they have
to have great credibility and i believe
they have great credibility but there
has been as i say there's been a great
deal of progress we should thank the
vietnamese for that although we still
have not gotten the full cooperation
that we need particularly in the area in
my view of laotian
the where the laos problem is as you
know there were hundreds who went down
in laos and very few ever returned
as a way of explanation when c-span went
to
hanoi uh we asked we had a what we call
a minder or handler or a guide you can
call whatever you want to provided by
the government his name was mr hung
you'll see him in this video and we
asked the minute we got there if we
could go to the prison where senator
mccain was held and they said we'll get
you there one way or the other we didn't
know quite when we were going to go
there it wasn't a great mystery but uh
one afternoon he said it's time to go
and we had plenty of time to do it what
you're going to see is haphazard ad hoc
we walked in
sat down visited with the
actually i don't remember the
gentleman's rank but he was he's in the
army and uh we our cameraman was greg
gursky and we took off into prison 29
and then at the end i hope it's with
this you'll hear
we i wanted to go up on the corner of
the prisons just to listen for a while
to see what you could hear and we'll see
if that's there because we haven't
talked to our producer whether that made
it or not this is about nine minutes
long and if you don't mind watching
we'll come back and get your reaction to
it
so
the section over there
is newly built
from from the car
you know forward is newly born newly
built and from this from the tail of the
car
backward there to the to the boat
is intact so these were cells right here
this install storage of uh film stereo
we
store our films in this
yeah
over there the screen
and i observe
the the life the the the daily life of
american pilots from this position i
stay there and observe
[Music]
the behavior of americans were the
american
[Music]
there was no this
this house that building wasn't there
right there
this is a courtyard in flower plants
and in the middle of the
courtyard there is a shelter
when american planes uh were approaching
hovering on the sky so all american
pilots you know uh went down to the
shelter bomb center for americans pilots
so there's a shelter underneath
in the middle in the middle
all right
these trees
were on the top of the bomb center and
we moved it over there
it wasn't good
oh
was being kept how long you know
because i was not in charge of american
pilot prisoners
was he here by himself
[Music]
this is this was during german john
against time here
[Music]
just for one person uh
shelter if they could not you know
manage to go there
uh to go down to the bomb center
you know there was a shelter underneath
there uh what is this room used for now
just working twice
later
these guys were not here
no uh over
it was other doors not this one
we also
were receiving mr john mccain in the
same room where i uh i i have the
receptive
when we just talk
oh there is the kitchen
for cooking food for americans where's
the kitchen
[Music]
this is also sales for american pilots
let's go to the kitchen
this is kitchen
and there is another section of the
kitchen over there
[Music]
second
another section was destroyed
oh there's the water reservoir
oh
[Music]
we go to the place where americans
pilots
watch
watching places
for americans pilots
program
here
[Music]
you're coming here
[Music]
may i
edit a bit
beyond that
first of all the windows were all
bricked over so the only ventilation
came from some small holes near the top
so when he said that that window had
been there with the bars on it that was
not true
it had been there with the bars on it
but they had just bricked it over put it
put bricks uh on it because they didn't
because they kept us isolated and they
didn't want us to see or communicate
with each other uh second of all there
was never any bomb shelter that i saw
during the two and a half two two and a
half years i was in that prison nor did
we ever
go to any bomb shelter because then we
would have had to obviously
be together and they didn't want that to
happen
that was true about the bathing area
there was a little
that exactly as you saw it they would
close you in and you had a cup and you
would pour water it could pour water on
yourself
um
we bathed infrequently and part of that
was not because of any cruelty but there
was a very erratic supply of water
particularly in the summertime when
they're
they just didn't have water
in the city
the large house you saw in the
background a couple of times would look
like a large building we call the big
house and that's where we would be
taking four interrogations up to that
area by and they had several rooms so
that they could interrogate uh
more than one prisoner at the same time
and the that area that you saw where the
trucks were under that was not there was
a
when we were there was a central
courtyard there was dirt basically
wasn't uh over but the rest of it was
was fairly uh was fairly accurate
depiction the
mr uh fomo suggested that you all got
together out there in the courtyard we
never got together in the courtyard i
remember i remember one time it was
christmas day and i think it was maybe
1968 christmas day or 69 i'm not i'm not
when they allowed each of us separately
to stand outside of ourselves for about
five minutes it was a wonderful event so
no we didn't spend any time out in the
courtyard together again not so much out
of cruelty but they knew and correctly
you keep people isolated don't let them
organize don't let us exercise our chain
and come in you break down resistance
much easier do you think he's telling
untruths or just doesn't know i think i
think the
combination of both you know they like
to i understand the other prison now
that they they've got flowers all around
it and looks real nice and all that so i
think probably a combination of both but
as he said he was not there it was told
to him by others but it was
it was a little different at least now
how has this changed since you were back
in 85 today by would you go back last
year to your old prison site
no i did not go back
no i did not
last year
that that shed had been built where the
trucks were underneath was about the
only change that i that i saw which
prison had the better conditions
that one clearly because the cells in
wallow the one we're going to see later
on i guess the old french belt prison
were much smaller
much more tightly guarded and we believe
that they kept the people that they
treated as kind of special prisoners so
they kept them in wallow
mine because my father was an admiral
others because they'd attempted to
escape it was it was a i think a tougher
environment back in in the in the real
hilton as we called it over the five and
a half years that we were in three
different prisons in
and around hanoi
how much mail did you get
i received about three letters from my
family one of them
actually two of them
[Music]
no i guess all three when the vietnamese
were offering me release in 1978 68. how
many letters did you send and how many
got back here about
40
to 50 i sent and i think they got about
10.
when did you come back to the united
states 1973 march 1973. did you have a
recuperative period
i i had to go to the hospital and get an
operation actually two operations on my
leg
and uh then i went directly to the
national war college after that here in
washington for those who have just
joined us a couple of quick things again
what were the five and a half years you
were in
the hanoi prisons yes yes i was there
for years uh 1967 1973. why didn't you
get out of the service when you got back
i loved the navy and i was able to get
back on flying status and i was able to
continue flying which by the way took
some
skill to do but after a certain number
of years i failed my flying physical and
so i had to get out
then i
my physical
injuries caught up with me to a large
degree we read so much about the impact
and i've heard a lot about the impact on
the individuals the stress the
post-vietnam stress syndrome that we
keep hearing so much about has that
impacted you at all i've never had a
nightmare i've never had a flashback
i've never had
any particular memories except the ones
that i cherish are the friends that i
made in the wonderful relationships that
we forged together
i hold no bitterness nor anger and
i would attribute part of that to the
fact that i was 29 years old when i was
shot down and captured and i was a
professional military pilot many of the
people that we find that have
difficulties
and have not or either difficulties
readjusting or not readjusted many of
them were the 18 19 year old young
draftees who went and served and frankly
were very badly treated on their return
and my view and not given the welcome
home which we've belatedly given them
after operation desert storm what's the
legacy of vietnam
never again should we go into a conflict
unless we are clear in our goals and we
are prepared to do what is necessary to
win victory as rapidly as possible
i think in retrospect maybe a hundred
years from now it will have been good
for america to define the limits of
power up until that time as you know we
could go anywhere bear any burden in the
world in the words of
of john f kennedy
we understood and i hope we continue to
understand the limits of military use of
military power and
although desert storm was a wonderful
success which we're all proud of we have
to be very very selective where we send
young americans to fight and die we have
a last bit of tape to show you this is
the hualo
prison which is in a different part of
the of the uh
town what do you remember about this
when you look at it well this this
prison that that you're going to see as
i mentioned was built in 1943 by the
french and uh it was well built it has a
lot of cells in it all of them solitary
cells they're small they have many of
them have stocks on the on the wooden
bed
they have small open little doors
peepholes for the guards
to look through
and
i think it would be been a very tough
place to live for us but also for the
vietnamese when the french
had that prison it is still used i am
told as a prison by the by the
vietnamese you're seeing one of the
entrances
uh there i believe uh to the prison
and um there was no exercise area or any
open area like we saw uh in the other
prison
it uh how many were there with you there
was about um
i think there was about 50 or 60 of us
in there at one time and then after they
moved us all into large see this this
you can't tell us too much from the
camera but this uh prison takes uh
covers a very large city block very
large city block part we were in were
where the individual cells are in 1970
and 71 they moved us into large
cells with 40 or 50 each which was in
another part of the prison
and
it as i say the the large cells were
quite nice as compared with the with the
small ones
at least
we were there on a couple different days
i remember one day when i was there
and don't have the tape right now but uh
standing
looking at the prison there aren't many
cars in hanoi all of a sudden a 27 car
procession came by with the prime
minister of malaysia
he had a 200 person delegation in hanoi
all for the purpose of setting up a
trade relation and you saw that the
entire time you were at least i saw a
entire time in vietnam lee kuan yew
former prime minister of singapore was
there also while we were there does it
worry you on the trade side that we may
be waiting too long to lift this embargo
it does worry i mean clearly those
countries especially japan are moving
into those markets and they have shown
that there are fertile markets i mean
the vietnamese are when given the
opportunity look what they've done here
in america are very industrious
productive people as long as they don't
have this
communist doctrine guiding them
at the same time
i think we have to face reality and that
is the american people are not prepared
to extend that to the vietnamese until
there is a full accounting as possible
of those who are still listed as missing
in action i'd also point out that
uh it's a very very poor country and
there's not an instant market there it's
one of the lowest per capita incomes in
the world so when we talk about all this
this market there a lot of it is there
in the form of natural resources as you
know there's the belief that there's oil
and gas
there and i think american companies
could take advantage of that
and i also think that
sometimes we cannot just put commercial
interest paramount to all others and
they have to be balanced against a lot
of other
issues that face this country and i
think it's also well to point out one
other fact a lot of americans still
resent the fact that vietnam was the
country that inflicted the first defeat
on this country and we have to get over
that part of it too which i think we are
with the ending of the cold war will you
go back
yes i would go back if it would do some
good you know the reason why i didn't go
back this time with senator kerry and
senator smith was because i had been
there the year before and i didn't see
anything particularly
beneficial to going back this time that
they couldn't do
and the other thing is i always have to
be a little bit careful that the
vietnamese don't try again to somehow
use me to for their own purposes and i
you know you just have to be a little
rather careful to that
but they they are it's interesting how
much they my name is known around
vietnam it's amazing
as you know um anybody can travel there
yes any american although american
travel agents and i'm not sure what the
last couple of weeks has been but you
could you had they have to go through an
australian travel agent or hong kong or
whatever do you recommend to veterans or
even people who have never been there
they go
it's a lovely country there are some
parts of it that are magnificently
beautiful
i think that many of our veterans have
found it to be very therapeutic to
travel back to vietnam i think they have
enormous tourist potential
if they had the right kind of system
again
and i would recommend that people go if
they so choose i think they should
understand one that the conditions are
still not good as far as hygiene and
that kind of thing are concerned is i
think you will attest i think also they
got to understand accommodations are
still very very poor and i think they
also have to understand that the
vietnamese are going to rip them off
every chance they get didn't you notice
that they had their hand out for every
car every driver every uh you know
they're you're kind of at their mercy
because there's no rental car there's no
uh kind of thing and um i must say
though it was it was much more prevalent
in the south than it was in the north
with a handout
and there were fewer hands out
in hanoi than there were in saigon yeah
i think yeah i think that's probably
true so i think you have to understand
that it's that it is really roughing it
uh although as you notice there's a
hotel floating hotel in saigon that the
australians have brought around which i
understand are good accommodations when
i was in south vietnam i stayed at the
old rex hotel which many of our veterans
were recognized was an r r hotel in
saigon and i swear you hadn't changed a
bit they stayed there you know the bar
on top of the roof and all that had not
changed it was like a leap backwards
about 20 years historically
but i don't think there's any doubt that
they will improve and their tourist
facilities will improve
etc and
i've talked to many vietnam veterans who
felt it was one of a great and healing
experience for them to go back i
strongly recommend they do so if if they
feel that that's that's best for them
i've talked to some others that say look
i never want to see the place again all
it does is dredge up
old terrible memories so i think it's up
to the individual i do believe there are
parts of the country as as you noticed
uh ha long bay i believe it is uh
and some others that are really lovely
places but again the accommodations
aren't
aren't much must report to you that in
hanoi there's a new or renovated hotel
called the metropole it was there when
you were there but the french have come
in and renovated it 109
rooms and about 100 a night per room
and it's forty percent on by the french
and sixty percent on with the vietnamese
and i think we would also agree although
it's very run down uh the city of hanoi
is very pretty with the trees and the
old french buildings and all that if
they could spruce it up
get some paints and things that would be
a very pretty old city yeah very
attractive senator mccain we're out of
time thank you for
sharing this your experience with us on
this
special vietnam revisited thank you
brian and could i say on memorial day
it's just
monday a lot of this is going to be
shown we should
appreciate the service and sacrifice not
only those who are still around but
those who are not and we we will always
cherish their memories thank you
chuck williams executive director of the
american ex-prisoners of war
organization when you see
all the attention paid to the vietnam
prisoner of war does that bother you
well i don't think it bothers me i think
it's uh i think it's important that we
keep the issue alive and
and at least this is part of the way of
doing it were you a prisoner of war yes
i was when uh 1944 45 where were you i
was in germany
captured in austria and imprisoned in
germany
what's the big difference from your
experience of talking about this between
being a pow in germany and being a pow
in vietnam
well i was just looking at the film
with senator mccain in it and i remarked
to someone
in the room out there
that
it appeared that they're living in the
quarters
were a lot better than ours
we were in a large barracks
with rooms in it where we'd have
anywhere from 18 to 20
to 23 men
in a room
our box and our bunks were stacked
three high
in the room
and something that looked like a picnic
table in the center of it but that was
our living
accommodations for anywhere from 18 to
22 or
23 men so how old were you then
oh
i was about 22 i guess when i was
captured
bill roland what about you were you a
prisoner of war yes sir where i was in
germany and
it's dog 7a and mooseburg which is uh
right out of munich how long
i was for seven well about seven and a
half months
and what's the difference between i mean
between your experience what say john
mccain had well john mccain was there
for a much much longer time
and i think it's a different
different
ethnic group of people that had john
mccain
i was
captive by the germans
and uh some difference i was an enlisted
man
and and they worked the enlisted men in
germany i worked on the
railroad in munich the winner of 44 and
45 on the railroad these airmen mr
williams group he
bombed out the railroad yards
and uh we would try to get it uh
a a line fixed so they could get through
and by the time we got it done they
would come over in 48 hours and do it
again so the germans were unhappy with
that how did the germans treat you as
people
i think they treated this very well
the camp
well
the time i was in prison
the time was divided by the first half
of the time i was there
the camp was run by the luftwaffe
and they were professional military men
and they treated us that way pretty well
yes we were flyers
not only the prisoners but the people
that were
that were keeping us and
doing the care for us so
there was a certain amount of
not a camaraderie but
there was a relationship there at least
they were flyers and so were we in
did they treat enlisted men differently
than they did officers i i
i don't know how they treated the
officers but we were treated somewhat
different i think they weren't really
too nice to us they
let you know for sure who is in control
and they worked us from daylight to dark
and and with very very little food that
was my biggest problem was food you went
you got up hungry you went to work
hungry you come home hungry you went to
bed hungry
and for
seven months i was hungry so that that
was my biggest problem
how many well before i ask you that the
american ex-prisoners of war
organization
was formed when
it was formed originally in 1940
44 42
originally by two of the
mothers
of men that were on the baton death
march in the bataan in the philippine
islands
they were japanese prisoners when they
were captured
on the 9th of april
and those that were over on corregidor
about a month later on the 6th of may
how long have you been the executive
director
about four years now what were you doing
before that
i had just retired a year or two before
that from treasury i was retired
military and then
went to work for treasury
and did 21 years with treasury and
treasury department yes sir
bill roland what's your job with this
organization well i'm on the legislative
committee and
work out of mr williams's office and we
normally just keep in contact what's
going on on capitol hill and
benefits for
ex-prisoners war and veterans as a whole
of course we're really interested in the
prisoners or the
programs that they uh that they have
and how big is the organization
uh we have i believe thirty thirty two
thousand about thirty two or thirty four
thousand twenty two or thirty four
thousand members and what does it take
to be a member
uh
to be a prisoner and you need to be a
prisoner of war do you have to well what
i i
i
shouldn't i shouldn't guess
can you be a member an associate member
do you have to have been a pow to
support the group
you don't you don't have we don't have
associate members we don't have an
auxiliary like most of the organizations
do
we're the only veterans group to my
knowledge
that admits the wives and the children
of uh prisoners of war as for voting
members so the thirty-two thousand
includes clients including
children yup that's right what's it cost
a year to belong
i have a life membership of
gosh i don't know about 60 65 or 75
dollars i paid but the life membership
i mean
the yearly membership is 20 dollars
if you don't
if you don't have a life membership how
many people work for the organization
very very few we have a headquarters
staff down in texas
there's a secretary a treasurer
who's two part-time help
so that's a total of four there
in
kansas
we
have
the editor of our bullet and our monthly
bulletin
and
a man
working out of that office and he's
part-time i think yes
the editor is full-time
do the pows in your opinion get
what they deserve from the government
well
i think they get a lot from the from the
government but there's numbers of things
that we feel that
that is lacking yet
and we have been trying to
to get congress to do some things
to help them well we have they they
passed a law in 1981
that was supposed to take care of all
the medical
benefits for former prisoner of war
this this did
happen until
i think it's a congress
100-322 bill or something that
was a
budget reconciliation thing and then
they put the the
the
prisoners of war if you were below 50
service connected they put you in a may
category they may take care of you if
they have the money now they have been
taking care of us throughout the uh
uh most of the time throughout the
country we'll have to give the va credit
they've been
i think they've been pretty good in most
all the cases there's so much ladies how
many pows have there been throughout the
last four wars or i don't know if you've
totaled this century yeah about a
hundred and
175
or so thousand total and as i recall how
many are there
still missing in action if you know that
from say world war ii
72 000 roughly 72 000 pows in the world
right no no
in action
they were missing and not recovered and
they've never found them no no never
been 72 000 from world war ii about 8
000 from korea
and still from vietnam to 2200 to 200.
yeah let's take a call i'm sure we'll
hear from some
uh pow expo tamarac florida go ahead
please yeah hi uh my name is george
schumann i am a vietnam vet but not a
pow uh i'm interested in the gentleman's
opinion of jane fonda and her visit to
vietnam during the war and
what charges if any should have been
brought about
thank you
any opinion
well i'm not a lawyer so i can't tell
you what charges should have been
brought
but anybody that
does what i believe jane fonda did from
all reports
i think some charges certainly should
have been brought
and i think that she should have been
stopped from ever doing that sort of
thing again some way
i have no idea how you'd do that but
i think that
i think that that added that
sort of action is a bad
uh is a bad thing
for the people that are prisoners for
the people that are fighting
the war
i'm sure that you as a vietnam veteran
were
gravely upset by her
we had in the second world war we had a
couple of
a couple of people
that did the same sort of thing
we had access our
sally we had
lord haha
and we had tokyo rose as i recall
what was what she was called isn't that
right bill i believe that's right i
believe it was tokyo rose out of tokyo
the other two were out of berlin or out
of germany let's go to louisville
kentucky go ahead please
yeah how you doing this is scott riggle
from louisville kentucky
i'm 29 years old i never i was in the
army for two years but i just want to
ask a couple questions here uh
i watched the movies on tv but did
germans really mistreat their own people
and did the prisoner of wars really get
mistreated like in the movies that's all
i need to know
bill roland you want to try that i don't
know what movies he's talking about
well it's the the biggest mistreatment
they they
the germans was at the end of the war i
was a prisoner for the last seven months
and of course jiren by the time i was
captured
the germans i think had lost the war
and and they were very irritated with
the prisoners at that particular time
and the food was
they run out of food themselves the
germans didn't have food to feed their
own people our guard was eating cheese
and bread and but
they at least had cheese and bread
and
and the mistreatment
when they worked that we worked they
were sure you had to work uh when we
were down on the railroads if you worked
they didn't bother you but as long as
you
if you uh
slocked up a little bit they'd give you
a lot of problems if how much did you
weigh when you were released as a p.o.w
back 100 and i weighed 106 pounds i
weighed 130
i weighed 137 pounds when i was captured
properly captured how much did you weigh
when it was all over
uh in the neighborhood of 110 or 12
pounds
san francisco go ahead please yeah i was
just wondering um how much
contact do you all have with the french
government seeing this how they also had
a similar situation you know
in regards to pow mias i think they had
a little bit more success in bringing
back some of their m.i.a do you all have
any counterparts in france that you talk
about the vietnam situation we know i
don't think we do do with chuck you have
an international group but there isn't
there is an international prisoner of
war group that's headquartered
in new york that has representatives
from about 55 or
56 countries and france is one of them
uh and i'm not really sure of how well
their relationship
works with france of your 32 000 members
how many of them are connected with the
vietnam war
uh
probably not more than
300
anderson indiana go ahead please yes
this is bonnie brown from anderson
indiana and i was wondering
why
is it that reverend john steer from the
vietnam vets association
why was it that when he him and several
other people had gone over to russia
and had talked to russian diplomats
on the number of prisoner of wars that
were in our that were still in vietnam
i'd like to know that why when they got
back to the united states with the vital
information that none of the government
agencies
of the united states uh even bothered to
even go to the press conference
thanks do you have any ideas no
knowledge of that
i i have no id no knowledge really
i know that there have been reported
live sightings there have been a number
of
reports and indications that there are
living
pows still over there brian
and this could very well be what you're
referring to
but
i have no idea
why if there were any living
pows
still being held against their will
why they wouldn't be identified and
brought out
host countries have always
denied the existence
of any living
pows being held against their will at
this time so do you think uh mr owens
your organization think that there are
living pows over in vietnam
well you know this is i'm not sure what
the organization there uh hierarchy says
maybe mr williams can answer that
but there's many people in the
organization feel that there are some
and many people feel that there aren't
any left they're alive today is it a big
issue on capitol hill for you uh it's
not we're not really involved too much
in the in the mias we're we're mostly
involved with the prisoners of war
former prisoners of war that is back
walking around
and with the problems they have and what
we can do for them nazareth pennsylvania
you're next
yeah i had the honor of meeting ralph
gaither who was a
he was in the hanoi hilton and my
husband worked for him at um in warner
springs
at the pow training camp there called
fear
and all i have to say is i have more
respect for that man
and several of the other pows that i
have met al nichols
and a couple of others through my
husband's affiliation with the navy
and i think this is atrocious what this
country is doing and not in not
supporting what these people have done
in many cases they have come close to
almost giving their life
and they're just sort of swept under the
rug and i just want to say that coming
from a very navy family
that i support anyone that dares to say
yes i will support my country i will
give my life for it thank you
do you feel that the country has swept
under the rug the
honor that has deserved the pows
i i don't think that they have ryan
i
feel and have felt for many years
that they probably were not as active
as they should have been
in bringing a resolution to the problem
not only in vietnam but in korea and
second world war
as well
and for that matter we haven't mentioned
world war one but there are still three
thousand
uh as i recall the figure
uh that are attributed to world war one
missing in action that are missing in
action so the the of the wars this
century the vietnam war has the fewest
number of missing that's the fewest
number of missing in action
carlisle illinois you're next
yes sir i want to thank you very much
for the original program
and i want to tell the two gentlemen
there that they don't show any signs or
bitterness towards the german people i
had
a uncle in the marine corps in world war
ii
was a prisoner of japanese and believe
me the bitterness he felt was pretty
strong
i've noticed in the vietnam veterans
group which i belong to couple
there's a lot of decisiveness among the
people uh
the pow mia is such an emotional issue
i've talked with people who just
take the exact opposite sides and it
just seems like they're not willing to
sit down and discuss it
i feel like the vietnam veteran was
short chains from world war ii
i feel like the korean veteran was
i want to thank you very much for the
program and thank you for letting me
call in thank you what's your
what's your most sensitive issue as you
walk around capitol hill
what's the issue that your membership
cares about the most
well uh probably a publicly medical
benefits we have a lot of people with a
lot of problems
and maybe in some
cases compensation for some of the
problems that they have
and and if the va is really
addressing it like they should i think
the va mr dewinsky seems to
really try to get it get everybody to
cooperate
but there's many times time it gets down
to the medical center
it doesn't the things that should happen
doesn't happen mr dewenski the head of
the veterans administration yes yes
secretary dewinski i should have said i
i i think the veterans administration as
a whole has a real interest in the pow
program does the taxpayer or the
government give pows anything other than
medical care is there any kind of a
stipend they get
not not specifically because they were
prisoners of war
there are benefits as you know that are
available to all veterans
in addition to the medical there's
educational
there's your home loan
program and things of that nature that
are
available to the former prisoner of war
as well as other veterans but nothing
that is specifically
uh there for the prisoners of war
bill you're well you do have looking and
so i'm missing no well you do have some
presumptives that the congress passed
and and 97 law 97 87 37
97 37
uh that gave some presumptives that when
the that that if the prisoners were
happen to have some diseases caused by
malnutrition and other things frozen
feet from maybe working in the railroad
yard in germany another thing that they
make that service connected even as this
late date if they can attach it to a
prisoner of war experience so that's
something that
the the ex-prisoners war have that some
other veterans don't yeah of the 32 000
members that you have how many of them
are attached in some way or another the
korean war
that would be a difficult question i
can't answer by far most time of world
war ii by far the majority are world war
ii
most of our people that fought in the
war were world war ii veterans
uh
they were it
any world war one veterans that are
still alive that were plw's oh yes
yeah we've got uh we've got a number of
them as veterans roswell new mexico's
excuse me roswell new mexico go ahead
please uh yes this business of uh weaver
and beaudets up in idaho brings the
subject to mind
weaver apparently wasn't special forces
my husband was in special forces
he served approximately four years in
primarily laos
and
in 1970 he
was home
and he told me about pows that he knew
about being held in caves
and being moved across the border from
vietnam into laos and then at about that
same month in 1970
he went to our local police force and
had his fingerprints done he also went
to a local dentist
and had his dental
x-rays and
things done and he gave these records to
me and said
hold on to them you may need them
someday
and
of course you know in april of 73 that's
when the statement was made that all the
men were out
there was no one left alive over there
they were all dead
in may
may 13th
he and three others
who
also had served in laos with special
forces were all killed dead at the scene
in a car accident
the man who hit them
was said to have been drunk and he was
immediately transferred out to korea
back in 70 my husband also mentioned to
me that there was a price on his head
by the nva
have these two gentlemen ever heard of
anything like this before
of soldiers in covert activities knowing
about something like this and then being
killed
because they might say something about
it thanks
i haven't heard of anything like that
you know there's rumors all around but
uh have no knowledge of any i have no
knowledge of anything like that brian
i've never heard of it why do you two
still do this kind of work after all
these years
i i retired from the government worked
32 years as i've said before in the
pentagon
and and i plan to go to florida maybe
it's a good thing i didn't after all
this trouble we've had then
but uh
i got involved with we opened up a
washington office
and
i found so many prisoners of war that
needed help
many of them out through the countryside
the hills of west virginia
tennessee and all over the country that
had some benefits that was passed in
that 91 37 laws passed in 1981
they didn't know the benefits didn't
know how to get through them
through the system and
i felt i was able to help some
and
that's my my only reason to help the
people
mr uh rollins a little partial of
tennessee i think he was born in
sevierville tennessee is that correct
that's correct where is that
that's up near the smoky mountains
and you are a native of stroudsburg
pennsylvania that's right where is that
it's on the east coast of pennsylvania
nearest town of note
has about a thousand population
it's delaware water gap so now why do
you do this why do you spend all your
time it's uh it's my interest in the
prisoners
the people that were prisoners of war
that came back and that i feel need help
that
weren't properly cared for
do you have a yearly convention yes sir
we do where is it this year it's in
evansville indiana
and it will be in about
what two and a half weeks bill
yes
how long is the meeting
runs five days usually and how many
people will attend it
all
we've we've had
conventions i guess as small as
probably 1400 and as large as about 2
500.
memphis tennessee you're next
uh yes i'm 19 years old and the uh world
war ii is pretty far removed from my
generation and i wondered generally when
i when i think of world war ii and
prisoners of war and prison camps i i
associate you know i think of hitler and
his henchmen and all the atrocities
committed against the jews i wonder why
exactly i know you weren't you know
treated probably humanely but it sounds
like you weren't treated uh or you know
at least you weren't he didn't you know
there wasn't experimentation and things
like that that were done against the
jews i wonder what political reasons
there were for that and my second
question is
did after the war did any of you and
your organization take part in like the
israeli secret service uh i know went
and they hanged adolf eichmann and i
just wondered if you all took an active
role
in uh you know trying to hunt down any
of the uh
people like joseph mingley and
people like that mr williams
uh to my knowledge none of our people
became active nazi hunters
there have been active organizations
that have done this sort of thing most
of them have originated
in what is now israel i think of all the
war yes
no it was speaking about the the the
camps of the uh political camps there
the dalkai
i believe that's the way they pronounce
it was fairly close to our camp 10 or 15
miles concentration camp the
concentration camp near augsburg
and and they it's just short distance
out of munich and they brought those
people we worked we worked in munich
uh on the railroad and also they brought
those people down
and work them at a little distance from
us i didn't speak german or polish or
anything but some of the people tried to
talk with them and that was one thing
you'd get more trouble talking with
those political prisoners from that
concentration camp and they looked
terrible we looked bad but the
conscience people from the concentration
camp was just terrible have you been
back to your old camp
i have not been back there any desire to
do so uh not not really i wouldn't mind
to go back uh sometime but i have not
been back have you been back mr winner i
have not been back do you have any
desire
uh
i think there is some now
and i think the reason that i had no
desire before was because of the
because of the of the wall
when it came down why i think
a lot of my attitudes to going back
have changed with that what i'd like to
do now is go back and start a trip where
i was captured
and move all across from south to north
germany clear up to the baltic city
where i was held a prisoner
but i'd like to do that trip sometime
now
we've got about five minutes left with
our guest tampa florida next go ahead
please
yes sir uh this is this is tony campos
uh and cuban
and um
i understand that one of the vietnam war
there would many cubans involve
communist cubans involved in the war in
vietnam
um
if this is true how come anyone has done
anything about it and expose this
um
really talk about it not not just in
movies all right thanks do either one of
you know anything about the cubans
communist cubans being involved in
communist vietnam during the war i know
nothing at all i'm not familiar with any
of them being there they may have been
but i'm not aware of it
in the folklore and i don't mean to
it sounds maybe funny someone who's been
a prisoner of war but who in the
folklore of prisoners of war during this
year during this century are the heroes
are there the best books the best movies
the
you know do you have books on your
shelves written by pows that are the
something that somebody wanted to study
this that you recommend
either one of you well
i i think that i've considered ramel a
hero
among the german officers
and so forth
uh there was a
and one of the interrogators of one of
the
one of the camps
that the air force especially and i
don't know whether any ground troops
bill
came through
dulog luftha frankfurt or not
but there was a there was an
interrogator
there that they wrote a book about
called the master interrogator
and this man had a reputation of being
what about american pows is there anyone
that's uh
still alive well known besides john
mccain of course john mccain mr alvarez
the the vietnam
former prisoners of war of course
they're in the limelight i think more
than the others because they spent such
a long time there
and many of them have been successful
since they come out senator mccain
everett alvarez
we have two congressmen
pete peterson and sam johnson peterson
from florida johnson from
texas texas
and and and as dick stratton and many
other people
from the from the uh
from the vietnam war have written
they've been many books written from the
world war ii groups whether you call
them heroes it's uh you know everyone
always i think he's got two books yes
yes there's one that was in the
bookstore in the last month or so last
call for our two guests from farmingdale
new jersey go ahead please yes hello i'm
a first time caller i just wanted to say
you know where i'm where i'm coming from
i have been an opponent of the war since
1964. and i've been dialing ever since
that last person made the call
concerning jane fonda and possible
charges that might have been brought
against her may i say that it's
absolutely outrageous to compare the
people who oppose the war in vietnam to
people like lord haha and tokyo rose
it's absolutely ridiculous the forces of
of fascism were represented by the
united states during vietnam not by the
other side and this whole this whole
prisoner of war issue was a phony issue
because they were not wrong we were
wrong and they do not have our prisoners
it's just like the 3 000 prisoners that
the other gentleman said are still
missing from world war one the kaiser
does not have them they are gone there
is no reason for the vietnamese still to
be holding our prisoners or
mia's thank you very much uh connor are
you still there yes i am is this
something you've followed
excuse me have you followed this issue
oh yes i do i'm i'm quite angered i
think every time i see one of those
black and white flags i understand that
it is an issue very close to the people
who lost people over there or people who
are missing that have never been
accounted for but i just feel that it's
a phony issue i don't i feel that it's a
political issue to make it seem as
though somehow we were right
because they still have our prisoners
and that is not the case in the least
thank you for your call
any reaction gentlemen
well everybody has their own opinion you
know so uh
i'm not sure exactly this guy's
evidently uh
uh
opposed to a number of
things they're trying to do i guess for
the
for the mission into action there
which war this century world war one
world war ii korea vietnam was the most
difficult for pows
yeah you know that would be a hard
question to answer who well let me let
me let me ask it differently then which
during which war were the pows treated
the most
unhumanely and humanely by their captors
and i and i'm looking not as being the
same question
and i my my reaction
is that
any time
we were involved with the
with the oriental
we we had a rougher time
only because of their mentality
concerning war only
and
the fact that
some of them believe that the dying war
is a straight ticket
into
their their version of our heaven
and i think that's made them
take a different view of human life
in the second world war the
the people who were captured
on baton for instance and held by
and corregador and held by
the japanese i think
were treated worse
probably
any comment on that mr romero about out
of time no i would agree that those
people that was in uh caught in the on
the cragador and the baton they were in
for three and a half years and i believe
only four out of ten
came back so they lo there's a lot of
people lost over there in that time it's
less lost in europe but you got to
remember uh the prisoners in europe we
were shorter time than the others if the
time had been three years we might have
lost a lot tonight a lot more too there
were people dying in their [ __ ] and
and uh
but uh i imagine in the in the in in in
the pacific it was rougher probably also
the korean
vietnam i would think because of the
oriental influence there our two guests
for this segment have included the
executive director of the american
ex-prisoners of war organization
chuck williams a native of strasbourg
pennsylvania and a pow in world war ii
and bill roland a member of the national
legislative committee of the american x
prisoners of war gentlemen thank you
both very much for telling us your story
and sharing a little time with us thank
you thank you
we've got a another four hours to go
here on this afternoon as we continue uh
a rerun on our vietnam revisited special
that ran originally over memorial day
weekend
later on this afternoon in just a few
moments by the way francis swenig will
be here she is a
she's a chief staff person for the mia
pow committee of the united states
senate select committee
she'll spend some time bringing us up to
date on
the activities of that committee and
what's next for them later on this
afternoon in about two and a half hours
joining us via satellite from boston
will be senator john kerry and there's
plenty yet to go next up you'll see some
videotape
of the senate delegation back in april
april 19th 20th in that range arriving
in hanoi and we'll be back with frank
francis renek in just a moment
oh
[Music]
[Music]
nice to see you again how are you
remember
you do
remember each other that's right
from iowa senator roberto
thank you for meeting us nice to see you
again
sir you're in the lead vehicle and this
one's right here senator grassley and
senator smith sir you're in the second
vehicle okay
good to see you about chuck bill
we going to get a chance to spend some
time shortly i want to chat with you yes
sir as soon as we can yeah
so maybe right when we get in we can
spend a minute
good all right
we all set yes sir
francis do you have the other bag
oh these are my biking glasses northern
virginia bike trails
it's all right
70 k's a day in and out from reston
virginia this guy is incredible last
time i was here
he'd be out early in the morning in
these tight jogging shots you know i'd
be out there talking to everybody in the
streets
yeah he's still pleasant he's incredible
you managed to date every day
oh yeah so you heard our comments yeah
on the voice of america
did they meet with approval or
disapproval
uh
positive
comment
positive comments positive comments
[Music]
and they prepared very uh closely to
meet the best conditions for you for
your delegation
to
to look at the situation in vietnam
well we
as you know from the communication that
we sent you this is a very important
trip with great possibilities
um
[Music]
and he hopes that this trip will play a
constructive role
in the development of a better
relationship between our two countries
and they have followed with great
interest your delegation's progress
and they understand and appreciate the
important role of the united states
congress in its relation to helping the
american people solve the problem of the
missing in action
and understanding that then it's
incumbent on them to try to create the
conditions for you to do your job here
however he is sorry that your time here
is so short for such an important
mission
[Music]
so for that reason we're going to start
into work immediately this afternoon
[Music]
we're ready to go to work right now yeah
right now and he said that also they're
ready to start right away uh with the uh
at 1400 with the foreign minister win
minecom
and uh
and then of course
we may be here for a brief time
ourselves our senators
but the teams will be here through the
next few months and we will be sending
some people back here to follow up on
that work
tuangai
and they are just perfectly happy to
receive your specialists and your other
personnel to continue this work
we will have some uh requests with
respect to the visits that we want to
make in country
in the next two days and we'll try to
sit down with you very soon to talk
about those
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what he'd like to propose is that he
show you the proposed schedule that
they've put together based on what they
received from you in washington and then
go from there
but then
there's perfectly happy then to discuss
from that any modifications or
supplementations that you might wish to
make
so when we get into the hotel senator uh
he said that that is the place to
discuss this
the re the schedule in the hotel yeah
the fellow on the right there andre
savagio you'll get to know a lot more
about him when we get to the trip on the
mekong delta which some of you may have
seen over memorial day he's the
interpreter the gentleman on the left is
senator john kerry a democrat
from the state of massachusetts and also
a number of other senators there
including chuck robb on the left hank
brown
bob smith at the back the tall gentleman
without tie on chuck grassley from iowa
all members of the select committee
senate select committee on m.i.a pow
affairs
and here with us in the studio francis
schwennig is the staff director of
that group uh since those pictures were
taken back in april what has changed
what what do you know now that you
didn't know then
well we've had several days of hearings
and we've done a lot more research
we know that the vietnamese and the
laotians are
as a follow-up to our trip
cooperating more than they were before
the trip went and
given and there have been
concrete examples of that cooperation
we thanks to our research now know much
more about what the united states
government knew
on the issues of pow mias in 1973 and
we're better prepared to hold our
hearings in the future
in in september we're holding hearings
on the paris peace accord negotiations
we are as you know a one-year committee
and we're wrapping up by the end of this
year and we're getting ready to
start the first drafts of our report
uh we we feel that we've gone a long way
toward fulfilling the mandate of our
committee but there's still a lot more
to be learned
now when was the last time you went by
you were on this trip i was on this trip
in april and then as a follow-up both to
our hearings which were in june
and
and um and this trip i went back in july
at the behest of the committee to see if
the promises that were extended to us in
april were still being lived up to and
also to
take the vietnamese up on some new
promises they extended to us as a result
of our hearings they agreed to look at
the cases that we previewed in the late
june hearings and give us more
information we're still working with
them to get that information
by the way how closely are the
vietnamese themselves watching these
hearings um
i think that they are both watching and
reading everything
that the committee does what evidence do
you have how do you know that
well we have evidence by way of letters
we have phone calls from them asking for
copies of
of of documents that are referred to in
the in the hearings
when we travel to vietnam they seem to
be quite up to date on what what we're
doing we've got a map here and i've got
my trusty little uh
a new pointer
i want you to tell us where you on this
map where did you go
on this last trip did you go back to
hanoi yes i did i went only to hanoi in
vietnam and i went to vientiane and laos
all right now vntn is over right in
there right right there it's on the
border with thailand right right across
the road thailand being down here and
then you come back down over here and we
can show where cambodia is we went there
in april we i did not go there on this
last trip
cambodia
is important
because the government of cambodia is
cooperating
quite well with the
with the united states government
and
even though there's far less prospect
for finding
lots of information because of the role
of khmer rouge in the mid 70s
uh mid 70s to late 70s the the cambodian
government is doing everything it can
within its power given the hole that
some khmer khmer rouge factions still
have on the country to to cooperate with
the dod investigators have you totaled
up so far how many days of hearings
you've had yes
we have had
we have had some 12 to 15 days of
hearings by the time we're through we'll
have 20 days of hearings we've had
we will have by the by the end of the
year 75 people at least testify before
us we will have taken over 100
depositions
reviewed thousands and thousands of
pages of documents and more importantly
through the declassification that's
occurred because of the committee's
prodding
will have available to the public
1.5 million pages of documents that have
to do with this period of time
of all those 20 days of hearing so far
which one has gotten the most attention
both from you know committee staff
public it's hard to say each each
hearing that we prepare for i think is
is the most successful and has gotten
the most attention yet the next one that
comes along seems to be even more
important and more watched
and more and
and require more work
i don't want to pick out anyone
how many people work for you there are
20 people on the committee
on the committee staff on the committee
staff we have 12 senators how many
republicans how many democrats the
very important point about our committee
is that it's that it's nonpartisan we
have six democrats we have six
republicans it's not a democratic issue
it's not a republican issue seven of the
members of our committee are vietnam
veterans so they have a personal vested
interest in solving many of the
questions that have to do with vietnam
but it but as you um may know the
mandate of our committee goes beyond
just the vietnam war
we also
look into the issues of world war ii
korea and the cold war with emphasis on
vietnam since it's chronologically
closest to us and we and most of the
emphasis has been there
when will
we and the audience meaning the american
people know what your findings are
well we will give we will do a report
which will be issued at the end of the
year some probably in december
but
the way we're approaching this issue is
that we are holding all of our as many
of our of our meetings as many as of our
hearings as we possibly can
in
in public and thanks to c-span the
people are seeing and they people the
public is learning what we're learning
as we go along
and we are upon request sending out
copies of documents
we are as quickly as we can get the
senate presses to go we're we're getting
the the transcripts and the um and the
documents and releasing hearings ready
for publication and out to the public
we get volumes of mail that we respond
to on a daily basis has there been any
evidence
other than the robert garfield
garwood i'm sorry carwood i've been
reading some this so much this i forget
what i read last robert garwood uh case
and by the way when was when did he come
out 1979
and
other than the robert garwood case since
1979 had there any had there been any
evidence that there's anybody alive
american
service person alive in vietnam there is
evidence right now today the united
states government is tracking down that
evidence in the form of following up on
live siting reports there are currently
um
109 live citing reports on the books for
vietnam laos and cambodia
um more than half of them are in are in
vietnam and those reports are important
to follow up on they are reports some of
americans
living freely some of americans under
captivity so there is evidence what the
level of that evidence is is still to be
determined but we are pushing the the
government the select committee is
pushing the united states government to
follow up on those investigations as
quickly possible and pushing the
vietnamese government to that was part
of
what we did in our trip as you could as
you know as you know we went to um
to a prison just 30 miles
southwest i believe of hanoi and
conducted a live sighting investigation
let's run a little bit of of the video
that we taped last time of the agenda
meeting right after that
plane landed there and see what it
looked like uh back in april
meeting with secretary solomon
in the five-point agreement yeah it was
agreed that there would be an immediate
capacity to go yeah we have a helicopter
right now for you to go anywhere so in
that prison we are ready to
to to offer to go
what time would we be able to do that in
the morning uh tomorrow
uh in the morning so it's my
understanding because instead of going
to visit because if you go to tech back
you have to go back in helicopter yeah
we're not right and you're not going
back two people might go no it's
possible that some people would go okay
but we would like to uh be able to
reserve the judgment as to where we're
gonna go it was my understanding that we
can go anywhere is that correct yes yes
so what i'd like to do is make our
decision as to where we'd like to go
and then uh if it isn't ending from us
and then inform you and try to do it i
think it'd be very helpful to the
process obviously
a lot of people are
curious about the access
and the capacity to go anywhere
so i think it's very helpful to us
as senators and as a select committee
to be able to make a request and see
exactly francis we're looking at your
boss senator john kerry and then senator
rob sitting next to him sitting across
the table from lee bang who's lee bang
he's the director of the department of
the americas of the ministry of foreign
affairs in vietnam
and what's the purpose of this meeting
the vietnamese approach a trip
in a very collegial sort of way they
greet you at the airport they know
what you want to do and yet you still
discuss your program when you get there
and what we're doing is discussing
um the outlines of the program we had
asked to follow
and we at this particular time we're
talking about
making the live sighting investigation
real we're talking about no notice or
relatively no notice investigations of a
prison
or of
a purported
military and imported prison or military
installation when you went back in july
you went by yourself yes
i was accompanied by
brigadier general tom needham who's the
head of the joint task force i hitched a
ride with him but you didn't have any
senators no
did you did you talk to lee bang when
you went back yes we met with him had
they followed up and and had they gone
along with what they agreed to do
yes and no there were some successes
there were some live citing inspections
that were done however uh as we we were
told i was told
that one of the live sighting inspectors
went to follow up on one of the
reports on the list and he was told that
he couldn't and when he
questioned why and he said this is you
know contradictory to the promises that
were made to the senators by domoy who's
head of the communist party in vietnam
he was told well you're not a
senator so
i brought that up when the discussion
with um with mr lebong and explained
that
the point of the senator's trip was to
reinforce the approach
the the approach that was worked out
between vietnam and the joint task force
and obviously
the senators could not undertake every
live siting inspection it was
unrealistic and it would be up to the
dod employees to do that
and we further asked as a
um
example of their good faith in following
through the promises that they had made
the senators that could we asked if we
could do a live-sighting inspection if
the live-siting investigators could
carry out a live-sighting investigation
while we were there in hanoi
and they agreed to that
let me go back to what we were talking
about earlier about you said there are
109
active live sightings that you're
investigating that the department of
defense is and that and it's
not just vietnam sloughs cambodia and
vietnam and half of them are in vietnam
about
a little more than half trying to get a
little more precise has there been any
american
official
that you all trust as a committee that
have seen any living americans in
vietnam laos or cambodia well i can't
really speak to that i think a lot of
the information that's contained in
these live citing reports is
is classified information and we better
not to discuss it
let me just say that
the
the testimony
by the department of defense officials
who we called in on august 4th and 5th
to talk about these live-siting
investigations
the testimony was that these are serious
sightings and they need to be followed
up on
how can you reach a conclusion in public
and give us a an answer to all this if
the information is classified
uh well if the
live-siting investigation is carried out
and carried out to completion then that
completes the
the case and then there's no problem
with classification but you raise a good
point and that's why we are pushing to
have the
the files declassified and
i think one of the very important
legacies of this committee is by the end
of the day
by the end of the committee we will have
gotten most of the
the
information declassified and
that which is not declassified we will
ask
the government to explain why is there a
chance and i can ask senator to carry
this later but is there a chance that
you won't be able to reach a conclusion
um
there's a chance
i mean you're what's your sense at this
point what you hear your senators
talking about our our duty as a
committee
is to
follow
follow the cases follow the information
and bring it out into the open there may
be some
questions that no one can reach a
conclusion but you know it's the we just
we put the truth out there we let the
chips fall where they may we let the
public decide there may be some things
that
you know it's a 51-49 call you know
there's a lot of hours that we've
covered of this and i remember watching
some of it i may be unfair by picking
out this little
again we're going to hopefully have
senator smith on the phone later
but he was quite unhappy with some
government officials over a photographer
i remember where he which he thought was
doctored
um
what is
what's the coral about what's the uh
do you get us are they is the government
from your perspective cooperating i mean
government by the defense department the
cia whatever agency you're working with
cooperating to the extent that you want
them to
i think that we have gotten very good
cooperation
i think that there is a difference
perhaps
between
what we are getting now and what uh
other people tried to get in the past
even people who come to our hearing and
testify they're saying well not on my
watch on my watch we're going to
cooperate i can't speak for the people
that came before
um we found that in during the follow-up
to the parole hearings for example
um
you know
there could be
um there could be conspiratorial
explanations for things that happen it
could be just pure ineptitude
that's our job to figure that out let's
look at some more videotape from the
trip back in april when
how many senators do you remember the
number was it five five
five were in vietnam and uh and and
cambodia when we roll this tape of trip
to the army museum archives can you
explain to us
what this is we're going to the military
museum where
uh
even by the vietnamese on admission
there are a lot of there's a lot of
information here we we are convinced
that
the vietnamese have answers to a lot of
the questions about the unaccounted for
and uh the
a lot of the answers are actually here
in this museum now in um
it is
it is interesting when you see the way
that the file cards are kept we're not
they're no computers here this is a very
primitive uh place they have three by
five cards that they they showed us
where they keep down very carefully they
keep down information
about um crash sites or or documents or
artifacts they find it at crash sites
the woman we're looking at there in the
picture probably is the computer brain
of the of the of the museum why don't we
listen just for a couple minutes so we
can get a sense of what they're talking
about
oh he goes to veterans and the veterans
organization
he goes yeah
come on
he says they stand ready senator to make
this uh these exhibits and the the
information here as helpful as possible
to your efforts and as constructive and
effort as possible to help build a
better relationship between our two
countries
you know as you and later on the week uh
our audience will if they didn't see it
before we'll be able to see the trip to
the mekong delta and that same line of
answer was given everywhere the stops
were made that they are prepared to be
as helpful as possible and constructive
as possible
do you agree that that is in fact what
they are trying to do
i think there are definitely people in
vietnam who want to be helpful who want
to be constructive
i think there are others who do not want
to be and uh
i think that there is there is more
cooperation but there can be even more
cooperation
it's interesting you know we work with
russia now
as part of the u.s russia commission
after
soviet union fell apart we're getting
more answers and i see the same sort of
tension in russia the people the
ministry of foreign affairs for example
they want to be helpful they are not
able to pull the documents pull the
cooperation from the ministry of defense
ministry of interior the same sort of
tensions you see in vietnam yeah is that
anything to do with being a communist
i mean being the communist way of
thinking in vietnam versus the are they
still thinking that way over in russia
uh could be i mean there are people who
definitely don't want to show their past
sins
in russia the kgb and the gru the
military intelligence arm yeah this
question also came up often uh what
would we what what would our cooperation
level be if people were coming over here
after we had
law i mean if if we had won a war and
the loser was coming over here demanding
this kind of well it's a good question
and you know the congress is finding it
has trouble not just with this issue
powmia but other issues getting
information out of the executive branch
there's a tension you know between the
congress and legislative branch
ongoing now will there be a vote
of your committee on before this is over
on anything i mean will be an actual
public vote or
well today we have done most of our work
by by consensus um and i i presume we
will proceed on that tag
so
is there a dispute now oh is there a
are there three senators on one side of
an issue and six on another no and it's
rare you know it's rare in the senate to
see that but it's a nice luxury i mean
is there any chance that when this is
all over that uh there will be a
minority report of some kind
now i don't see that the the
the way we are approaching this issue is
there for the most part no one has any
agenda except to find out what's there
and we we try to find the truth and then
we let the chips fall where they may you
know we are we're not trying to prove
anything we're just trying to see what
went wrong why it went wrong
your hearing's in september will they be
the last
no we're going to have the hearings in
september are on the paris peace accords
we're going to have the people who
actually negotiated with vietnamese
we're going to um the the chief among
them will be henry kissinger who will be
in on september 22nd
in october
we will have what we call the oversight
of dod hearings we will talk about how
the
central identification laboratory in
hawaii deals with the remains that come
out of hawaii there have been lots of
reports in the past about how
that still high facility as it's called
it's not done a very good job we asked
the general accounting office to do a
study and in our hearing in october they
will
they will go through that study and we
will ask the still high people to come
in and respond to it we will ask um
dia
for
the defense intelligence agency yes
sorry the defense intelligence agency
which is part of department of defense
they we will do an oversight hearing on
on how they perform the live sighting
investigations the follow up on the the
satellite imagery reports
we're going to
do a set of hearings later in the year
on the issue of whether this issue
whether the powmia issue has been abused
manipulated used for fundraising in an
inappropriate fashion uh is there fraud
you know involved with some of these
photos with the with the marketing of
bones with the marketing of dog dog tags
it's an issue both for
for southeast asia and for here and
finally most importantly we're going to
have a hearing focusing on how the
families the pow mia families have been
have been dealt with
they sometimes get lost in this equation
uh because i don't know the details on
it and i'll just allude to and i know
you know what i'm talking about we've
got two family groups that are coming in
this afternoon that will not sit down
with one another at the same table
can you help us understand that
well this is an emotional emotional
topic
and
people feel very strongly about
their approach
[Music]
i don't think it's peculiar to this to
this topic but they're
just you know anybody who's worked on
something for as many years as most
people have 20 years they are
they're entrenched
positions and if someone uh takes an
opposite point of view
it's a lot of bad blood it's not just
with respect to
to
groups outside i see that on a daily
basis inside the government
uh one of the gentlemen that's going to
appear here is a h bruce franklin a
rutgers professor he has a book m.i.a
or myth taking myth-making in america
let me just read a paragraph a sentence
the belief in live pows was based not
just on political rhetoric rumors in the
pow rescue movies but also on a sizable
body of books pamphlets and articles
that have promulgated a coherent and
superficially plausible pseudo-history
compounded of self-deception amateur
research anecdotes half-truths phony
evidence slick political and media
manipulation downright lies and near
religious fervor
what is your reaction to that
well i think that uh mr franklin has
raised some interesting issues in his
book everyone who has read his book or
the excerpt from it appeared in one of
the magazines
it's made an impression on it and and
it's brought up some
some good topics of debate and i think
it's very good you're going to have him
on here and that he's going to respond
to calls because i think he raises some
interesting issues uh do you have to
watch your words on all this francis yes
i'm a staffer i'm not a senator
and and what are the restrictions on you
well it's there's no written code but um
i don't vote i'm i work for the senators
and i try to
do the job that they assign me you went
to duke law school
where is your hometown
uh it's in georgia where gordon georgia
and where did you work before you went
to work for senator kerry on the
committee i was senator kerry's uh chief
of staff administrative assistant for
four years before that i worked for
senator white fowler who's the senator
from georgia can we go back to some more
videotape when the congressional
delegation visited hanoi and here is a
visit to a
prison
[Music]
hmm
food
francis wennig do you remember this trip
to the prison and what was the purpose
we went to this prison because there had
been reports of americans kept hostage
here and we one of the live-siding
investigators just the month before had
been refused admission to this prison it
was very important for us to
get admission and and do an inspection
uh as will you play the whole um
tape at some point in time for the
audience you are you talking about uh
the visit to townley on friday on friday
because they will see
that um when we first got there there
was a there was uh initial resistance to
our touring the facility um upon
intervention in recession by the
ministry of foreign affairs official who
was there with us
on he was on the phone for two hours
both to his boss and to the
head of the minister of interior through
his boss the ministry of foreign affairs
we got admission to the prison
and we toured and it turned out that um
that prison
in the
in the um late 60s and early 70s
actually did house 10 americans who had
been brought who had been caught in the
south but been brought up there
and were kept prisoner in that prison
is there any chance you all will go back
again as a delegation to vietnam there
is a chance perhaps you could ask them
to carry about that but if it if it
makes sense to complete our
investigation to complete a report
here's some uh more of the video and
matter of fact i think you've got a
bright red dress on there orange orange
excuse me
my eyes are failing
uh
are these hard to arrange was this did
you go over there in advance to arrange
this no this is this was a we pushed
them on this this wasn't their their on
their list of things for us to do we
this was the one of the live site you
know it's a short notice
uh inspection of this prison
and the
prison officials were none too happy to
see us there they were they functioned
just like bureaucrats anywhere in the
world it was like
please leave please leave me alone am i
going to do something wrong am i going
to say something wrong that will get me
in trouble with my bosses higher up this
man is terrified you can see uh so what
was the advantage of doing this the
advantage was uh to we we followed up on
a live sighting report there was a
report that there were americans being
kept hostage that very day in that
prison and the senators toward the
prison
they didn't let they let us the group in
a part of the prison where the americans
had been held in the late 60s they
didn't let the group except for the five
senators in the rest of prison and the
senators could go in any cell they chose
to and they did
we'll have more of this for the audience
all day on friday it starts at 12 noon
east coast time and goes until 5 o'clock
in the afternoon and included in that
day besides watching all the
video that we shot in hanoi will be a
trip down to the mekong delta looking at
the different bases by the way
the trip to the mekong delta is have you
gotten any benefit out of that since
then
well
again that trip just as the trip to the
prison was
a
precedent-setting
set of visits for the live signing
investigators because up to that point
in time no americans had visited
military installations those airports we
went to and fuquak island now there's a
precedent so that the live sighting
investigators can go back in there and
do the thorough job they need to do to
check out every report let me uh
play the role sign i know somebody out
there is watching this that would say
this
if they were calling in during this time
they've had it up to here with this
whole issue they say when are you people
in the government and you
pows and mias and i'm not it's not me
saying this but there's
you've heard it from the viewers going
to stop talking about the vietnam war
uh we've had in our pow visitors were
here earlier said something like sev
there's still 72 000 people who are
missing in action from world war ii 8
thousand from korea three thousand from
world war one so i ask you that what
would you say to them well in defense of
the committee even though there have
been
sever uh at least 11 congressional or
other investigations of the way we've
conducted
the
pow accounting since since the war was
over no one has looked at the documents
the way we have i mean it is not right
that people have claimed to have done an
investigation of what we're doing now
we're looking at documents we're talking
to people who have never been talked to
before and what we're trying to do is
is do it in this thorough fashion so we
can
put the facts out and let people
conclude for themselves but as
as people know vietnam
there is something about vietnam that's
captured the imagination of the american
people and there are there
the lessons of vietnam have yet to be
learned and i don't think we're going to
ever
not talk about vietnam what are you
going to do when it's all over you know
no i don't
is there any chance that the committee
would recommend an extension of time i
don't i think that we all feel that the
15 months that the senate voted is
adequate to do the task and we're going
to do it what happens once you you know
you issue your report does it just fall
off the end of the earth and nothing's
done or is it referred to another
committee
uh technically what happens in a town
like this well
our report will include recommendations
and
i know that the executive branch will be
called upon to
account for our recommendations the
senators don't go out of existence after
after
the end of this year and in their
different
positions there are several senators on
the armed services committee there are
several senators in the foreign
relations committee they all have a
pulpit from which or a podium from which
to pursue these issues and they will
because we're not going to answer every
question if you go back in bruce
franklin's book among others and go back
to 1969 1970 you find out that there was
an organization back in those days
headed up by ross perot that was called
united we stand
if you move forward in 1992 the
organization formed nationally that
fronts
his sign up of all the different states
it's called united we stand
what about the ross perot experience
in the committee for you all he was
going to testify
he wasn't and now he did
what happened well ross perot is a
fascinating person this is a man who has
been involved with this issue from the
very beginning
he has had
access
to presidents to secretaries of state to
secretary of defense descent defense
access that no other american has had he
provides a sense of history and i think
he performed a very important
uh function in our committee in our
hearings what was the reaction of
senator kerry when ross perot looked up
at him and said you know don't look at
your notes look at me
i think that was a good throwaway line a
politician appreciates another
politician all the time
what was the result
before i ask you that question let's
look at just a little bit of that
testimony and we'll continue with
francis winnick
now first for the record
i would like to establish
whether or not at some point in time you
became privy to a conversation
that dr roger shields of the defense
department had
with mr bill clements who at that time
was in the defense department with the
responsibilities for pows did you become
aware of a conversation he had when i
was doing the pow study in 1986 for the
vice president
i heard this story i called dr shields
he uh i said roger uh
i'm surprised
yes oh sure that's roger i'm surprised
that uh
you declared all the men dead
in april 1973.
he said i was ordered to do it
and uh he said he was ordered to do it
by the deputy secretary of defense uh
william clements
i walked in the room in hanoi and their
first question was why are you here
this is after the advanced meetings
the letter of invitation and so on and
so forth and my response was because you
asked me
and they sat there for a minute
and
they said
we hold no pows
and i responded
don't embarrass yourselves i know too
much
and then they broke out laughing
and said we had heard you were direct we
are direct too we will get along fine
and then they said your own government
declared these men dead in 1973
why should we think your government
wants them back
pretty good logic right
why should we thank your government and
then i explained to him that he said now
our goal is to rebuild a relationship
with your government
and since this is our goal
why wouldn't it be counterproductive
to
finally admit after all these years that
we have these men and women to give them
back
what was the result of his testimony
before your group
we're still
evaluating the results
he has
there's still some information that he
owes us
that we need to follow up on
when he does provide that to us
i think he um
he stimulated some thought
but
a lot of what he
told us was already in the public domain
i don't know that he broke through any
new with any new information this uh
question is not at all related to ross
perot i don't want to even sound like it
is but i wanted to ask you this earlier
as you've sat there and listened to all
the testimony 75 witnesses
it will be 75. have you ever gotten the
feeling that somebody is
knowingly lying to you
not
not knowingly lying
i do feel that people know more than
they are perhaps saying why won't they
say it
a variety of reasons
have you ever gotten a sense that any of
the organizations surrounding all of
this including some of the mia pow
organizations are in the business of
just raising money to keep their
organizations going
that's an issue that's been a question
has been raised and i think it's the
role of committee to look into that i
don't have any sort of judgment on that
right now how about the story that
actually
strangely as it may sound emanated from
an offhand question that we asked lee
bang when we were over there about ross
perot i mean the question was who comes
to see you and he said lots of americans
and one of them was this guy named
richard perrault and then he
corrected himself said ross perot and he
said this aide to harry mccullup has
been here 13 times and that ended up
being a big story about how ross perot
was really interested in going into
business over there did you get any
idea of what's that all about did he
answer those questions in your opinion
uh they
they weren't really the questions
weren't really asked that much but just
uh
on the topic of offhand remarks by lei
bong
he mentioned to me um i i when i went
over there i took a copy of the new york
times article that was written just
before my trip and it contained the
parole letter to reagan reporting on his
trip and his recommendations about how
to proceed
and
um leibn uh
opined that he thought ross perot had a
better approach to solving the problems
with vietnam than the reagan
administration did
did you ever find out or do you ever get
any sense of how the letter signed by
the vietnamese
to ross perot making him
a letter in principle making him their
agent for business in this country was
released to the press
where it came from no i don't know
anything about that
for those
joining us and we've been sitting here
now for over a half hour talking let's
go back over the facts as they are how
how much longer does the mia pow select
committee uh have
to be in existence in the senate we go
out of business on january 2nd 1993 the
end of this congress
and how many senators are there on the
committee 12 how many in each party 12
12 senators six democrats six
republicans what will be the result i
mean what's the end result of not the
not the i don't want you to answer the
issues questions
but what will be what will the public be
able to look at when this is all over
the public should feel confident that
the senators their staffs the wit the
witnesses the hearings have
given them the most complete picture
of the top the mi pow topic for the last
20 25 years we've looked at every
document we've talked to everybody
that's still alive
and read papers for people who aren't
and we've when we've tried to get it out
in the open we've tried to declassify
and demystify this issue how much has it
cost the taxpayer for the select
committee our budget is 1.9 million
dollars for a 15-month period has that
been enough money oh i yes no problem
there now
you should one of the questions you
should ask your defense department
people when they come on is what is
their budget what has their budget been
for the past 20 years following this
issue up do you have an answer
uh millions
has it been enough in your opinion
the question is not the amount it's how
it's spent
do you think that the government in
general over the last 20 years has
devoted enough resources people interest
to this whole issue
i think that perhaps the quantity of
people and resources is okay but i would
question the quality
what has surprised you the most we've
only got a couple minutes left for you
personally about this whole experience
this year
the depth of emotion
the depth of feeling
i
i thought that
that the vietnam war was something that
as your caller might have said with
something we should put behind this but
i think anyone who lived the vietnam war
the vietnam war whatever their position
was whatever that will be with that
person forever
how about the the personal experience
that you've had in this whole year that
you'll most remember
the people i've met some truly
remarkable people
and
i've seen
people operate at
you know the very work very hard to try
to bring
the best um attempted truth that we can
and people are very dedicated now
there's i know a lot of folks out there
that
don't have a clue as to what the
conclusion of all this is and they're
looking to you and the committee
to help them understand it what
recommendation do you have for people in
the audience
that are trying to get an answer to this
what should they look for in the next
couple months well i'm not sure there's
any single answer to any of this but i
think that uh we have
uncovered uh the fact
that not everything was told or not
everything perhaps was known and not
everything was that was known was told
back in the in the war period i mean we
were in a war after all
um i think that what i would like people
to conclude is that these 12 senators
have done the best job they could in
trying to make up for some lapses in the
past september 22nd henry kisner
testifies correct how many days during
that period we'll have three days we'll
start in the 21st 22nd will be mr
kissinger and the 24th you know keep us
busy aren't you
october how many days and what date yeah
uh middle october we haven't firmed
those dates up
at least three days of hearings there
and some day some days in november we're
going to be working to the very end and
then in december perhaps possibly some
december hearings yes we're going to be
printing the
rolling printing presses as we walk out
the door
francis swenig thank you very much for
joining us and bringing us up to date on
the activities of the select committee i
enjoyed being here thank you
in about 11 minutes or so we're going to
have mary backley
the national league of cities is that
right back clear bakery
of families oh we excuse me um and later
on tom ashworth who is
the national alliance of families they
will not be on together and bruce
franklin will join
mary beckley
who is the author of this book m.i.a or
myth-taking in america
and we've still got another three hours
and 10 minutes to go
before this day is finished remember
friday is a trip to the mekong delta
among other things but up next is
president bush's appearance before the
national league of families a couple
weeks ago
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
who want me
ladies and gentlemen as you all know
president bush while serving in the
reagan administration was actively
supporting and and directly involved in
our pow mia activities and after
assuming the presidency
he expanded that priority with his
personal commitment
it's indeed a pleasure to have
him back for his third visit ladies and
gentlemen the president of the united
states
thank you all very much
thank you
thank you all
well sue thank you very much and anne
it's glad to be back with you and this
organization
to the members of the board my respects
to the family
friends
let me first start off by saluting two
two uh former uh nsc hands
uh bud mcfarland and dick childress
over here who worked very hard on all of
this
and also
the chairman emeritus george brooks
and
let me begin by thanking you for the
opportunity to speak again to
what has got to be one of the bravest
and
most dedicated groups of americans in
this country
and we live in a
marvelous time
time of tremendous opportunity
we've seen the end of the cold war
the collapse of imperial communism
and a new birth of freedom from moscow
and agua
america's courage
america's vision america's values have
indeed
changed the world
and yes
and yes the cold war may be over
but the noble cause that took your
fathers your sons and your husbands away
from home
is with us still
and our work must not end
and will not end
until you have answers about your loved
ones
over
over the past 20 years the national
league of families has seen the issue of
your missing
swept up
in international or domestic politics
manipulated by foreign governments
exploited by con men
sensationalized by the media in all that
time
you never lost sight of what you were
looking for good faith and honest effort
to resolve your uncertainty
to find answers to the agonizing
question that you live with every day
sometimes you may have wondered whether
your government had forgotten you and
when president reagan and i took office
in 81 we made your ordeal our top
priority
we knew that with all the uncertainties
you live with
the one thing you should be sure of
is that your government really cares
you're talking to a person that was shot
down himself in combat fortunately i
wasn't taken taken prisoner but i i was
shot down in
in combat i understand a little bit what
that means understand what it means
and so we set out to meet with you
uh to ask your advice and when we took
office
no policy level negotiations with
vietnam laos or cambodia had been been
held for several years
and despite the fears of some
that negotiating with vietnam implied
recognition
despite the fears of others that the pow
mia issue was a cold war fantasy
we took your advice
and entered into high-level negotiations
and when we took office some saw this
issue as a matter between this nation
and vietnam not part of a broader
relations between the u.s and soviet
uh china and our friends in asia
the asian countries
we took your advice and urged our
friends uh as well as our adversaries to
help us find the answers
and let me add that i am gratified to
hear the asean ambassadors are here
today i salute them over there
they are cooperating with us
their their countries deserve great
credit for their understanding for their
help and for their fellowship with you
the families
[Applause]
most important of all
when we took office
we came up against the string of
official statements
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
national
i want to prosecutors the president
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i think it might be very important
[Applause]
we'll simply ask others
[Applause]
and maybe if the media will stop taking
pictures of the minority they'll go away
[Applause]
[Music]
you're only embarrassing yourself would
you please sit down
with the
[Music]
[Applause]
guys
[Music]
for the president
thank you for returning
[Applause]
remember the president is our guest
please have a little courtesy
where were we
yeah let's get these guys down in front
that's right
no no no this is a this is a
very emotional understandably emotional
and the thing that i would say to you
however as a veteran
and one who
still wears my navy wings from time to
time is
i hope you understand how i feel about
patriotism
about service to my country
and i will put my record
up against anybody here
and i just
would you please be quiet and let me
finish
[Applause]
[Applause]
that led this country into its most
successful recent effort would condone
for one
single day
that personal knowledge of a person held
against his will whether it's here or
anyplace else
is simply
totally unfair now to say that i
understand the agony
to say i understand the agony that
i've reheard here today is true i do
but i do not like the suggestion that
any american
anywhere would know of
a live american being held somewhere
against his will whether it's here or
the allegation being over in in over in
the other part of the world
iran
the suggestion was made that we left
people being prisoner in iran so to win
an election now what kind of what kind
of an allegation is that to make against
a patriot
what kind of make it make against it is
not
and so i would simply say to you
i care about it
we are trying and we're going to
continue to try and i understand the
divisions here i understand the
divisions we hear in these hearings
i understand the agony that people feel
but i would also like to ask that you
understand where i'm coming from on this
issue and i think most of you do and i'm
going to continue to try
mary beckley uh director of operations
for the national league of cities what
was that all about national league of
families i'm sorry this is the second
time i've done it today and i apologize
it's quite all right
what it was about was a few family
members handful of family members and
support who are supporting another
organization who also are members of our
organization were exerting their
frustration over the lack of results
against the president of the united
states what's more important to note is
that the president's policies are the
strongest policies we've had with
regards to the powmi issue
since
since it has occurred in the 70s it's a
issue that is a matter of highest
national priority it's being pursued as
such the vast majority of families who
attended that conference which were 600
plus were mortified over the irrational
actions of a few and have made it quite
clear in numerous letters to the
president that they most certainly did
not resp represent the majority of the
family's views as to his actions on this
issue now what's the national league of
families how big is it
we are comprised solely of pow mia
family relatives over 3 800 as well as
return vietnam pows we were incorporated
in may of 1970 in the district of
columbia and our three-fold objective is
quite simple it's the same today as it
was when incorporated the return of all
prisoners the fullest possible
accounting of the missing and the
repatriation of all recoverable remains
of those who died while serving in
vietnam what's your connection to the
war
my connection is that my father served
in world war ii
i've known a great number of individuals
who have served in vietnam
and
because of the lack of the educational
system teaching vietnam when i went to
high school and college i never had a
clear-cut education on it i have learned
a tremendous amount since being with the
league
since 1983. nine years plus full-time
job for you absolutely how many people
work at the national league of families
we have a national staff of three
which runs the national operations of
the organizations there are coordinators
in almost all the 50 states throughout
the country who operate on a volunteer
basis they implement the programs as
developed in the national office what's
it cost a year to run the organization
that's a wonderful question uh i won't
deny that the recession over the past
years had a tremendous effect on us i
would say it costs probably 500 000
plus in order to implement responsibly
and effectively implement the public
awareness
activities we would like to see
throughout the country there's an
organization called the national
alliance of families and a gentleman
from that organization tom ashford is
going to appear in a few minutes what's
the difference between the two
difference in
strategies on how to resolve the issue
it's my understanding that the national
alliance of families
believes there is a conspiracy and
cover-up within the united states
government currently on the powmi issue
we don't support that theory that has
been investigated time and time again
since 1982 there's been eight plus
investigations the senate select
committee now is under is doing another
investigation as a part of that
i think we agree though that um with
regards to what occurred in the 70s the
families most certainly were
deceived they were not told the proper
information they were lied to with
regards to incident information loss of
location uh there was not a serious
effort on the part of the us government
in the 70s that's why we have an issue
today uh the national alliance of
families i believe not only deals with
vietnam but also world war ii in korea
our charter and bylaw restricts the
solely to those prisoners missing and
unaccounted for in vietnam i understand
the two you won't fear together well not
with regards to appearing together we
most certainly disagree strongly on on a
number of issues with regards to the pow
mia issue i think obviously rather than
sitting and arguing for the public
consumption i think the public has a
right to hear both views in a very
cordial and adult atmosphere i'm not
saying that we banter and we
get hostile towards each other but
obviously
we are not at all
pleased with the performance of some
other members at our national meeting if
they are going to have a meeting they
most certainly have the opportunity to
have it at another time or other
location or they can even invite the
president to their own meeting if they
want to express what they expressed out
they're the ones that caused that
difficulty they're supporters of the
national alliance of families who most
certainly were the ones who instigated
and initiated the
demonstrations against the president it
was encouraged at their meeting which
was held at the same time across the
street from our national meeting so i
think fair is fair obviously this issue
is an extremely frustrating issue and if
individual organizations have views
about whether what the vietnamese are
doing or the the current government is
doing then it should be an appropriate
form of their own form to express it not
somebody else's now do people belong to
both organizations at the same time
absolutely uh there are members my
understanding there are members that are
not only members of the national league
of families but are also either members
or supporters of the national alliance
of families however i go back to our
membership our membership is 3 800 plus
it's the largest since a corporation uh
we
have an extremely strong following
throughout the country and uh we
while we represent other people's views
we are open to other people's views on
how to expedite resolution of this issue
we are looking at every possible means
that will provide answers for our
membership what does it cost to become a
member there is no cost to become a
member we are non-profit 501c3
organization humanitarian non-government
contrary to circulating rumors around
the country we are not government
affiliated we are run solely on
donations there is no membership dues to
join the organization and unfortunately
you have to have the honor of being an
mi relative
in your opinion and i want to ask our
other guests here in a moment to give us
his opinion in
in your opinion are there living
americans mia's pows still in vietnam
absolutely it's been our long-held
position that americans are still alive
in southeast asia we base this on a
number of reasons number one is the
discrepancy cases we have long
maintained that men were held against
the will at the end of the war and did
not return
the senate select committee came out
with this startling revelation as they
termed it a few months ago that was not
a startling revelation to us it is
something we have long believed and
known uh we based it on the number of
live sighting reports that continue to
flow in while it's true that many of the
reports have proven to be fabrications
many correlate to americans who have
since been accounted for there are over
a hundred
active live-siting investigations more
continue to go come in
until we have the access that the
vietnamese have committed to give us
short notice live sighting reports until
they adequately prepare for joint
investigations
we will continue to believe that there
is too much information that the
vietnamese are withholding not allowing
us to have access to for these questions
to go away until they answer the
questions of the men who are last known
alive we will continue to believe that
h bruce franklin you have a book that
you put out this year called mia myth
making in america
what's it all about
well
it's about the powmia issue obviously
which i think is from the beginning a
completely bogus issue
it was an issue that actually predated
the end of the war
it was an issue concocted by the the
richard nixon administration in january
1969
as a way to keep the war going for four
years so that nixon could attempt to
settle it on his terms
and i don't think one can understand the
post-war belief
in the continuing existence
of pows in china without understanding
that history of how the issue was used
to manipulate american opinion for four
years from january 1969 to january 1973.
in your opinion are there any americans
still alive that are mias or pows in
vietnam
well we simply do not have a single
shred of verifiable or even credible
evidence that any american prisoners
were withheld by any of the governments
of indochina after the war in fact
all the evidence that has been subject
to
examination
that people could actually look at has
been proved to be bogus
for example all the pictures that were
circulated last summer
the committee is spending 1.9 million
dollars this year the select money in
the senate to uh and they have 12
senators involved and 20 staff people is
that money well spent
well i think some of what the committee
is doing is is worthwhile i think that
there are some fundamental problems
with the framework of assumptions that
the committee is operating within
and one has to recognize something about
the history of that committee itself
where it came from what its sources were
and for example uh senators helms
grassley and smith
uh were instrumental
in creating helping to create the myth
of pows which and i use the term myth
in a very
uh
specific way to refer to something which
has real religious power these three
senators were responsible for helping to
create that myth in the 1980s
uh let me interrupt just to ask you do
you think that richard nixon or these
three senators sat down and said to
themselves
we want to do this on purpose to
fool the american people to prolong the
war for four years so that more people
can be killed or ended injured or
whatever well as far as as far as nixon
i mean
this is really not subject to debate
because the evidence is
uh across the river in alexandria in the
nixon archives i mean it's thoroughly
documented there
that they created this for that
what they were doing was using that was
using this to manipulate the american
people there's a real irony involved
here uh in 1971
a hundreds of vietnam veterans staged an
anti-war demonstration through their
medals over the fence at the capitol one
of those veterans was john kerry
a hero who was wounded
he testified to the senate foreign
relations committee in april
immediately
haldeman
wrote to the other members of the nixon
white house and in a panic-stricken mode
and said that what they had to do at
this point was keep the wives in line
that was the quote from this secret
document
in order to counter the veterans
anti-war movement
and he got a response three days later
from general hughes
who cited alexander hague and said that
it's absolutely essential that we quote
keep the wives on the reservation for
the next six weeks because of the
veterans anti-war movement
and if and if you i'm just citing two
brief examples the evidence in those in
those archives is overwhelming that this
was very carefully staged to manipulate
american opinion and
to achieve another goal which was to
deadlock the paris peace accord
talks for four years and they did this
by demanding that hanoi and the southern
insurgents
release all american pows as a
precondition for our agreeing to
begin to discuss terms of ending the war
now this is this is crazy it's a
preposterous and unprecedented demand
warring powers
figure out how to settle the war then
they exchanged prisoners but what nixon
was able to do with major help from ross
perot which i again document in detail
in the book was to convince the american
people that hanoi by not releasing our
prisons as a precondition to ending the
war was using our men as
hostages ransom and bargaining chips the
three key terms of the post-war myth
mary backley the national league of
families reaction where do i begin
well i would have to begin with mr
franklin's reference to the nixon
administration concocting the powmi
issue i cannot concoct cases documented
cases of men who are known to have been
alive in captivity at the end of the war
that is not made up that is true there's
facts there's credible evidence there's
physical evidence to substantiate that
i cannot concoct or or make up the
president's reference to all the pows
our home at the end of the war when that
is not a true statement it was not a
true statement when it was made
obviously that is not a that is not a
statement to keep the war going that is
a statement to get the war get the issue
get the pwm issue behind you and move on
that is something that we adamantly
demonstrated against um concocting is is
a total falsehood in that respect
because there's too much documentation
that strongly suggests that where are
these men why haven't they been returned
home with regards to um
the vietnamese i have to i must i i have
to address the fact is that they are the
ones who have the answers what happened
in history has happened historians are
going to be able to to write about that
obviously dr franklin and i have have
very severe disagreements on this issue
however the league sticks with the facts
we have to stick with the facts we
cannot raise false hopes for the
families number one we have to deal with
the fact that men were known to have
been alive they have not come home there
is live citing reports there is strong
evidence that the vietnamese are
withholding information they are not
allowing us access to live siting
reports they are not allowing us access
to archives it took us 16 years to get
an 84-page document that general bessie
received last year
which has startling credible good
information that could resolve several
cases why hasn't taken us 16 years the
vietnamese are in a position if they
want to improve relations if they want
to move on with the united states they
are in a position to do so they have to
make the decision the policy is there
it's been spelt out for them they have
continued to manipulate this the
american people and the families dr
franklin's going to be with us for a lot
longer than our guest mary backley so
we're going to take a phone call here
we'll give you plenty of chance to uh
respond virginia beach uh virginia go
ahead please brian hi this is to mary
i have two separate things that i want
to tell you about on june 23rd senator
smith who is the co-chair of the powmi
committee
in a news conference said that the
administration is blocking
efforts to obtain information on pows
he said that the committee has evidence
that vietnam had live pows as late as
1989.
the second thing i want to tell you is
on july the 8th on the 700 club
it was reported that richard allen had
testified that in 1981
vietnam had offered 57 live pows for 4
billion
and that president reagan had turned him
down on that same program
a former senate staffer
bill hendon h-e-n-d-o-n
reported that the
committee was destroying documents they
were shredding documents
and that i would like for you and all of
the
families to know about that information
and check into that thanks well i
appreciate the phone call with regards
to the united states government blocking
efforts that's obviously an appropriate
question for the us government however
the best of my understanding the
president has just signed an order an
executive order authorizing
declassification of all pow mia
information
with the exception of information that
has to deal with ongoing negotiations
and intelligence efforts so i don't call
that blocking it's actually i've
attended many of the hearings that the
senate select committee has had and
senator kerry in addition to speaking to
our families at our annual meeting
emphasized that the president has been
extremely cooperative on the powmi issue
and very supportive and helping the
committee in whatever capacity what
would what would you do if this
committee decided at the end that there
are no living americans over there
well
that's that's a big fear for us because
a committee of congress cannot resolve
this issue the families have lived
through the senate the subcommittee
chaired by
congressman sonny montgomery in 1978
they lived through the woodcock
commission
both of those committees or commissions
concluded that no americans were alive
in southeast asia in addition these uh
sunny montgomery select committee also
concluded that there was little to no
chance for further accountability of any
americans well ironically since that
time over 230 americans have been
accounted for while it is true we have
not seen the return of a live american
uh with the exception of bobby garwood
and robert schwab in 1983
a committee of congress cannot conclude
this issue can they cannot say whether
or not men are there or not it takes the
responsible serious implementation of
agreements that the vietnamese
consistently make for the past 10 years
to do something but they don't implement
them and it's going to take the
vietnamese to resolve this issue and
their serious cooperation
well i'm glad you brought up the
montgomery committee because sonny
montgomery was the member of congress
absolutely most vociferous in the belief
in live pows he persuaded the house to
set up this committee they conducted an
investigation for 15 months which in my
view in many ways is a better
investigation than the one presently
being conducted and the proof of that is
in the five volumes of hearings
the montgomery ended up conclu after
being absolutely convinced that there
were live pows there
completely convinced that there were no
live powers he did not say as as you
claimed that he said and it was in 76
not 78 that there was little or no
chance of further accountability what
the committee concluded was that there
was no possibility of a complete
accounting this is impossible in a war
it's never been true in any previous war
they asked for the discrepancy cases the
government at that time was saying that
they were 56 or 54 or 53 they had three
different numbers they had only 36
discrepancy cases of those there was
evidence of capture only for eleven the
committee concluded that one of those
was still alive
and that was robert garland
and so the committee has been proven to
be right and every single conclusion
that it drew published in 1976 and the
hearings themselves are just a mine of
information that
information that was gathered when the
trails were warm not after two not after
two decades of the myth-making process
which i described in the book the
committee also well i'd be glad to share
with you the report which i'm sure you
have seen where i can most certainly
reference where they say there is little
to no chance for further accountability
with regards complete accountability oh
we totally agree with that the families
are not unrealistic of course in every
war you're never going to get a complete
and full accounting they are not realist
they are they are very realistic however
with regards to this war to the vietnam
war there are many cases of men
discrepancy cases men who have died in
captivity where are their remains why
haven't they been returned
the sunny montgomery committee traveled
to vietnam spoke to the vietnamese they
turned over the remains they said they
had no more live pows they were not
holding any more remains they took them
at their word lo and behold 200 230 come
out in the next 13 years
ironically many of those shows show
evidence of storage so i i think the
question sugar should go back to where
the blame and the guilt belongs what why
haven't they provided us with this
information what are they after
obviously
they first they do not have the
scientific capabilities that we have
they have 200 000 mias of their own but
that's the most conservative estimate
they they find remains they try to
identify them which is which is why
their warehouse and trying to understand
this issue i was on a call-in program a
few weeks ago and someone called up and
said
my family has been trying to find out
about a family member of ours for a long
time we know he was captured we know
where he was held we know the name of
the prison camp where he was held at the
end of the war he never showed up where
was the prison camp in wisconsin he said
what
it was a confederate soldier who had
actually sent letters to family members
and at the end of the war it wasn't
there and this happened to many soldiers
in the civil war
the astonishing thing about the vietnam
war is how few discrepancy cases there
are how few unaccounted for there are
let me enter because i got to grab this
call from alexandria virginia go ahead
please good afternoon uh dr franklin i
have a
multi-part question for you i find that
your treatment of the facts is rather
breathtaking when you make a sweeping
statement that uh in nowhere in
indochina are there mias or were there
mias and you make no reference to the
nation of laos
uh and ms beckley i find your
self-control admirable dr franklin could
you address that issue well actually i
have a whole chapter on on laos
in the book and what i said what i said
was not that there are of course there
are of course there are mias and the
fact that you're using that term in that
way shows the genius of
the nixon administration and confusing
the issue confusing between pows and
mias by inventing this new category of
p-o-w-m-i-a
suggesting that any person missing might
be a prisoner of course of course there
are people missing in in any war
the
my answer to the question was not no
there's definitely nobody there my
answer to the question was that there is
no verifiable or credible evidence there
is no way possible to disprove the
existence of something you i mean that's
that's why so many people see elvis or
people see alligators in their sewer
system in every major
city in the country they're people who
believe that they're living alligators
you cannot disprove their existence what
we have to do and try to understand well
are there aren't there
as far as questions of policy belief
what we should do as a society so is
what is the evidence where is the
evidence and when we look at that
evidence what we find over and over
again is that most of it is just plain
phony bogus fraudulent some of it is
mistaken and some of it just has not
been resolved such as the 109 unresolved
live citing cases
there is a also a disagreement with
regards to the number of discrepancy
cases i've heard numbers bantered about
from 135 to 109 to 45.
there's a tremendous difference in in
people's opinions with regards to
numbers we know that the vietnamese can
resolve
cases hundreds of cases if they make the
decision to do so again i go back to the
facts i go back to the men who were
known to have been alive in captivity at
the end of the war i go to the fact that
the vietnamese how many are we talking
about sir it's more than a handful i can
tell you that much it is more than a
handful we have discrepancy cases of men
many families are involved um the senate
select committee 11. we're
the senate select committee themselves
has brought it down to i believe the
numbers was 135 that the vietnamese most
certainly should have information about
now that's more than 11. now with
regards to the remaining families there
is a tremendous amount of questions that
remain uh granted i go back to the
reality that the families do not expect
to complete accounting but they also
expect
an answer what we are asking i i note
over the past three years we have 18
joint operations with vietnam that's the
tremendous amount of pr they have gotten
how many americans have we accounted for
as a result of those operations only
five so one more call and then we have
to let mary beckley go mission viejo
california go ahead please yes how are
you doing today brian fine go ahead um i
uh wish that you could have got senator
kerry or the staffer to take some
questions because i've contacted their
office senator carabion spent about an
hour over about the last um seven or
eight months i've been calling them back
and forth and i have some information i
was stationed in vietnam and i went to
bangkok thailand
and i uh the cia and uh american embassy
tried to recruit me to go train troops
in cambodia
and you call them and they tell you
they're gonna call you back and get your
statement and everything and that's all
you hear but that's the end of it i
guess there's just certain things they
don't want to talk about and
i hope that mrs backley you know sticks
with it because they're still covering
up a lot of things i mean i
i have a friend i haven't seen in 23
years or talked to and he could have
confirmed it through him what happened
all right thanks name caller i do not
but my recommendation to you is that you
have to call or call you at your
your headquarters i certainly hope the
caller would follow up and call me at
two 202-223-6846 six eight four six two
oh two two two three
six eight four six go ahead you wanna
you have anything more you wanna say to
the caller no i i would like to again
follow up with regards to the cover-up
again i refer back to my previous
conversation my previous comments with
regards to the issue itself i think if
it wasn't for the lack of seriousness
uh the lack of
adequate attention and the deception
that was to the families we would not
have the
pwmi issue today if we had the
seriousness with which the issue is
being addressed today back in the 70s i
don't think this issue would exist
however we don't so we have to focus on
what we have we didn't so we have to
focus on what we have today uh we have
to focus on the increased assets the
increased resources you can put either a
hundred men or ten hundred men
on the ground in vietnam it's not going
to mean anything unless you get the
access unless the vietnamese give you
the access it's great pr for them around
the world but we're not getting the
answers mary beckley is director of
operations for the national league of
families p-o-w-m-i-a issue thank you
very much for joining us thank you this
afternoon it's my pleasure professor
franklin will be with us for a little
while longer but we're going to take
just a short break so we can ask our
other guest tom ashworth who's with the
national alliance of families to join us
as we said earlier we had a viewer
response line back during the memorial
day first running of vietnam revisited
we heard from over 3000 people here is a
bit of what some of them had to say at
that time
my comment was how do we know that
knowing that that committee was coming
that they didn't transfer the prisoners
or put them into hiding
it just seems very possible to me that
that would happen you tell kerry and
smith unless they subpoena nixon and
kissinger under oath the whole thing is
whistling in the wind they're getting
nowhere those two liars have to be put
under oath furthermore uh during the
period late 74 to early 75 while in the
joint jesus after i witnessed numerous
analysis of americans being moved
approximately 20 12 to 15 of them into
eastern bloc nations and into the soviet
union for interrogation
i was in vietnam for eight years and
i know that some of those people could
possibly still be alive
my question is japanese could
survive through world war ii it just
come out
a couple of years ago why can't i people
yeah i think you're looking in the wrong
places for life and my age i think you
should be looking in thailand maybe
you'll have more
[ __ ] there i served in the army around
donghae vietnam
and
what about i was thinking what about all
the tunnels that that whole nation is
full of tunnels that probably under the
tunnel very good program uh i am a
vietnam veteran please comment on the
drug trafficking
with uh government
individuals uh
put in there to fight the war that are
still there now dealing drugs back to
different countries i was calling just
to say that i haven't heard anybody make
any statements in reference to
anyone in any mia that was over there
after 27 years since my husband has come
home
nobody made a comment to the fact that
maybe some of those people have had
their minds twisted to the point that
they don't want to come home i think it
would be very beneficial to list all the
mias and the pod pows on your
tv screen so that maybe some of the
vietnam vets that
may know
some information perhaps
one of their buddies was killed and
perhaps it wasn't
um
put on the screen you know they don't
know about it and it might answer some
questions
yeah
that's a retired navy
and i spent some time off the coast of
vietnam gunfire support
i am proud of been there my biggest
complaint about the way press handled
the vietnamese situation
was running box scores if you will
across the screen during the news
number of
wounded killed in action i just heard a
guest say that they weren't lying about
the war in vietnam that is
blatantly
a lie in itself they lied constantly
our commander rescue forces over there
and when i'd come in from
going to a christ side that that's me if
there were holes in the airplane or if
there were holes in the individuals
because they had a rule if there were no
holes and it wasn't lost to combat your
cinema verite production on vietnam is
not only great theater it is truly
professional objective journalism
congratulations and thank you you all
pat yourself on the back about press
conference coverage my perception is
that the press has become
more timid when confronting government
policy and more sensitive to
television ratings yes i'm a college
student and i
generally feel that
kids my age don't really have a sense of
what happened in vietnam no one seems to
talk about it and it's not taught in
school
yet i feel that
through the um
operation desert storm
people my age for the first time got a
real effect of what war was like and
what it entailed and
i think there should be more education
what has the press really learned in
dealing with the united states
government after vietnam how many
reporters can attend the white house
press conference today and ask any
questions of the president
i will believe the press is really doing
their job well and learned well from
vietnam
when they all walk out of the white
house press conference if they are not
free to ask any questions of the
president that they deem important
dr bruce franklin the author of m.i.a or
myth-making in america why did you write
the book in the first place what what
got you interested in this subject
well i've been writing about
the vietnam war and its effects on on
america for over a quarter of a century
and i
gradually became aware that this belief
is an extremely important fact of
american life today uh i mean we've been
talking so far just about the question
are there aren't there
pows
what has the government been doing about
investigating
and certainly i do deal with that
at length in the book but that's not the
main subject of the book the main
subject of the book is the function of
this belief in american society today
the history of that belief and how it
works
why it has the effects that it has
how it serves as an instrument of policy
and also how it serves as part of our
culture you're at rutgers russia's
university of newark what do you teach
there
i teach a course in the vietnam war and
america it's coffee is called vietnam in
america
and much interest in it
it's always over enrolled
the only problem is finding a room to
fit how come a large number of students
so often when i ask the question of
people all over the country who
are in schools and high schools and
colleges they say they don't know
anything about the vietnam well that's
one of the things i deal deal with the
very first day of class i mean i asked
the class
when did they become aware of the war
and
to what extent did they learn anything
about the war during their schooling and
typically
i would i would say we're talking about
one or two percent of the students have
actually had any contact with the war in
the classroom prior to choosing to take
this course what's the impetus for them
to take your course then
well it's it's it's quite mixed uh i
mean this year i noticed uh i just got
the roster there's several vietnamese uh
american students in there but there are
many people who really are concerned
they are aware that this is very
important in american life i mean
if we if we look at it i think we have
to recognize that the vietnam war is not
over
that it's not over either as a war
between the united states and vietnam
nor is it over as a war inside our own
society and if you if you say the words
vietnam war in any group of americans
you can feel the emotional
temperature rising in your book you
write about uh cbs 60 minutes producer
monica jensen stevenson and her husband
william stevenson uh who wrote this book
kiss the boys goodbye
uh was it popular it's been very popular
and it's i believe it's hold well over a
hundred thousand and its premise is
that there's a vast government
conspiracy because of government
and cia involvement in the drug trade to
conceal the existence of live pows what
do you think of that premise well i
think what they're doing is misusing
some excellent research on the relations
between the cia and the drug trade which
are represented in al mccoy's book the
politics of heroin
but but i mean the book is so filled
with just uh mistakes uh contradictions
really irresponsible handlings you're
talking about a woman that is a producer
of 60 minutes the most popular on the
show right yeah but it's i mean it's
really
uh
it's
it's disgraceful that any publisher let
a lot of that stuff go through uh i'm
just the obvious
internal contradictions in the book and
the and the errors in fact that you that
filled the book we used i used it i used
to quote earlier you you
you debunk almost everything that's ever
been written about since you say the
belief in live pows
was based not just on political rhetoric
rumors in the pow rescue movies but also
on a sizable body of books pamphlets and
articles that had promulgated a coherent
and superficially plausible
pseudo-history compounded of
self-deception amateur research
anecdotes half-truths phony evidence
slick political and media manipulation
downright lies and
near religious fervor
you're condemning
lots of works
true
why
and are you you know do what do people
what's people's reaction see when i when
i
started working on this book i mean
actually it wasn't supposed to be a book
it was supposed to be a chapter in a
book but i had assumed that there would
be some really responsible scholarship
out there on an issue of this importance
and what i found was it just didn't
exist
thomas and and one of the one of the
problems is that is that the material
which is published although sometimes it
has footnotes or endnotes
what looks like uh
documentation when you go to verify that
documentation you cannot verify it
independently which is one of the tests
that you have to apply to a work of
scholarship or a research the reader has
to be able to go and check that
documentation for himself or herself all
my documentation every reader can go
check for himself or herself and that's
a test which is failed by all the other
material out there tom ashworth is
sitting across the table from you and
he's with the national alliance of
families i suspect you disagree with dr
franklin well slight understatement
it's the myth of the myth that we're
dealing with
why
why is he wrong
because he's apparently not a researcher
he's done no credible research
he at times accepts
misinformation outright lies by our
defense department and presents that as
the truth
we should point out
based on what i've just heard it is
disturbing and he's also a gentleman who
claimed that stalin had been maligned
for his crimes at one point in time
true
well i don't know if we want to get off
in the stalin question i wrote in his i
wrote a
i edited a collection of stalin's
writings so that people could see the
writings and i have a historical
introduction about stalin
it's published by a major trade
publisher
it's not
not exactly a
skeleton in the closet
i've also also i also post a book about
robert heinlein
which has somewhat different politics i
would suggest that anyone who would like
this cleared up read a book called the
best defense by alan dershowitz that'll
define what the gentleman's attitude
towards stalin is
you both look to me like you feel rather
deeply about the subject is that safe to
assume yes
and
are your beliefs on this issue
political in other words
are you both being driven by a political
belief beyond the issue of pow mias no
political belief at all
the the sad thing for me
is to say that the vietnamese at times
tell the truth and our government lies
on occasion you can catch our government
telling the truth but only on rare
occasion
well we have a point of agreement
can i ask you tom ashford some questions
about yourself mary beckley was on here
earlier and she's with the national
league of families
i understand you two don't
get along or don't sit there the two
organizations don't sit down together
i'm more than willing to sit down with
her i think they're afraid of the tough
questions that we can ask them in public
so they hide what's the difference in
the two organizations how big is the
national league of your national
alliance of families as i understand it
thousands of people work with the the
alliance of families i should point out
while they claim vast numbers 3 800
they cannot get a quorum at their annual
meetings because they have so little
support and when they say that few
people were actually dissatisfied with
the president the hall was filled with
their people who had been denied access
outside were other members there was a
great number of family members who were
exceedingly upset with this
administration and its reluctance to
come to terms with this problem how big
is how many people work for your
organization
i'm a researcher with the organization
you should ask dolores alfond as i
understand they're represented in most
of the states can you give are you here
in washington
uh no i was called in to give a
deposition before the senate select
committee and that's the reason where do
you live i live in fort smith arkansas
and do you spend full time working as a
researcher for the organization uh i
work
i'm aligned with them i actually do not
work for them i work for myself in a
sense i've worked on this eight years
full-time
why
because friends of mine who were the
cia's top indigenous agents in laos told
me of over 200 americans who were
knowingly abandoned by this government
when i tried to get our defense
intelligence agency to interview these
people they refused to do it when i told
them of the exact location of account in
october 1983
they then broke contact with me their
response later was the dias was to call
me a communist why why why are they so
upset with you
i think the problem with our government
is simply this it's been the policy of
the government of the united states to
abandon
living american prisoners of war since
world war one
i have carefully studied this issue from
world war one through world war ii
through the korean war through the cold
war through the vietnam war it's a
consistent pattern it happens war end
and war out i have personally been
through over 600 000 pages of documents
in the national archives i've read over
300 books i've traveled from rhode
island to california northern michigan
to texas interviewing people on this
i have a master's degree in political
science and i will put my skills and
those of other people i work with up
against anybody from rutgers or any
other university that puts out this type
of nonsense
well i mean
if you're going to call it nonsense what
you have to do
is find errors in the book and although
obviously my book is extremely
controversial
nobody has yet been able to find an
error in it there may there probably are
errors
but i certainly feel that if you're
dealing with a subject like this
you have a responsibility to put your
work out in public to show your
documentation
and to do everything you can to make
sure your your work is error free and
responsible
so respond
what exactly we're talking about i'd
like to get back to i'd like to get back
to the issue and not deal with the your
personal personal attacks let's deal
with specificity
the fundamental question has to be why
in the world would vietnam hold any
americans after the war i mean what what
possible motive could they have
so in addition to the fact that we have
no
verifiable evidence that there are live
pows we have essentially nonsensical and
illogical
explanation for the behavior of a nation
mind if i respond to that
let's listen to what the north the
vietnamese say let's go before let me
just ask you how long did you you served
in what service u.s marine corps for how
long four and a half years when were you
in vietnam 1969 and where were you
stationed i was at fubai and aboard the
lph to the iwo jima and were you ever
m.i.a or a pow i was not okay go ahead
why would the vietnamese hold them
in 1975 when the senate or the house
select committee on the mis traveled to
hanoi
and asked about or missing
the vietnamese responded by saying yes
and we'd like to know about our money
the two things are connected they said
that then they continue to say that for
years and years let me read one
statement by the vietnamese and maybe if
we can't believe me or our government
let's say if the doctor would like to
believe the vietnamese
this is quoted from a radio hanoi
english service broadcast
may the 20th 1977
under the title quote washington tries
to shirk the responsibility it has
assumed the hungarian newspaper people's
freedom oregon of the hungarian
socialist workers party on may 18th said
quote
washington fans to desire rapid
normalization of relations with vietnam
but everyone knows that the u.s has
always tried to shirk its responsibility
to contribute to healing the wounds of
war in vietnam as provided for by the
paris agreement the paper continued
quote paradoxically enough while the u.s
evades its responsibility to fulfill its
duty under article 21 of the paris
agreement article 21 meaning money to
the vietnamese which we agreed to it
urges that vietnam implement article 8b
example to continue the
search for and provide the u.s with
information about the u.s military
personnel missing in the aggressive war
in laos if the u.s wants to normalize
its relations with vietnam it must
fulfill its obligation the paper
stressed over and over and they have
many times directly connected the
missing to the money over and over in
the paris agreement
and in the non-agreement on laos
kissinger agreed that the uh we would
provide the promise of the money in
return for the list of the our prisoners
held in laos
that's that's not true it's not true and
this is where this history that's what i
mean by pseudo-history what actually
happened
the paris peace accords were signed on
january 27 1973. they were essentially
represented capitulation by the united
states article 21 which is cited
the thing that tom is quoting is right
it says the united states will
contribute to the democratic republic of
vietnam that is north vietnam healing
the wounds of war that was january 27th
on february 2nd richard nixon wrote a
secret letter to fam van dong premier of
hanoi promising three and a quarter
billion dollars of aid and then with an
addendum saying there might be another
billion or a billion and a and a and a
quarter
and
as uh brian is showing it's an appendix
in my book
how did this letter get to hanoi henry
kissinger brought that letter to hanoi
in february 73 prior to the completion
of operation homecoming this was just a
few days after
the paris peace accords have been signed
this was a colisal to the paris peace
accords so kissinger brought that letter
here was the pledge which the vietnamese
had insisted upon
with one hand he brought something else
in another hand
he brought a list of 80 so-called
discrepancy cases 80 people who he said
that vietnam had to account for now
in september of 73 henry kissinger was
being considered for secretary of state
and in his confirmation hearings he
testified before the united states
senate what he said in those hearings
and this is where the linkage occurs
this is where the linkage occurs not
from hanoi from washington and it's
right there and again this is verifiable
in the senate's own records kissinger
said we are not going to normalize
relations with vietnam we are not going
to contribute to rebuilding vietnam
because they have not satisfactorily
accounted for this list of 80 that i
brought to them in february 1973 he did
not mention the secret letter
which the government kept denying
existed until the montgomery committee
actually went to hanoi
and were given
copies of part of the text of that
letter we have a call waiting and tom
ashford if you want to give us just give
us 20 seconds if you can so i can
there's people those folks in san
francisco are spending money the
vietnamese government say both are
connected the missing and the money they
say that the accounting for the missing
was always related to the money
kissinger himself admits to that that uh
from his own book lee duct toe and i had
agreed that the message would be
delivered on january 30 1973 three days
after the agreement was signed in
exchange for a list of american
prisoners held in laos the communists
have repeatedly said that also all right
which which which is very different from
kissinger's sworn testimony before the
senate but you see so the argument that
look let's be let's try to be use our
common sense the argument that vietnam
is holding prisoners as bargaining ships
first of all the problem is how do you
borrow with chips you swear you don't
hold but let's say let's go with your
let's go with your analysis
of what's going on in in 73 and the and
this is the argument which is presented
by you and many others with your
position that is that vietnam was
holding the prisoners because we re we
reneged on the three and a quarter
billion dollars hold on so they want the
money but let me just this
okay
then in 75 with the fall of saigon they
captured 71 more americans so if really
what they wanted was to exchange
americans for money they could have at
that point said okay you haven't given
us our money we have 71 more americans
give us our money now that's not what
they did san francisco
san francisco thank you for your
patience i know it cost you a lot of
money go ahead please hi
this is uh directed towards the
gentleman from i guess the family the
alliance of families national alliance
of families right uh i just wanted to
tell him that i watched that committee
hearing that ross pro testified before
and there was one thing that i agreed
with him on was that if there's one man
left over there that isn't accounted for
or is still there we ought to do
something about it but to this gentleman
here i'd like to ask him a question i'd
like to ask him if he thought it was an
appropriate way that they treated the
president of the united states if he
thought that it gained support for his
cause because frankly it turned me off
the way they treated him i was appalled
at their rudeness i just thought it was
caller are you involved in this issue
personally at all are you just a watcher
i'm a watcher i'm 43 years old i'm a
nurse i went to college during the whole
era and i'm very interested in the whole
situation but
i just thought that the way they treated
the president united states was
appalling stay on the line so you can
answer tom ashford go ahead
i
in a sense i hate to speak for family
members but i will say this knowing many
of them i know one family in oklahoma
they gave up hope
and there were two suicides in one
family i personally know of four
suicides the government lies and lies
and lies to its people
and some become distraught and kill
themselves others stood up to the
president a man
who represents an administration that
lies to them day in and day out and i
feel great sympathy for people who live
with this burden
and who are lied to daily by their own
government san francisco
i i sympathize certainly with anybody
that suffered over this issue i mean i
can't even imagine it i haven't suffered
that way however i totally
totally disagree with the man saying
that the president lies because he
fought for his country he served his
country time and time again in world war
ii and i think it's a it's very
disrespectful thing you're doing sir
thanks for the call let's go to salem
virginia next go ahead please hi brian
hi i've been watching your segment all
day here today one admonishment for you
in an earlier
portion you discussed the
vietnamese and the bureaucracy and
whatnot coming to this country
has the winners and us the losers i
don't think we ever lost anything in
vietnam as a vietnam veteran i can't
remember any engagements face to face
with the viet cong or the north
vietnamese that this country lost
two quick questions by the way but not
to argue with it i just wanted to tell
you what what i was saying what i was
trying to say there was their perception
we were talking about visiting hanoi and
their perception there that they won and
the
that they still treat us not as an enemy
that's what the point i was trying to
make but that's well taken go ahead with
your points okay thank you
um in terms of the question about live
p.o.w.s which seems to be what
mr franklin is disputing
i'd like to know if either of these
gentlemen know of any efforts that have
been made to contact various military
units and their op reports i know as a
veteran one of the missions that i was
on over there was to go out and
literally look for
a
united states serviceman
who we were told was out with the viet
cong in the bush north of bongsong which
was in two core in the central highlands
operational reports it seems to me if
proper research is done would reflect
what various missions were conducted by
different combat units in the field i'm
not talking about your rear type but
nonetheless would shed information on
what the results of those
efforts were
and uh the same applies to francis
zenwig earlier i don't know if this
select committee is looking into what
actual veterans experienced in their
day-to-day field experiences but i know
in my unit there were at least three
different occasions that we were sent
out to in fact look for
uh american servicemen who were reported
to have been in the captivity of the
vietnamese all right sir thanks
response from either gentlemen
there are reports of americans who serve
the communist units and uh there are
very few a number of them and there
apparently were some who did in fact
serve but there are a great vast number
of reports of americans held in
captivity who were never released
well yeah certainly i mean i mean the
most obvious case is robert garwood and
i i have uh i mean just looking at the
literature
talk directly with some of the people
involved in searching for him such as
barry romo who was uh at that time the
first lieutenant this unit was out there
looking for the salt the so-called salt
and pepper team would you i hate to do
it would you tell the audience somebody
that's never heard of robert garwood who
he is because his name is robert garwood
was somebody who was captured
by
the insurgents in the south
and went over to the other side uh he he
guarded uh fellow prisoners
and after the war elected to stay but to
stay in north vietnam there was a
testimony about him offered at the
montgomery committee and they concluded
that he probably was still alive
uh in north vietnam came out when he
came out he came out in 1979
uh and he was he was court-martialed and
convicted on so seven counts
the witnesses the witnesses against
garawood were the american soldiers whom
he had guarded
in the guerrilla prison camp in the
south tom ashford
the witness against garwood i've heard
i know some have given depositions and
at least one has said that he was
pressured and threatened by this
government
to make those statements there is no
evidence that garwood was ever given the
chance to come home he had to slip out
two notes the first one
was actually destroyed but when the man
told our government about it it was
ignored it was the second note that got
him out and that note also stated that
he knew of others i was a marine officer
a marine colonel lieutenant colonel by
the name of miller collaborated with the
enemy came home is an honorable
quote honorable retired officer drawing
his pension and when a marine private
came home this government butchered him
apparently for the one reason that he
was aware of living americans and they
wanted him so discredited that he could
not would not be credible to the
american people you know again fact
facts are facts you know and and fantasy
is fantasy and the fact here is that the
men guarded by garwood actually
published their stories about him before
he came out when they certainly were not
any government pressure to besmirch
garwood's fair reputation let me grab
this call because we have a
stacking them up long island go ahead
please uh yeah hi um i'm 43 years old
and um
i was in vietnam and i was in a long
range reconnaissance patrol
and uh one of the major responsibilities
of this kind of patrol was to monitor
the traffic
going uh
down through laos and cambodia
and
i think what people fail to realize is
the lack of cooperation
between certain areas of those two
countries uh to even their local
governments i don't think a lot of these
prisoners war ever made it up to north
um i i don't think you're gonna find
a whole lot of prisoners sitting in some
stupid bunker somewhere in hanoi
to me that sounds ridiculous uh you know
you had uh cambodian and laotian rebels
and uh
they they weren't afraid to attack uh
either american soldiers or uh uh north
vietnamese uh uh they would attack them
kill them and loot them all right sir
thanks uh because senator smith is on
the line i want to grab this call and
we'll possibly come back and talk about
what the gentleman just uh
just was referring to senator smith can
you hear us sir sure
thanks for for uh spending some time
we're trying to again uh deal with this
issue of the mi pow select committee and
your activities and the discussion here
that's going on this afternoon give us
we've we're going to show later on the
week the trip to the mekong delta back
in april
as you know we've shown a lot of the
hearing since then
what in your opinion has changed
in your investigation since the april
trip
if anything
well i think uh a significant uh number
of things i mean we have worked on a
huge amount of information we've
reviewed
hundreds of live citing reports
we have
some of the things that i can't i can't
get into at this time
specific with real a lot of specifics
but as you know there there is an
alleged offer
uh which we have to investigate uh on
american pows during the reagan
administration in 1981 we were trying to
get to the bottom of that i mentioned
the live citing reports
we have hearings scheduled which will
get into
some of the
intelligence other types of intelligence
that we may have received we're going to
be hearing have a hearing on the paris
peace accords coming uh that we've we've
uncovered numerous documents uh which
would lend a great deal of credibility
to the fact that that americans were not
accounted for and were in fact alive
when we left uh
vietnam in 1973. senator smith are you
and senator kerry in agreement at this
stage as to what's going on
well i think we are but you know
basically i mean there you can get into
semantics and definitions i mean i uh
have made the statement and i stand by
the statement that there is evidence
that americans were were left behind and
i think that uh
i i will let other senators speak for
themselves i feel very strongly about
that i stand behind that statement uh
and that not only were they left behind
that that they may even be alive today
and that uh when when all of the
committee uh hearings are over and when
the documents and evidence
uh are put out to the american people uh
i'll let the american people and the
reporters uh decide whether or not what
i said was accurate when i said there
was evidence but i'm saying that there
is evidence yes are you going to try to
reach a conclusion as a committee the 12
of you together that everybody stands by
well i think the main that we'll be able
to conclude we'll be able to make very
definitive conclusions on some things
and other things it won't be that easy
but i but i think the tragedy of all
this
is that in in spite of uh
some comments to the contrary over the
past uh few weeks and months
we are not getting uh the total
cooperation and i say total uh they may
even be alive today
and that uh when when all of the
committee uh hearings are over and when
the documents and evidence are are
put out to the american people
i'll let the american people and the
reporters
decide whether or not what i said was
accurate when i said there was evidence
but i'm saying that there is evidence
yes are you going to try to reach a
conclusion as a committee the 12 of you
together that everybody stands by
well i think the main that we'll be able
to we'll be able to make very definitive
conclusions on some things and other
things it won't be that easy but i but i
think the tragedy of all this
is that in in spite of uh
some comments to the contrary over the
past few weeks and months
we are not getting the total cooperation
and i say total cooperation of our own
government i mean it is it is very
difficult for us to to pry out this
information
we are the oversight committee here but
uh you know it would be nice if all this
information came willingly now are we
getting information yes we're getting
more information than ever before we've
declassified tens of thousands of
documents but are we getting total uh
unobstructed total cooperation the
answer is no we're not not as much as we
need we have to dig dig dig but it ought
to be coming to us rather than us having
to go to them to get it all now watching
you at the hearings a few weeks ago you
became quite irritated with a group
testifying and you walked up and or you
had them go to this
photograph in which you suspected that
the photograph had been flipped and uh
i'm going to get more confused for
everyone if i try to describe it anymore
what were you getting at why were you so
irritated
well because i had asked for
imagery of a certain area
of downtown hanoi the area was called
the citadel uh i had requested it uh
several days prior to the hearing i did
not get it
and finally after the day after the
hearing started or the morning of the
hearing i don't recall which i don't
have my notes here in front of me
i received a series of photographs which
was not which were not the photographs
that i wanted but anyway uh at a break
uh in in the hearings i began to look at
those photographs and compare them to
some of the live sighting reports to try
to see
uh whether they matched and i couldn't
understand why when people said
they turned right to see a certain place
that uh in fact you didn't see it unless
you turned left and finally i realized
that that the images were reversed and
and so it was so stated by mr distad at
the hearing that the photographs were
simply reversed much like if you take a
photograph and reverse the negative you
have a scar on the right side of your
face it'll show up on the left so that's
what they did now the question is did
they do that to me deliberately
or or not well if they did not and they
in fact uh made a mistake the question
is were the were the people who have
been debunked those those people who
those who have seen say they've seen
live americans did were they looking at
the reversed photographs as well were
they debunked because they couldn't
figure out where they were on that
street i mean this this is the kind of
stuff that has to be answered and the
bottom line is a united states senator
who requests
imagery of an area ought to be given the
right imagery there is no excuse for a
mistake like that whatsoever let me ask
you a question that a caller asked
earlier in the day and that is do you
think there are live americans hidden
under the mausoleum of ho chi minh in
hanoi
uh i believe that uh let me put it this
way we have
seven reports
seven that i know of that where
individuals talk about an underground
facility in the vicinity of that tomb
called the citadel it's west of linam
day street
six of those reports are either
unresolved that is they're under
analysis or they've received no analysis
at all by the dia now uh those are those
are the facts i mean we've got
vietnamese vietnamese army officer
we've got a
former lieutenant from the ministry of
interior we've got a doctor who claims
to have treated a patent general inside
the compound and it goes on and on and
on my point is
we ought to be the vietnamese and i i've
and i've heard that some on the
committee have made statements that the
vietnamese are being totally cooperative
well that's simply outrageous that's not
true if they're being cooperative let us
look at the citadel let us go into that
that area and if it's nothing more than
uh an underground water system as as the
vietnamese have said then fine but i say
let us go in and see that area let me go
let anybody on the committee the
senators on this committee go and check
that site out that's the way we find out
whether or not they're americans there
are you going back to vietnam for the
year's end
uh if they will if they will allow us to
have access to those locations yes if
not no
let me ask you a question as kind of a
leap from where we're talking right now
but do you well how do you feel about
the what's the possibility that after
your report is in at the end of the year
that a president
whoever is elected president will be in
a position to drop the trade embargo
with vietnam and
go back to normalized relationship
what we have established in this
committee
uh in the case of laos in vietnam is
that they're not being cooperative
they're they they are not providing us
the access i would not give them any of
that i would not give them i would i
would keep the trade embargo on i would
give them absolutely no business
whatsoever no aid no anything the only
business we ought to be doing with
vietnam is the business of accounting
for these men and i think once we do
that once we we we get that access then
then i'm more than happy to do it i
think every veteran who served there
would agree with me the the point is
let's we cannot we cannot deal with
perfidy here we've got to have the truth
and the people at the vietnamese and the
lao have not been truthful with us they
have not they have been withholding
information from us they haven't even
been candid with us on remains and and
we certainly have unanswered questions
about live americans as long as these
reports continue to surface we've got to
be able to
to get access to these locations and
frankly negotiate with them to get the
truth senator bob smith thank you very
much you're welcome
senator bob smith is from new hampshire
he's a republican he's also one of the
12 members of the select committee mia
pows in the united states senate
gentlemen any reaction to what senator
smith had to say well i mean the
accusations against vietnam are really
pretty preposterous when you look at
them
and this is one of the things that was
documented by the montgomery committee
that we have been we have been asking
the vietnamese to account for people
including people who were lost uh
dozens of miles off their coast in the
in the gulf of tonkin we've been asking
them year after year to account for
people that they could not possibly
account for and every time in the in the
recent history in the last several years
we've given them list after list we give
them one list they they try their best
or
make some efforts they account for some
they get they they they help with joint
searches tear up people's houses and
villages to dig to dig out our remains
of of planes and then as soon as that
list is more or less accounted for
they're given a very different list one
of the interesting things that has come
out of the uh senate select committee is
that there's so many different lists
floating around in the pentagon the
pentagon itself can't even keep the list
straight so as the montgomery committee
pointed out there's every reason for the
vietnamese to think that we are acting
in bad faith in this issue tom ashby
well to suggest that houses are being
torn up in vietnam and we're abusing
these poor people is ridiculous they're
paid millions of dollars for our
quote right to go over there
they are blackmailing us on this and
we're paying dearly for it but we only
pay for remains this government pays to
get back cubans it
consistently year after year since world
war one has paid to retrieve people
sometimes including americans this time
they won't do it the communists have
held americans since world war one we
paid 80 million dollars in those days to
get back american prisoners each
no 80 million total which would have
been overwhelming sorry i thought you
said 8 000.
80 million in 1945 we paid over 2
million people a million of whom died
because we traded them for americans
from the soviets
in the late 40s we paid hundreds of
thousands to get back people from
aircraft which has been shot down over
eastern europe we paid 53 million in
goods to get back cubans the americans
left in vietnam should be worth
something
freeport new york thanks for waiting
uh yeah i just uh
would like to say to dr franklin um i've
listened to you on pacifica radio and i
haven't read your book but
you seem absolutely convincing to me uh
i've watched the hearings uh et cetera i
just wanted to know your opinion
about shows like the one you're on or or
c-span in general
um doesn't it seem bizarre to you
yourself how these shows themselves
for all your comments
uh mr lam is is utterly upset by the
idea that there might not be
m.i.a
missing in vietnam uh i wonder as a
historian what you think uh when you
have such a compelling case uh and you
you're living right in the middle of a
miss
uh i just wanted to know your goal let
me just ask you i want to know this i
was i was going to speak for you but
where have i shown any upsetness over
what yeah
mr lam i don't think you really realize
your facial expressions that when you
ask a question um
well you've given so much attention to
this issue i mean there's so many real
scandals going on in the in the country
and and as as dr franklin has pointed
out you can't even say what the
motivation is
of the vietnamese to do this kind of
thing and yet you have
made such a huge thing of this in terms
of the air time that you've given to
this issue
uh and i'm i'm just telling you my own
reaction when you
ask
dr franklin gee could it really be that
there aren't a you sound as if
you look at i'm sorry you look as if
um this would be the worst thing in the
world uh that just in fact turned out to
be a an utter myth yet in fact
my own opinion is dr franklin is
absolutely convincing uh that it is a
myth there is no credible evidence when
perot uh was asked at the hearings to to
specifically give
what what the evidence was he was
absolutely unable to do so anyway i'll
just listen to you okay well i i i want
to say i want to say something in
fine lands defense i haven't interpreted
our interactions that way i mean i i
think that what you're trying to do is
to
allow the presentation of conflicting
views on something which uh deeply
troubles the american people the now
that
what bothers me about about the media
coverage is not that finally someone
with this view is allowed on but that
it's been it's been almost 20 years when
nobody with the view that i'm presenting
has been on there's been a complete
media monopoly that is the the media has
over and over again presented the whole
range of views from the government's
view which is maybe there are live pows
maybe they're not we're doing our best
to find them out to a mr ashworth view
or the view monica jensen stevenson when
she was a producer of 60 minutes uh so
that the so that the
the perception of the american people
have been very much a product of the
view including
we
in the media all the movies that uh that
i just that i discuss in the book uh
one quick thing about the attention
we've given to this the the caller
is right in a lot of ways you know and
this is an interesting problem we have
as a network we got into this thing
in the first place because there was a
lot of interest in it and now we're in
it and you can't just get out of it i
mean yeah i believe i mean i believe
that i mean i understand what he's
talking about i mean we did the same
thing we've devoted lots and lots of
time to this when there are lots and
lots of different issues but once you
get into one of these things you go back
in our history and whether it be a hud
situation or
the savings and loan scan and once you
start it
everybody's on your case they want every
little tiny bit of information so i hope
you'll understand that's one of the
reasons why
i think the unfortunate thing is well
first of all you think about what the
media did with presenting all those
phony pictures as evidence and then when
they were shown to be phonies hardly
anybody heard about that
but
by the pentagon
there's really no doubt one of the
pictures came out of a 1923 russian
magazine the other was allowed
right you can't do it
fantasy but the but the real tragedy is
how this issue
has shaped american policy and american
attitudes toward the war and allowed the
war to keep on going because from that
first week in february 1973 which i
talked about earlier when kissinger went
there from that point on every single
administration
nixon
ford
carter reagan bush every single one has
used this issue as a pretext to keep the
war going and we as a society need to
end this war so we can heal and get well
and we are an extreme case of the
families they need it too mr ash
and thank you for letting me speak
what he said is absolutely ridiculous
it's even asinine
for this reason carter offered
diplomatic relations to north vietnam in
1978
vietnam turned us down
oh and they said hey guys there's things
we have to do before this happens what
about our money what about your missing
so carter he claims was using this issue
what's your evidence for this time
newspaper articles government documents
where i'll send them to you and i'll
tell you now this is no let me make this
point see how he reacts to this see
have a show where you just respond to
this one single point and see who knows
what they're talking about
one of us is an idiot also also i'll
tell you a really good source on the
question you're raising which is paul
mather do you want to dispute paul
mother who is a man who is head of
criminal who is head of joint casualty
resolution center who knows about as
much about this issue as anyone and he
explains and and the documentation for
for the actual political history is very
clear that in 1978 when corridor was
approaching the possibility of
normalizing relations with vietnam
the carter administration decided that
they would not because china was more
important than vietnam and and they
would and they would harm relations with
they would one of us is wrong
and find out which one it is and then
point it out right paul mathers you find
out you you you produce some you produce
some evidence that the courtroom
i will absolutely produce that evidence
i should be tested on that one of us is
a literal idiot who doesn't know what
they're talking about they should be
exposed publicly let's do it let's do
that let's find out who knows what
they're talking about and who doesn't
paul mather should be pointed out was
probably the colonel who served the
longest time in world history in one
position for years and years and years
and over a decade he was apparently was
a cia operative working in air force
uniform whose job was to cover this
issue up and to quote him on this
subject is like quoting an inheritance
of adolf hitler on who was right and
what grabbed this call from escondido
california go ahead please yes my name
is todd wilson i speak vietnamese and i
i speak to a lot of vietnamese all the
time
with the garwood case uh what i see is
is is america shutting the door on the
pow's just
they
if say you're a pow trapped over there
and one day they just came over they
unlocked your cases you're free to go
what are your choices
um if you go united states you have the
fear you're going to be thrown in fort
leavenworth for the rest of your life
or
your bad
best solution probably would be to keep
your mouth shut and stay there
well i mean the garwood case once again
this is the one case that the montgomery
committee was convinced yes this guy is
still alive this is the one case of
somebody where prior to his
reappearance there was plenty of
published evidence that he had in fact
gone over to the other side guarded his
fellow prisons abused his fellow
prisoners boasted of the fact that he
was an officer and and the other side's
army and and that's again cited and
verifiable in the book you can look it
up yourself
that is published sources by the
prisoners that garwood guarded before
garwood came out
garwood did collaborate to some degree
i'm not taking up for him on that on
that but almost every prisoner did he
was a young man 19 years old who broke
under conditions of horror how many
people had a kalashnikov assault rifle
that they used to to guard
hardwood was never involved in
suppressor but let's do something that's
verifiable right at this point in time
how many discrepancy cases were there
that's a description that's an it that's
an interesting question i'll answer it
the answer is
they were at first the government said
they were 56 then they said they were
54. then they said they were 50 that is
the case of somebody believed to have
been captured but who was not either
returned as a prisoner or accounted for
as having died or
otherwise accounted for it was 56 54 53
and again this is all documented but
when the montgomery committee said to
the pentagon and said to the defense
department produce your
54 53 56 cases they had only 36 tom
scott
and the pro well right the the the thing
is
the thing he's holding up is the
document put out by the senate select
committee which is assuming that the
pentagon
is in fact minimizing the number when
the pentagon has been maximizing the
number ever since 69.
well my opinion is the man who came up
with this is a man named senator john
kerry who's a noted anti-war
leftist who to this day is uh
relatively friendly to the north
vietnamese he lists 244.
51 of these people were identified by
returning prisoners at the end of the
war
were we ever told this by our government
absolutely not it was classified and
hidden from us and not only that but
this list can has no one from laos
general tai has said that there's four
to 500
americans who were on this list who
should have come home this is a grossly
understated list it's over four times
his number his facts are that the the
they are a myth themselves when he says
56 when we can prove that it's well over
200 can i just interrupt a second
because we only have about three minutes
left and i
suggest we're probably not going to
solve this problem this afternoon i want
to know a little bit more about the two
of you uh dr franklin you teach at
rutgers how long have you been there
since 75 in newark
in newark and where are you from
originally brooklyn new york where did
you go to school
i went to amherst college and then uh
got my phd at stanford in what english
and american literature and then after
that where did you teach
i taught at stanford johns hopkins yale
wesleyan before before i did my graduate
work i i flew for three years as a
navigator and intelligence officer in
the strategic air command
your book is published by lawrence hill
books who's lawrence hill
the lawrence himself is that this is an
imprint of chicago review press it's a
it's uh
it's a very small press and it's the
only press i showed the book to lawrence
hill because i did not want a major
trade press handling this book because i
was i was really afraid of what they
would do when the heat was turned on and
this press has been wonderful about not
you selling any books
quite a few the first printing went out
real fast
you're
living in fort smith arkansas that's
correct where did you go to school
uh arkansas uh tech and then graduate
school at the university of arkansas uh
and and you went to the marine corps for
four and a half years that's correct
what'd you do what what year did you
come out of vietnam uh 1969. and then
what have you done you said the last
eight years you've worked on this
subject what did you do in that interim
period i worked for the city of anaheim
for over six years i ran my own company
for a number of years i became involved
in this only i was a person who believed
no one had been left behind i believe my
government would not do this and when i
was personally shown that our government
will absolutely not follow up on current
information on live americans i became
involved in this and i did it to
document
how this all came about and the sad
thing is is that no evidence was
presented here today about the americans
who were left behind now you said you
were deposed by the committee the select
committee on ma mias and pows that's
correct how long were you deposed and
what kind of information were you giving
them
over seven hours i gave them information
on the debunking of this issue by our
defense intelligence agency how they
claim they follow up on information when
they absolutely do not follow up on the
information how this is tolerable year
in and year out with both the reagan and
the bush administrations
i uh again it was over seven hours i
gave them information on hundreds of
americans who were held in laos from
multiple sources from the communists
themselves saying it to all types of
intelligence people saying it to
photographic evidence to uh intercepted
radio messages we're out of time but
just a quick comment when you see this
parade magazine a week ago sunday you
have a gentleman by by the name of ka
here and and james webb former secretary
of the navy does that you follow this
stuff does that bring anything to mind
what's
what are they trying to do in a store
like did you read this by the way i
didn't read that particular story i i
think they're trying to end the war
yeah we all want to end the war but when
you see this what do you think of i mean
i think until uh the american prisoners
come home this war will never never
never end and the vietnam veteran will
see to it that it never ends and what do
you think give me just 15 seconds
well i think we have to recognize how
our government has used this issue to
keep the war going and when we
understand that it's been a phony issue
ever since it was created in 1969 turn
into a myth after the war then we can
begin to heal as a society and to end
the war inside our own society as well
we're out of time dr h bruce franklin of
rutgers author of m.i.a or myth making
in america and tom ashworth
of the national alliance of families
thank you both very much for trying to
help us better understand all this thank
you brian thank you
senator john kerry is expected in about
nine minutes from boston via satellite
but for the moment let's take a look at
some video that we took back in april on
the trip down to the mekong delta stops
at
kento fukuwa island where john kerry was
based down there during the war in
vietnam and roxia
my last question to you is this
some people in the united states
are convinced
that there are some people being held
here
how do we resolve this issue between our
two countries how do we answer these
doubts
from
because he thinks it's such a strange
thing for people to think that
it's just a strange idea
they
[Music]
so he's been in this area since the end
of the war
what why is it strange
when many frenchmen
after diane benfoo in 1954
remained long after the war as prisoners
i'm i'm high i'm a thingy smith
[Music]
his surprise senator smith sir his
surprise
uh reaction and the reason he thinks
it's a strange idea
is based on his experience in this area
where because he has so much experience
in this area because he's never heard of
any such report because he's so familiar
with this area he knows there can no be
there could not be any such
uh event in this area therefore taking
from his limited experience and
expanding it psychology react in a very
surprised way can you finish the answer
to my question of how we resolve the
issue
how do we get rid
[Music]
birthday so i'm bored
[Music]
marston mapping
was this all american this whole base
uh there were some vietnamese here too
yeah
we used to dock that was our dock right
over there
we'd come in here overnight
or get a couple days if our boats needed
repair we had a repair thing out there
that was floating
they'd lift the boat right out put it on
the
repaired hike and fix it up and
we had a barracks ship out there
where would you operate to from here
which one would you go straight back
into the whole peninsula we go back
about a half an hour over to hatian
and good up there and then we go way
down the end of the peninsula and work
off we had destroyers and uh
coast guard vessels re-harm us and
everything but we go into the rivers and
spend about a week you call the brown
water navy
yeah
well it became known as that river rats
i don't know
but not when we were out here when we
were out here with turquoise and
paradise it's beautiful look at this
stuff this belongs to vietnam this part
oh yeah this is uh we have 15 000
prisoners of war right up here in this
island
and um
this is where they make a great fish
sauce
mom
but this is uh the reason we came here
today is that uh
our guys really wanted to talk to the
security people here a number of
americans have been arrested
in the waters here off of yachts and
other things some involved in narcotics
muggling other kinds of things and
our guys really wanted to get a handle
on how many and who had been
worked into their prison system
etc in order to be able to determine
uh in order to determine
um
who uh who might be the subject of a
live-siting report or something
well putting people into the system
means that we can if there are prisoners
in there these guys that went in with
the yachts and so forth we can track
them
what we really want to push for is
records of foreign
no cameras no cameras
he's just gonna go make a phone call you
know
don't worry
it'll be okay
are they worried about the time
i miss her phone already told him okay
you know just great
hello
every person
this is my marching team
[Music]
now be careful we don't want anybody run
over tell them be careful we don't want
anybody in the car uh
[Music]
yeah has he ever seen any america has he
ever seen any americans here looking at
the village of raksha one of the many
stops some five stops down in the mekong
delta that the mia pow select committee
headed up by senator john kerry made
back in april this year c-span followed
the committee throughout the country
of vietnam and in boston via satellite
senator john kerry since that
trip in april what's happened in your
investigation
well brian first of all again just
looking very quickly at a couple of
those scenes let me congratulate you yet
again i i keep being moved by the
extensive and remarkable coverage that
you guys produce down there i think it's
it's tremendous to see
uh since that trip we've made i think
very significant progress in this
investigation the most significant thing
that has occurred
is a massive declassification of
documents we we've succeeded in in
securing
literally more than a million documents
that are now going to be made public
uh this will help people to really
understand this story over the course of
20 years and i think it's perhaps going
to be one of the major legacies of the
committee
in addition to that we've held hearings
an important set of hearings on the
numbers of people that might make up the
universe of potentially
left behind americans
and we
have arrived at a conclusion
that there was some evidence
that some people i can't give you a
specific number
we came up with a number of 133
possibilities
that obviously will be reduced by some
people for whom there has been an
accounting
that was 133 as of 1973
but we're trying to come up with the
real universe not a fictional one
not uh
fantasy or or
anybody's wishful thinking but the real
possibilities based on real evidence
of who might have been alive in 1973
that was not accounted for
and to our amazement in terms of all the
prior efforts of investigations
we have indeed come up with hard
evidence that suggests the government
had a reason to believe
that someone might have been alive and
that a fuller accounting was due us
in march and april of 1973.
senator smith was uh with us by phone
earlier senator kerry and he says that
the vietnamese and the oceans are
holding up on some information that he
said until access
better access is given
that the vietnam trade embargo that the
united states the united states straight
embargo was vietnam should continue
what's your opinion on that
well i don't think it i mean the issue
at the center of the pow mia resolution
is has nothing to do really with the
trade embargo that's a different
political question
and my own personal belief is that the
united states would be aided and i
underline we would be aided
in getting the answers to the plw plwmia
issue
if we were to
perhaps lift portions
of the embargo
as we go down the road here building a
stronger relationship
i
absolutely want to distinguish and i
want every listener to carefully
distinguish
the difference between
lifting a portion of an embargo in an
effort to show good faith in this
process
as distinguished from normalization
i am not and no member of our committee
is advocating normalization which means
full embassy uh full uh recognition
imf loans credits a whole lot of other
advantages that go with it
we're not talking about that we're
really talking about building the
relationship
building trust so that we can get the
answers that we want and ultimately
can secure
some of the needs that it has let's take
some calls portland oregon for senator
john kerry go ahead please
hi i just had a question
my husband he went to vietnam last month
and his family found two body
with an id on it
and he called and reported nobody
wants to do anything with this
they just try to ignore him well can i
ask you first of all when was this
last month
last month
and this was your husband
he was in vietnam right who did he call
he called um
two or three places that give his number
different places they said just call
these police
and each
number let me just suggest this to you
if you call area code 202
224
2306
right now
you just say you were talking to me on
this program and give them the
information and i promise you it'll be
followed up on
let's get that number once more uh
senator kerry i've got 202 202 224
2306.
lynnhurst new jersey go ahead please
yes i'd like to ask a question about the
trade embargo please go ahead sir okay
my father
owns a business in
vietnam i'm a little nervous sorry
that's okay my father was a business in
vietnam and he's
he's banked a lot of his
a lot of his bankroll on the fact that
the trade embargo will be lifted
and do you know like
eventually if it will be lifted or not
caller is your father vietnamese
yeah yeah okay
as an american my father's vietnamese
my answer to you is that i believe
eventually it will be lifted i think
that the rapidity with which it is
lifted
depends on the vietnamese response to
the remaining questions that we have
we have told the vietnamese very clearly
there is a small group of live siting
reports
and there is a small group of cases
called discrepancy cases
which we need answers to
as fast as those answers are forthcoming
i am confident there will be a response
from our government cleveland ohio for
john kerry go ahead please hi i have a
question concerning the public hearing
involving mr perot yes sir i watched
twice the entire eight hours or so and
in addition to that the live coverage
that was given
i understand that someone has to ask the
hard skeptical questions
and uh this is very important but the
distinct impression i received from
senator mccain's questions and his his
actions were that they were somewhat
i don't know politically motivated in
light of mr pearl's previously
undeclared candidacy and i was wondering
if you could respond to that gee i
really didn't sense that at all and i'm
not saying that
you know to protect senator mccain or
anything he's perfectly capable of
protecting himself i just didn't feel
that i thought senator mccain was
restrained i think senator mccain
has some very strong feelings as a
former prisoner himself
as someone who has obviously intimate
interest and knowledge of this issue
i think he has very strong feelings
about announcements people have made
over the years that he believes are not
true
i think he's entitled to those feelings
and i thought he acted in a manner with
mr perot that was both dignified and
fair fontana
california go ahead please
yes i'd just like to say that i think mr
franklin is working against the american
people
and deceiving
helping people to deceive the american
people and i'd like to see
no senator kerry we're talking about
bruce franklin who is our guest in the
last half hour who's written the book
okay
has he ever testified before your
committee
i know he has not mr franklin is is a
what i would call a gatherer of multiple
information from many sources an
interpreter of that information he is
not really
a firsthand player in this drama if you
will
he's a commentator
his comments or his personal opinion and
his personal opinion is
that the issue is a bogus issue
i don't share that belief and many
others don't share that belief
i do think that part of his thesis is
correct and i have acknowledged that
that i think there are those who through
the years
did exploit this issue
and there are those who in calculated
fashion
use this issue for political purposes
now he has put forward that portion of
the story
but what i think he conveniently avoids
is
that there was something there to
exploit
you you can't exploit people if they're
not going to be in a sense open to
something or or
if they're not going to believe a kernel
of truth about something in order to be
exploited and in the case of this issue
what the committee has succeeded in
showing is that there was more than a
kernel of truth to the possibility that
somebody may have been alive in 1973
for the families that knew that truth
for the families that were aware of how
their loved one was last seen alive or
last known to be in captivity
it was absolutely unacceptable that the
books should be closed
just bang bang that's it close the books
and that is what started the movement
that has been sustained for 20 years to
get to the bottom of this issue i think
that mr franklin too cavalierly
dismisses the reality of that or in fact
it's not a question of dismissing it
people were not aware of that reality
until this committee has done its work
over the course of the last months so he
really wrote a book without the full
story being on the table buffalo new
york you're next i happen uh senator i
happen to believe that also that uh this
pia business is a myth but i have no
problem with the government
in the event that there are that there
is a small chance that there is a few or
one or two over they have no problem
with the government doing an
investigation such as you're doing but
my question is this
if a poll and i'm not aware of one but
if a poll were taken to the american
people wouldn't the vast majority of the
american people want to want to end this
whole sorry chapter of our history and
initiate trade and diplomatic relations
with vietnam as
even granting aid as partial
partial payment to some of the terrible
devastation we brought in that country
the polls have been in fact taken and
the polls show
a significant majority
would like to
move on however the polls also show that
a majority of americans believe that
some american might have been left
behind so you have conflicting
results from just two different
questions being taken on their own like
that it's up to us in political life to
resolve the conflict that is presented
in policy terms by those two different
answers and that's what this committee
is trying to do
by finding the answers to the
possibility that somebody might be alive
today and hopefully by proving to
americans through an exhaustive process
what the likelihood is that somebody
might still be alive at the end of this
process hopefully those in a position to
make policy judgments will be in a
better position to make the kind of
judgment that you're calling on them to
make have you decided yet sir whether
you're going to go back to vietnam
before this is over uh brian it it
occurred to me in the last few days
reviewing the material and where we are
that we may have to return
somewhere in the end of october or
november
in order to have a series of meetings on
the subject of these discrepancy cases
and the access issues that senator smith
raised
it's my hope that
that could be avoided but if it can't be
i want to make certain that as the
committee draws its final judgments we
do so with the utmost of information up
to the last minute available to us and
with the with the greatest opportunity
possible available to the vietnamese to
resolve cases that are critical to the
judgments that we will make in our final
report baltimore maryland you're next
yes i'd like to ask
senator kerry of why the committee
doesn't
go forth where planes were shot down in
the water
and checked for the planes it sunk i
have i'm a vietnam veteran from
baltimore
and i have a girl who notified me
and asked
if we can get some information you know
about vietnam veterans of america get
some information on her father and she
has gotten
documentations since 1989 that her
father's plane was shot down in a rescue
temp
on a phantom jet and her father was in a
fixed wing plane
and the guys that was rescued from her
father's plane
have uh notified her that he was
inside the plane
since it was a rescue plane
there was a cable they were hooked to a
cable all the doors were open and when
his plane got hit with a mortar and it
went down the other guys that got
rescued by the by the choppers that come
in said that his body was still on that
plane when it submerged when they were
pulling away why doesn't the american
government ultimately
ultimately that may be possible uh at
the moment
there are simply other cases that take a
higher level of priority right now where
for instance you know there was a crash
site on the ground
you have evidence that somebody might
have survived that particular crash site
and the limited resources that are
available to this and the limited
personnel demand that you set some
priorities i have no doubt that over
time
as our relationship hopefully improves
as we progress down the road of that
relationship that naval equipment will
be able to to
go to some of those sites that some of
our deep water recovery capacity will be
applied to this and it'll be good
training exercise for all of that and
something that i think would be a very
helpful for some of the families but
it's not at the top of the of the list
when you have minimal resources in 15
minutes deputy assistant secretary of
defense alan patak
who is
the bush administration spokesman on the
prisoner of war missing in action
affairs among
several will be here to take your calls
and talk more about this issue santa
cruz california you're next for senator
kerry go ahead please
yeah hi brian um i
hope that you watch your facial
expressions today
senator kerry i don't know what
people have been accusing me of a lot of
things today because of my facial
expressions but um that's not
there's two objectives uh actually i
like that senator to carry this so we
saw during the uh hearings um senator
smith raised the issue of
government
honesty
with respect to the photograph
i have one specific question and one
general question
the specific question is how honest
has our government been with
that is the executive branch of our
government been with your committee
um
this general question is
as an american senator as a united
states senator
what can you do what can be done
to make our government
more honest i'll just wait to listen to
your answer thank you well i'm going to
give you a pretty biased answer on the
second question i happen to think we
need a wholesale change
in our approach in washington
to deal with the question of overall
honesty in our government i've been one
who has been outraged
by the
willingness of our government to lie to
our own people and i've seen it over the
course of 20 years
we've seen it in iran and iraq
we've seen it in policy with regard to
the contras in central america we've
seen it in regard to vietnam
we've just seen it too much for a
society that prides itself on our
constitutional format and and on our
approach to to
the relationship with our own people
it saddens me and it's a reality and
it's one we have to deal with and
constantly be vigilant about
i think the committee has done a good
job
of getting behind that veil of secrecy
and the documents are going to tell a
lot of their own story i caution people
from trying to draw conclusions before
everybody's had a chance to appear
before the committee and tell their
story i don't think it's fair to anybody
the committee is not trying to
point the fingers at people the
committee is just trying to get at the
truth what did we know who knew what
what choices were made
and i think everybody in america
recognizes that at that point in time in
the 1970s at the end of an exhausting
war with the country in turmoil and with
watergate there were some very special
cross-cutters in our politics that
affected
uh people's reactions and judgments to
things and and and you can't just look
at it in 1992 terms and avoid that
the answer the first part of your
question is that uh
the committee i certainly would reserve
judgment as to how open
uh lee we've been dealt with
at this point we are still receiving
documents
i think senator smith and i share a
judgment that we could be getting more
documents faster and we could be getting
some documents in fuller form that is to
say less redacted
but it doesn't mean we won't get them
and so again i don't want to cast brick
bats prematurely i would like to see us
work cooperatively with other branches
of our government so that the end of
this everybody can stand up and say this
was a joint effort where everybody came
together and we did our
our duty and i hope that will be the
final judgment of the committee but we
have a certain distance to travel in the
course of the next weeks before we can
say that
boston massachusetts where the senator
is at wgbh studios go ahead please
senator relative specifically to laos
would you please comment whether or not
you believe there's any correlation
uh between the mia issue
and the secret war on laos and the uh
specifically along complicity
uh with the central intelligence agency
and the drug trade
and well aside from that would you
please comment on an investigative
recruit reporter
jonathan whitney
and it may not be relative but the the
negan hand bank please
well it isn't uh the new can hand bank
is i think
not relevant to directly to our inquiry
and it gets a pretty complicated area
for a short
time span that we have here
the issue of cia
excuse me
drugs
and
mias
i don't think is directly correlated
though i have no evidence to the
contrary i'm just telling you i don't
think it is
uh
there is no question in my mind
that there are those who took advantage
of the
secret war and secret supply networks
just as they did in central america
to run drugs
i can't tell you
that that was sanctioned i can't tell
you to what degree people at higher
levels knew it though i know that some
certainly had heard of it and suspected
it
now
i don't know i have no evidence at all
and i welcome it if it exists
that there's any relationship between
what was happening in terms of the
secret war
and any
shunting aside if you will
of knowledge of prisoners per se
what the committee has learned is that
laos was very very difficult terrain
that there was very little control by
anybody in the country
that the north vietnamese had maybe a
hundred thousand troops in the country
and really were the people in control of
the northern and and ho chi minh trail
provinces
uh and that the patek lao were really
just a puppet basically that they had no
no real control or government per se
there was very little information coming
out about prisoners and we have not yet
determined what the full body of
information was that our government had
about
airmen who may have been lost that might
have been taken prisoner we just don't
have that answer yet the committee is
focused on laos right now pretty
intensely we have a lot of questions
that we're asking but i'm not prepared
to
draw any conclusions at this point next
call for senator kerry tells oklahoma uh
yes senator curry i want to thank you
very much for this
it's been a real blessing to know that
someone was working on it
but back in the night early 1960s
i had a friend that was part of a
special air force
service that went to vietnam a couple of
times and he was talking about
at one point and there was a lot of
scuttlebutt came back to tinker
about a special hospital
that was
had
several
of our service people
there that had a type of aerial diseases
correct i've heard that rumor for years
it was a rumor we heard when we were
soldiers in vietnam
and none of us i certainly don't know
anybody who went there i don't know
anybody who didn't come back from there
and i've never seen any evidence of the
existence of this particular place
senator again uh for those who've just
joined us what years did you serve in
vietnam and what i served i served in
vietnam
two tours of duty one off the coast on a
guided missile frigate in the gulf of
tonkin in 1968
in the beginning part of 68 about six
months and then i went back to vietnam
as officer in command of a swift boat
gunboat in the mekong delta principally
and
served there again for another six
months jihalis washington you're next
yes thank you brian i want to thank csbn
and i want to thank senator kerry i've
been watching this clear through i was
stationed in daharan saudi arabia i was
with post office and customs
and we got the flights of the french
being sent back when the vietnam thing
started i lost two personal friends in
the korean conflict
now what i'm seeing is dr franklin is
one of these people and you hit it right
on the head you were beautiful the way
you explained it to me he's a naive fool
either that or he's a total government
cover-up
and
i want to mention something senator
kerry
senator mccain
i'm not degrading him i don't mean that
i respect the men tremendously
but the man that called earlier about
the reaction he got from the parole
thing was absolutely right i got the
same feeling and whatever his reasons
were we got that feeling but the point
i'm going to make is senator mccain
i don't remember where i saw him they
were interviewed i'm sorry i'm nervous
that's okay but he uh
uh
okay he
he said made a statement at one point
that uh
he couldn't believe in his own heart
that any other military man would cover
up
and leave people behind and sir i'm here
to tell you i saw it happen over there
it does overwhere over where i saw it
through arabia where i was stationed
we were during
pardon me during the gulf war
i was stating no no oh during the
vietnam war right this is something else
that our government has not brought out
neither has the media that i was furious
about they did not tell the american
people that we have had a base there
before i was stationed there for 16
months
we were we serviced all the middle east
attaches and embassies
including beirut which is a horror to me
because i love that city but anyway what
i'm getting at is i know there's
cover-ups they don't tell us the truth
now senator mccain made a statement he
couldn't believe
that other men would do this to other
man he's very naive in that respect
because they do all right chihuahuas
we'll let you go i think you made your
point uh reaction senator
i i think he speaks for himself except
that i i'd just like to make certain
that anybody who's listening understands
that
i have nothing but extraordinary respect
for senator mccain i think that
for whatever
reasons of conscience that promote in
him as a former prisoner to ask some
tough questions some people seem to
resent that fact i think it's terribly
unfair to senator mccain
he is a patriot a man of great
distinguished service to this country
and and i think people ought to listen
more carefully to
the factual basis of the questions that
he's asking and not necessarily
doubt where he's coming from in this
no one would be more committed to
finding somebody if they were alive i
mean tell me a reason why senator mccain
wouldn't want to do that
so i am absolutely confident
that he's going to continue to ask tough
questions because he's a tough guy
and i think at the end of this people
will be grateful that there were
different members of this committee
approaching this issue in their own
style
with their own belief structure and that
will ultimately be one of the strengths
of the committee that there will have
been every point of view represented on
it last call for senator kerry from
pittsburgh pennsylvania go ahead please
hello senator kerry yes sir um i'm
calling in regards to a backup on the
fella that called concerning the drug
running by the cia yeah and uh
concerning that plus you know many other
things you know that the cia
you know did in vietnam i can see this
government not wanting to bring the men
home because could you imagine
the men that have been there for what 20
years
what they know what they could tell the
people you're presuming government has
done yeah but sir
you are making a huge presumption there
and that is to say that every one of the
people being held or some of the people
being held
were complicitous in whatever it is
you're suggesting the cia did
now you know nobody knows that
and nobody has come up with conclusive
proof that
that
military personnel flying in these
airplanes
that that i mean you're talking about
folks who were lost in laos
flying uh
military planes out of air bases and and
people who had nothing to do with drug
running the best of my knowledge i mean
that's a far cry from cia people on the
ground in laos itself
so the notion that somehow a prisoner
drops out of a
you know fighter aircraft or bomber
is involved in the drug trade just
doesn't stand to reason
senator kerry what are the chances that
there will be a 12-member select
committee that you run
that will all sign off on your report
that there will be no minority report at
the end of this year
well i certainly hope there wouldn't
have to be a minority report i can't
predict that yet brian because we're
just not at the point of drawing
conclusions
let me also emphasize when you say that
i run i think this is a collegiate
effort senator smith and i are working
hard
to keep this thing non-political doesn't
mean there aren't tensions there
obviously have been and will be
because there are different dynamics in
a group like this but i think the
committee has been extraordinarily
unified
our purpose is very clear we have some
tough work ahead of us in the next few
months my hope is that the truth will
leap out at us and that the truth will
declare itself in a way that makes it
possible for 12 people to come to the
same conclusion
i am absolutely confident
that there will be a very significant
majority
in
some conclusion and if there are a few
people who digress because they just
don't like definitions or they don't
like
one conclusion out of 20.
you may have some
some sidebar statements to that effect
but i would hope that we would not have
to have a significant large-scale
minority report
we've only got about 30 seconds what
on all these hearings you've got
scheduled the september october november
hearings december possibly
which one you think will be the most
important for the audience to
keep an eye on
well i think the hearings about the
paris peace accords will be very
important because they will shed light
from the policy makers themselves about
their beliefs at that point in time and
what they did and how the government
acted and i think it's very important
for people to have a full view of that
story and the second piece that will be
very important
is the last sort of accounting process
of our own government hearing from the
department of defense from the dia from
the current teams in vietnam about what
they've done in the last year
what questions have been answered over
the course of this year and where we
really stand in this accounting process
i think those two are very significant
and finally we will view to some degree
the question of whether this issue has
been
fraudulently built by certain
individuals we will look at the question
of myth
ourselves and we will examine that
and i think obviously some people will
take great interest there are examples
of people having solicited money
with fake bones and we've seen the fake
pictures and other things
i think the committee has to be
responsible and look at those also so we
will
senator john kerry we're out of time
thanks again for coming in uh during
this holiday
thanks
and we've got another hour of this day
to go on our vietnam revisitor program
those of you who are seeing this for the
first time it resulted from a trip that
c-span took back in april
it was a two-week trip to southeast asia
which included
a five-person team of greg gursky
jacqueline pham
jim mills our producer and richard
weinstein and myself
and
the a lot of the video on that will be
seen on wednesday
thursday and friday each day starting at
12 noon east coast time and going
throughout the afternoon until six on
both wednesday and thursday and at five
on
friday
here in our studios allen patak
deputy assistant secretary of defense is
on the screen at the moment by the way
first of all am i pronouncing your last
name yes you are thank you i assume
somebody pronounces it from time time p
tag right
uh you are in charge of the prisoner of
war m.i.a
affairs part of the dod defense
department that's correct and before i
go any farther i want to just thank you
very much for
inviting me to be here and for the
effort that your network has shown
towards uh bringing out the pow-mia
issue
we have a good story to tell and
again i appreciate being here
one of the things uh when my office was
formed uh it was so that there would be
a focal point for the pow mia issue in
uh the department of defense so i i'm my
office is the focal point for that
effort
structure for just a moment
who do you work directly for
my my immediate boss is jim lilly who's
the assistant secretary of defense for
isa international security affairs
and through jim to uh paul wolfowitz the
under secretary of defense for policy
right to the secretary and what's your
charge how about how long have you been
in this job nine months how long has the
job been there nine months why was it
created
uh
back in july
of 1991
the secretary of defense and the
administration
uh wanted to recommit themselves to uh
the fullest possible accounting of pow
mias
the secretary basically uh uh took
charge and said we need an organization
that will uh be the kind of the tip of
the sword
and bring all of the other organizations
in dod that had been kind of working
independently together under one roof so
my office and uh my job was created
in uh september i came on board in
january and have been there nine months
where'd you come from i was uh the
deputy staff director of the select
committee uh up in the senate working
for uh
senator smith
so you came right from this committee
that francis wenick is the staff
director yes
and how long did you work for him on
that committee uh right from the
beginning of the of the inception of the
committee where were you before that
before that i was the
council on the senate intelligence
committee
working for frank murkowski of alaska
and before that
i was the republican staff director of
the senate veterans committee for three
years is this a partisan issue in any
way not at all in fact one of the things
that i've really enjoyed
about uh
my last
nine months and also my time on the
committee
is that this truly is not a partisan
issue it's a republicans and democrats
working together
left-wing right-wing all
aspects of beliefs working together to
get the fullest possible accounting and
what's different first of all were you
confirmed by the senate for this job no
as a deputy assistant secretary uh that
was not uh required
and
is there you know when you when one of
the questions i've been asking all day
and for the last couple of months is
trying to get a sense of whether or not
they're going to be unified at the end
of this
not to create a a wedge or anything but
just to find out when that report comes
out are people going to be split again
on this thing what is your sense looking
at this select committee and having been
there will they be unified in the end on
their decision
i hope that they're unified on their
decision
i know that one of the things that's
been uh
particularly heartwarming for me is the
fact that
this has been one issue where the
executive branch and the legislative
branch have truly worked together
to try to resolve the issue and also to
get answers
one thing which i would mention also is
that
a lot of emphasis has been on southeast
asia
as a result of the committee and my
office working together with our
counterparts in in russia we now have a
joint task force
and a joint commission
where you have ambassador tune
uh his counterpart general volkagonov
you have senators smith and kerry
congressman miller congressman peterson
uh myself from dod
folks from state department people from
the archives and our counterparts in
russia so not only do we have this
bipartisan effort here in the united
states with regard to southeast asia but
we have this working relationship now
with our counterparts in russia so
you've got executive branch and
legislative branches all working
together to the same goal any way to
quantify how much money you're spending
at the department of defense on this
issue
there's no way to quantify it number one
and number two as i will tell you it is
not important how much money we spend in
trying to quantify it the main concern
is getting the fullest possible
accounting how many people work in your
office in my immediate office i have 14
individuals
when we first started out and before my
office was formed there were about 150
people all together in the department of
defense working the pow mia issue
right now we have about
450. so uh you can see that the
commitment uh just in the past nine
months is certainly there
and one thing i would add too is about
three quarters of those people
are men and women who are in uniform so
they have the they have the honor to uh
trying to get the answers to the pow mia
issue what do they all do i know that
you can't mention what each one of them
does but give us some sense of what
those 450 people do let me uh let me
answer that by maybe giving you a little
walk through of the organization and
that might
clarify a little bit
as i mentioned earlier
there is my office which is kind of the
focal point in the department of defense
about 14 people
we then have one of the major
offices
called the central document office it's
co-located with my office
and
they have about 75 individuals who are
going through the the
literally miles of documents trying to
get them all put together and going
through the process of then
declassifying them so we can get them to
the public
uh i'm pleased to announce that
we right now have forty thousand pages
that are on microfilm available to the
public through the library of congress
and through their cooperative library
program that they can now uh
look at
on powmia
we have another 40 000. what's what's on
that what's on that microfiche there's
everything from uh reports of uh
progress being made in the issue
uh there there's a
documentation about
the organizational structure and uh
people who are involved in in trying to
get the answers whether progress is
being made and that sort of thing
and as you ex would expect what we have
to do is
we have to if if it describes a certain
individual we have to under the privacy
act get permission to release that
information from the primary next to ken
we also have to look at it if it has any
uh
implications for ongoing negotiations
with
foreign countries and so forth but for
the most part it's a
historical perspective of what we have
have done in pow mia
we'll have another 40 000 pages
available in another week or two for a
total of 80 000 pages the ultimate goal
is to have 1.3 million pages
declassified and available to the public
and uh to come to washington's library
of congress to get this no you can do
that through your local library the
cooperative library set up that's uh
set up with local libraries and the
library of congress
um hopefully by the end of the year
we'll have the predominance of the
material available to the public with
the exception of those uh instances that
i mentioned
that's the central document office
we then have a very large uh
organization
under admiral larson out at sync pack
the commander in chief pacific called
the joint task force full accounting
the commanding general that is general
tom needham
and he has approximately 150 people who
are the folks that
physically go into the field
go to vietnam laos and cambodia
and do the joint activities with the
various governments looking going to
crash sites trying to get
information or material is this where
the remains are brought to
that is where hopefully at a crash site
we would discover remains
the remains would then be
inspected on the spot to see whether
there is a strong possibility that they
are
human remains
and then they are sent to the central
identifi central identification lab in
hawaii which actually does the the
identification we understand from
francis swenig who is the staff director
of the mia mia pow committee select
committee in the senate that that
particular facility will be under
investigation and hearings coming up
later this fall that's correct uh
to put it a different way all aspects of
what the government is doing in the area
of pow mia are being investigated by the
committee as they should be that's
that's part of this process of working
together with the legislative branch
and uh i must say that the
uh what is overlooked many times is the
central identification lab
is the
facility that not only looks at remains
from southeast asia
but for all conflicts be they world war
ii korea wherever so they've got quite a
task uh
i can hear somebody saying
what does alan pitak have
what background does he have to know
what he's doing in this job where did
you come from before you got involved in
this senate committee staffs well i had
uh after graduating from the naval
academy i had nine years of active duty
in the navy
i then left active duty i stayed in the
reserves
and went to uh the intelligence
community where i worked for five years
from the intelligence community i went
to capitol hill and worked on the armed
services committee under senator phil
graham of texas for three years
i went to the department of state worked
on
the inf treaty there for a year
three years on the veterans committee a
year at the intelligence committee and
then sometime on the select committee
what i hope i bring
to the to the job
is an understanding of how our
government works because a lot of
getting the job done
is getting
various parts of the government to work
together the military dod state
department
but i also think that by
having an understanding of how the
intelligence community works
how the state department works the needs
of our veterans which i learned through
the veterans committee
uh that i have an understanding of the
types of answers and the needs of of the
people of the of the us are when they're
looking for answers how many people does
the department of defense have over in
country in in vietnam in laos in
cambodia right now
we have 51 individuals in vietnam
because we have an ongoing joint
activity with the vietnamese we also
have a permanent presence in hanoi that
is is there all the time whether there's
a joint activity or not so there's 51
people plus the number in hanoi varies
but but roughly about anywhere from six
to ten individuals
in laos we just completed a joint
activity where we had one of general
needham's teams in there but we also
have a permanent presence in vientiane
again the same roughly the same number
of people
and uh in cambodia again the same thing
we have a joint activity coming up in
cambodia in october but we have a
permanent presence in phnom penh again
roughly the same number of people
what uh what gets overlooked sometimes
is we now have a permanent presence in
russia we have four people on the ground
in moscow that are going through
archival material
doing the same types of things that the
individuals in southeast asia are doing
in terms of
doing interviews
trying to do live sighting
investigations getting archival material
together and trying to get answers so we
we now have a presence in three
countries plus russia
and what i'm hoping is as we get more
and more
answers and maybe more and more
questions we will have a presence in
some other countries
alan patak is the deputy assistant
secretary of defense at the pentagon
where he's involved in the pow mia
affairs office running that
and
we'll be with us for another 15 minutes
as we talk about his activities we want
to point out that wednesday thursdays
and fridays
of this week wednesday thursday and
friday of this week we continue our
vietnam revisited
repeat from memorial day a lot of people
wanted us to do this again so you can
see it we've updated it with interviews
and call-in shows and there we will
continue to do that a lot of the
videotape that you saw over memorial day
will be rerun especially through the
rest of the week this is a talking day
the next couple days you'll see a lot
more videotape on wednesday by the way
we will focus a lot of attention on
the non-pow
activities we'll be discussing
besides
looking at the
ho chi minh and his mausoleum and things
like that up in hanoi uh we'll get back
to the agent orange issue that we talked
about before this time
addition to this discussion will be reid
irvine of accuracy and media
in addition to that later on uh we will
be talking about this prosthetic center
and fred downs will be back with us for
a while tren van gaal vietnamese
assistance for the handicapped
who has been involved in prosthetics and
kanto will be here so there's a lot to
talk about
before this week is is over
what's the difference for you
being a spokesman for the bush
administration and the defense
department and working for the
congressional or the senate committee
what how do you think differently now
well first of all
because of the issue
i really don't think differently in
terms of trying to accomplish
what needs to be done which is the
fullest possible accounting
what really was a wonderful working
condition on the hill uh with francis
senator smith and senator kerry was the
fact that we work together as a team and
we work towards a common goal
uh in the job that i'm in now
i know that i have the the full backing
of
the president the secretary of defense
my chain of command
and it's the same sort of a feeling that
no stone will be unturned we're not
going to worry about a dollar value
placed on our efforts um quite frankly
when you have
a situation right now in the department
of defense where because of potential
budget cuts and so forth officers are
losing people
and to have my office and and the people
that are working for me ramping up from
150 to 450 people that to me tells me
the commitment that my chain of command
has now you've been in this job you say
nine months nine months
um
i'm going to meander a little bit just
to to get to a question uh it would be
my guess
that you came from
the committee
that somebody in this mix said to the
defense department if you think we're
gonna if we're gonna clean this mess up
we got a lot of people mad at us out
there they're hot there's a lot of
confusion we better get somebody in this
job create a job here that'll bring it
all together and it can work with a
committee how am i am i on target so far
i mean this or the dish i mean you
didn't you didn't knock on the door and
say they need you need me somebody came
to you and said you're the guy you're
the liaison how did it work how did you
get this job i i basically got a phone
call saying uh we need you
and after
some
phone calls were made and so forth uh
i was brought on board and i i would i
would hope
that uh
i would bring to uh to the job the the
knowledge of how the hill works and and
knowing the people from the committee
but also uh how the executive branch
works
and how to have the two work together
and so i hope that's how the how the
decision process was made but what
really created the need
wasn't there a frustration somewhere
along the line that things weren't
getting done fast enough in my judgment
i think that the commitment was made
that we needed to get answers and get
the fullest possible accounting and i
believe that that commitment was made
right from the president on down
and as i mentioned earlier we had a lot
of
individual organizations that were
working but not necessarily talking to
one another and
this was an opportunity to bring
everybody together i might add too that
what sometimes gets overlooked
is that
under under my auspices it's not just
southeast asia as i mentioned earlier
we've got what we call the joint task
force russia
that has ramped up since march but you
know we have 77 over 77 000 mias from
world war ii
we have over 8 000 from korea
we we have after putting numbers
together and again this is uh hard work
over the course of the last nine months
we have about 135 cases that are
discrepancy cases from what we call the
cold war the cold war is that period
from korea to vietnam
where uh
the tension was growing between the u.s
and russia and uh we had reconnaissance
flights and so forth
so you have 78 000 from world war ii 8
000 from korea 135 from the cold war you
have 2 266 from vietnam
we have about six that are unresolved
from china
and it seems like the more we dig into
trying to get answers the more questions
that that come up so our effort keeps
expanding because we think we owe that
to
the people the finest people in uh that
have ever worn the uniform the united
states who are in uniform right now it's
important that they know that their
country
will not rest until there's a fullest
possible accounting that's the least
that they should expect since being in
this job have you been to either vietnam
laos or cambodia been to vietnam laos in
cambodia and have also been to russia
and as we
continue i'm going to be going back to
russia in three weeks with ambassador
tune when we have
our next joint commission meeting i'll
be going back to
vietnam laos and cambodia probably in
october
and uh as long as there are
answers out there hopefully
i'll keep traveling because that means
we're making progress senator smith said
earlier by phone from new hampshire that
the vietnamese and the law oceans have
cut off some access you didn't sound
very happy with the vietnamese and laos
the the oceans what's your view of that
well let me make let me be very clear on
on
the issue of
of vietnam and laos and cambodia
in my judgment
i am very very enthusiastic about what
we are doing in dod
but the truth is the answers to our pows
and mias rest in the archives in vietnam
they rest in the archives of other
countries and they rest with with the
knowledge of a lot of the people in
those countries
and so we can only do so much
but what we really need to do is we need
to keep the pressure on the vietnamese
there have been some hiccups in
our access to
things such as our live siting mechanism
i think we've overcome some of those
hiccups but
as enthusiastic as i am about the job
that we're doing in dod uh the answers
are in vietnam and the other countries
and we need to get those answers and
they're not as quick as i'd like when
does the president have to deal with the
trade embargo again isn't it this month
uh no the president has stated
repeatedly just recently that uh unless
there is more progress made
uh
that we're not going to move any further
with vietnam does he have to redo it
though under the is there a yearly
no we have we have a road map in place
and the road map is basically pretty
clear about the fact that there has to
be we have to see results
the key the key word particularly with
vietnam is we have to see results and
there won't be progress towards
normalization until we see those results
what's your sense of timing how long is
it going to take to get results and to
get to a point where the embargo could
be lifted well i think that's where the
pressure rests on my shoulders to make
sure that we keep the pressure on
of vietnam laos and cambodia and again i
might add that uh
we are hoping that there will be some
answers to
vietnam laos and cambodia and perhaps
the russian archives so that's why we
keep the pressure on
russia to give us access to documents
do you feel any pressure because of the
campaign because of the election none
whatsoever
uh
and none has been pre been put on me uh
the pressure i have is to get the
fullest possible accounting so that's
that's the pressure that i feel is on
myself what's your reaction when you see
the national league of families
have a meeting here in town and the
national
alliance of families
go to that meeting and raise the
objection to the president his position
when you saw that were you in the room
by by was what was your reaction to it i
mean
i thought that it was unfortunate
because uh this president is so
committed to the pow mia issue and
getting the first possible accounting
that it was an unfortunate incident but
i also having been in the room it was a
minority of individuals and uh
one of the things i guess is that it's
their right to speak out that's what
makes america so great so uh but i think
it was unfortunate because this
president
is totally committed and the secretary
of defense is totally committed to the
issue ross perot's been very visible on
this he's always been involved with
government activity over the last 20
years has he ever called you since
you've been in this job he has not
has he called the pentagon that you know
of well i have had a conversation with
uh with mr perot
uh just to uh let him know i was on
board and that sort of thing but that
has been the extent of our conversation
how do you view his involvement at this
point
my view is anybody whether it's mr
perrault or any anybody who has
information that can help me get the
fullest possible accounting i will take
gladly
and uh earlier there was a an individual
who called in said that they hadn't
received
any satisfaction or something with
regard to some information that was
provided
anybody that has information the number
that they can call to me is area code
703-284-1297
and uh 703 703-284-1297
any information from anybody that helps
me
accomplish my goal of the fullest
possible accounting i will take gladly
and i know everybody that works for me
feels the same way earlier this
afternoon tom ashworth from the national
alliance families was here and he was
saying the government is lying has lied
a lot the defense department's lying
we're not getting the truth you no doubt
i've heard a lot of this
what's your reaction when you hear that
my reaction is that i can speak only for
the period of time that i've been in my
job
and
to the best that i can
state no one who has either ever worked
for me in this position has ever lied
about the issue
and i'm committed to uh
to the truth
all right let's assume that the report
is filed at the end of this year by the
select committee
what happens then
what's next i mean let's say the
president wins again and you're still in
your job and
january rolls around
reports filed what do you do then
nothing changes for me and all the
people in my organization my our charter
is to get the fullest possible
accounting and until that is
accomplished and i'm not going to kid
you or the viewers
there particularly with the 77 000 who
are missing from world war ii i don't
know if we'll ever get a full and
complete accounting for those
individuals or for the 8000 from korea
but i am not going to rest and i know
that the people that work for me are not
going to rest until we've we've given it
the best shot that we can so nothing
changes we'll keep trying the best we
can uh being a realist
what's going to happen
i mean the reason i asked that we've
devoted a tremendous amount of tension
some of the audience even irritated us
to spend all this attention on we get
calls on it people don't like it they
want to know when is this going to be
put away this issue
i think that the answer for that is
really going to be
when the american people are ready to
put it away but i think the important
point to make is is that i think it's
important for
i think the american people will be able
to deal with it
in a lot more open
fashion
when they come individually to grips
with the fact that their government
truly is
committed and totally committed to the
fullest possible accounting you know i
mentioned earlier that uh not only do we
look back but my office also is uh
has oversight over things such as escape
and evasion the code of conduct
uh
seer training
we we also look to the future and so a
lot of the things that i i hope that we
learn from the job that we're doing
will be translated to people who are uni
wearing the uniform right now and
they'll know boy this was a a total
commitment on their government for pow
mias
and i think when the american people
realize that their their government
really truly is committed i think
they'll be able to deal with deal with
it a lot better
alan c patak
is the deputy assistant secretary of
defense for prisoner of war missing in
action affairs
at the pentagon thank you very much for
joining us today thank you brian
pleasure to be here
those of you who've just tuned in this
is vietnam revisited
we did this first back over memorial day
it lasted some 30 hours and this week we
split it up over five days in the
afternoons give you a chance to get it
in a little uh
less concentrated dose but back during
the memorial day weekend we had a viewer
response line where people could phone
in those who couldn't get through and
give us
anything that was on their mind
regarding the vietnam and the pow mia
situation let's listen to a few of those
calls and we'll be back with open phones
i'm an american history teacher and i'm
appalled that our u.s delegation feels
it is their right to handle primary
source material in the vietnam archive
this behavior focuses our
misunderstanding of the vietnamese
culture
vietnamese officials stood in front of
the cabinet to keep the senate committee
out would we allow this same behavior by
foreign officials in our country if we
want to normalize we do need to look at
things from a vietnamese perspective
i think that we ought to learn how to
talk to the vietnamese in a group
situation before we go over there so
that we don't look so stupid
i regret that there's not more
historical background being given but i
am delighted to see the programming
especially the senate select committee
and have uh
people in this country be able to
witness the arrogance
of u.s foreign policy and u.s white male
representation in particular it is
appalling i was in the
tri board area which is
pleiku canton doctor that area from
september 67 to june 69.
oh
as far as i'm concerned you leave those
senators
that are showing over there you just
leave them there
that's the problems that we had to start
with
i'd say take down the trade barriers
as long as bill dale thinks they're
helping us sufficiently i just found the
comments that i think the show has been
excellent but i am fairly disgusted with
the representatives from this country i
feel they have been rude and arrogant
not only to the vietnamese but to the
interpreter who has i think been an
excellent job i think this is one of the
reasons why the west the rest of the
world really does not like us because of
the representatives that we send over
representing us and they do not
thoroughly represent the way we the
american people feel
the two gentlemen there on the screen
just a moment ago off to the right
holding the cameras were richard
weinstein and greg gursky
and they did real hard work over there
on the trip to vietnam they were
carrying those big cameras around and
it was not cool it was 100 degrees and a
couple days it was over 100 and did a
superb job of holding up for that week
in vietnam
welcome if you've just joined us the
phones are open and we're going to go to
those phones for the next 25 minutes or
so
later on this week by the way those of
you who follow these things closely
these two gentlemen will be here on
separate days
trent van gaal
who just went back to vietnam to his
homeland
and james webb who's a former
sec former secretary of the navy uh
we're featured in an article that mr
webb wrote he's an author also
in a parade magazine of august the 23rd
and they'll be here to talk about
everything from prosthetics to
mr webb's case what he feels about the
whole mia pow thing
and a lot of other things his
observations from his trip back there he
went from hanoi all the way down the
country to the mekong delta tulsa
oklahoma go ahead please you're on the
line yes i'd like to make this statement
back in during vietnam it was well known
to naval intelligence for many years
that the north vietnamese got 80 percent
of their armament supplies and other
material in large volume through the
high fong harbor the only other
alternative route was over the small
mountain passes
over which you couldn't hardly get
anything of volume across those
naval intelligence was aware for years
that the hyfan harbor had these unique
characteristics and that was that its
tributaries perpetually fed silt and
sand into into them and so the harbor
over a period of time i would not
accommodate large ships in order to do
so they had to keep a sand dredge in
operation 24 hours a day
uh the simple solution to have a knocked
out 80 percent of north vietnam supplies
material would have been to take out the
sand dredge but that was not done
there were some enterprising individuals
in the united states who undertook a
project independently of the government
to knock out the sand dredge but naval
intelligence told them that if you
attempt to do so you will be
kept from doing that what's the reason
what's the reason in your opinion that
they didn't take out the sand dredge the
international banks chase manhattan city
corp american express
bank of america where i should say why
the multinational corporations they
wanted to build up a huge gigantic war
debt which we are still paying in
trillions today to the banks and to the
multinational corporations indirectly
and so uh therefore uh it was all money
and power and it's interesting to note
that uh a few days after this was made
known to naval intelligence that the
sandridge was the the key
uh
the president nixon uh mined the high
fong harbor and just a few days
thereafter the north vietnamese were
bargaining in good faith with paris
peace talks for the end of the war all
right sir thanks corpus christi texas
you're next oh thank you brian uh thank
you for c-span and it was i just wanted
to say it was a wonderful article and
time on you oh thank you you're welcome
uh during the hearings where perrault
was testifying there was a mention of
some satellite pictures of a walking k
if somebody could explain that to me
i'll hang up and listen to you all right
thank you francis who was here earlier
talked about the examination of the
satellite photos in a hearing coming up
later this fall
i'm not i can't answer your direct
question uh you know there are a lot of
uh intelligent satellites around the
world who can see things rather close
you we've shown pictures of that before
here uh that from hearings that have
been held and it it appears that uh from
their schedule that she gave us there'll
be hearings on september the 22nd where
they deal with the paris peace talks
and
invite
and they expect henry kisner to testify
later on in october looking for my list
here
they plan to have in the middle of
october three days of hearings that will
deal with some of the satellite imagery
and maybe at that point you can get an
answer to your question i'm sorry i
don't have a direct answer las cruces
new mexico you're next brian i don't
think it's your fault that you have to
go back to this i just think that it's
the democratic party keeps bringing this
up it just seems to me that they
whenever what did president bush have to
do with the vietnam war i mean how could
that was a reporter that was standing in
front of that that uh the group of mia's
and asking the question and the camera
showed that it was the the husband the
the wives and the the children of the
mis instead of showing it was a reporter
that refused to shut up and sit down
and it just made the pr i think the
president's
poll numbers went down ever since that
filming of the mis and the president
because it wasn't true it was just some
reporter wouldn't let him speak now
here's a man that has stopped the call
war without a shot he has saved the
world from being under the control of a
maniac a two-thirds of the world's oil
in the persian gulf
i just don't understand why the
democrats continue to spend the
taxpayers money
for so many of these investigations
for which
no one has been found guilty for any
great conspiracy all right thanks get
your point let's go to fall river
massachusetts go ahead please yeah
chowing brian yes hey brian uh but i
guess the question i have uh uh
for you
is um
recently uh captain red mcdaniel from
the american defense institute put out a
documentary entitled americans abandoned
it's very well done
and in that uh it shows uh a scene with
uh casey the former head of the cia
where he stated and i quote he said
we know this prison is out there uh but
there's no public support to get them in
what do you want to do to create another
hostage crisis
and the other thing uh brian
is if there has been no cover-up and if
there's been nothing to hide why was
bill bell relieved against
all common sense and why was he taken
out as head of the powmi uh office in
hanoi and replaced with basically an
individual a very nice guy by the way
from massachusetts who died of speaks
reads in the rights of language and is
culturally ignorant why all right sir
thank you rhetorical questions uh i
don't know whether we're going to get
some videotape here of some of the stuff
we shot over in vietnam or not but we've
got another 20 minutes or so to go here
on our open phones let's go to houston
texas next go ahead please oh yes thank
you for taking my call
i didn't think i was ever going to get
in
i just wanted to make a comment i
remember
in 1973 when it was old when the vietnam
was over and we withdrew our commitment
to this country and this saddened me
very much and no one is any more
american than i am
but believe you me we should not we
should lift this trade embargo from them
and i heard carrie and the the previous
one uh
arizona from arizona
is saying well maybe partly we should
lift it but i i just have to disagree
with this because we have our government
has blown it in the past and sometimes i
feel like your previous caller but those
sinisters are just not in the real world
when you're out in the audience in my
living room and listening
you know it's a different perspective we
are in the real world all right thank
you fresno california we're looking at
the old american embassy which is now an
oil company in saigon go ahead please hi
how are you today fine
i'm a vietnam veteran and
one of the things that i've you know
i've enjoyed watching this coverage
but one of the things that i haven't
seen
is
information on the covert operations
that we ran against pows that we left
behind
i happen to know that they happened
because i was involved with them
and
in what way were you involved
um
i was a part of
a team that that went into cambodia and
laos to
terminate certain prisoners that had
information that the government didn't
want getting back out talking about our
american prisoners yes and were you and
did you did you terminate people yes
and it's been bothering me for 18 years
why haven't you told anyone besides us
because if i told anybody the government
would know who i i am and i'd go to jail
for violating my
security and and why were they
terminated what information did they
have that the the the public wasn't
supposed to hear they had information on
ci cia covert operations
[Music]
that
the government just really didn't want
people to know about
i i hate to be i'm not looking for
graphic uh evidence or anything like
that but how did you terminate people
sometimes we go in and destroy a camp
sometimes we just do long range
kills
do you have any idea how many
my
my unit was responsible for terminating
15 prisoners 15 american prisoners of
war based in cambodia cambodian laos
and uh do you are there others that you
were in that unit with that are still
here in this country that you're in
contact with
no uh
half of the unit's dead right now
um half of your unit's dead half of my
unit's dead how did it die
we got hit while we were in country and
the three of us that were able to get
out
ended up killing our friends because we
were at orders not to leave anybody
alive
and and what was the reason in the first
place and who gave you the orders to
kill your own people in
our own people in a pow camp
[Applause]
i really can't go into that because then
people would know who i am
and you signed something that said you
never talk about this
i sign the same papers that anybody that
does any work for intelligence
signs that make it pretty clear you're
not supposed to talk about it have you
ever talked about it with anybody
i have
one friend that used to work for the cia
that that i sit down with when it gets
too bad for me to deal with have you
ever had counseling yes lots does it
work
um
i've made peace with my ghosts
i still have occasional
times when i can't sleep and i have
nightmares
were there a lot of
of units like this that killed our in
your opinion our own people during the
war because for intelligence reasons
during the war i can't talk about um the
time that we were in operation was right
at the time of the withdrawal
and
as for how many units who the hell knows
all i know is about my unit
okay i you know we could talk forever
about this and i thank you for calling
us uh
obviously i must say this for the
audience out there don't dispute the
gentleman's
point of view but it it is and then it
is a phone call without a name to it
without a face to it and we'll just have
to digest the information on our own
that's the only thing we can do wayne
michigan go ahead please yeah i was
wondering if you might have uh
presidential candidate lieutenant
colonel james bold greats on as a guest
uh to be honest with you i do not know i
don't schedule the guests here but i'd
be glad to pass it on and uh i must ask
you uh why you're supporting him
well i think a lot of things he wants is
what the country needs right now and
what's that
well if we want to get rid of the
federal reserve it's just straighten the
government out
there's a lot of a lot of problems just
like this idaho thing that just went
down
and were you in the service no i wasn't
all right sir thanks for calling we'll
pass on that suggestion
and uh hope to be able to see at some
point uh mr greitz where are you calling
from please
santi
where please santee california santee
california what's on your mind
uh am i on you are on okay you sound
different
sorry i must be coming through this
microphone or something okay um i i just
uh blown
by this man that called in that was so
nervous about the cia and everything and
i can't help but wonder if it wasn't
george bush was the head of the c.i.a at
the time
that scares me and you know
why hasn't
the
lame duck
presidency issue ever
been brought up on your program i'm very
surprised because so many people call in
what do you mean by lame duck presidency
you know
if mr bush gets in again he will be a
lame duck president
okay thanks for bringing it up
collinsville illinois you're next
hi collinsville you're on the air hello
my name is bob herzberger uh i'm a
veteran that was overseas 67-69
i'm just watching your pictures of
south vietnam and brings back a lot of
memories i was wondering what your
restrictions were as far as where you
could go and take pictures of
and i've heard of some different
veterans groups that have gone over and
visited i'm not positive about this i
was wondering what what restrictions
they might have had as far as where they
could go
as far as old units and things like
where they were stationed well you know
there are a couple things i can tell you
that and you'll see some of it on camera
when they tell us to turn our cameras
off
once in a while in an airport but it's
not that is not uh a special thing about
vietnam because a lot of airports they
won't let you take pictures
uh i know i asked to go to benoit and
they wouldn't let us go there
they didn't tell us why they don't
usually tell you why they say it's off
limits i think um the cameras were we
were told to turn the cameras off um
in fukuoka which you'll see on friday
but didn't
and you'll see exactly what everybody
else saw uh
you aren't i think
we landed at the base of which is on the
tip of the mekong delta where senator
kerry's base used to be
and
we were told that we could shoot
anywhere we went and these local
commanders were making the decision as
they went as the only reason why we kept
rolling you didn't you weren't going to
see anything that's
revealing at all
by the way that's the old presidential
palace there um
other than that i can't think of a whole
lot of times where they uh they you know
we didn't get the sense um that
we couldn't shoot most places as a
matter of fact you could i know i
personally went out in hanoi by myself
took a little camcorder a little high
eight camcorder walked all over the
the city uh and took pictures everywhere
and got nothing but a friendly reaction
and everything that i shot you've seen
or will see before the week's over and i
think that's you know i don't wanna
there were military operations where
we were told we couldn't go too but uh
other than that it wasn't a whole lot of
not much harassment at all doc in
alabama go ahead please hello this is
mark tatum i have information about the
burial site of up to 17 american
advisers
yes sir have you passed it on to the
committee
no i've tried to supply this information
to numerous people ever since 1980. and
why won't they take it i don't know in
fact if they did and acted on it i
didn't get any response and that's
immaterial to me as long as they did
something about it the only thing i can
tell you is that you contact the
committee directly that's not our role
here except to hear you talk about it
and
it's a very complicated process
and my suggestion to you is either
contact mr patak over at the defense
department or francis winnick at the
committee and let him know what you got
talladega alabama you're next
okay
uh sir yes
i'm a mother of a son that was in the
vietnam war and he died a year ago today
and
he he lost his dad two months after he
got in vietnam and had to come back home
for his dad's funeral and go back for
the second time he was helicopter repair
and as my congressman that i was in
contact with from my house to his in
washington and d.c
told me that a lot of the vietnam
vietnam veterans
got on drugs over there
and my son did that
and was on
uh
diminished rations put in the stockade
but he stayed his full term of over a
year in vietnam and he was proven to
have agent orange
affected him and he got a couple of
checks from that fund and he died last
year and i cannot even get a marker for
the foot of his grave showing that he
was a vietnam veteran and he wanted to
go to washington dc so bad to see that
vietnamese memorial and if he were here
today he would love to see what you're
putting on tv because he read books he
was very interested in what went on in
vietnam what did he die of
well he had
liver problems he had hepatitis first he
went to the hospital he was on
disability from 82 until he died last
year and he started bleeding from
bleeding ulcers he was hemorrhaging how
old was he
39.
all right thank you sorry
i didn't mean to cut you off i'm sorry
about your son and thank you for the
call san juan capistrano california go
ahead please hi brian hi finally got
through to you guys welcome
let me i just tell you real quickly i um
i didn't go to vietnam but i had a
friend who came back and committed
suicide from there and told me all kinds
of gruesome stories about his time there
but
one thing that i've found lately and
i've been involved with the local a
local deal here trying to find out
about environmental problems at one of
my local bases and
i'm very sympathetic with anybody who
has to deal with the department of
defense because
i found that
they're
not so much ill-intentioned as just
some of the most incompetent people that
i've ever had to deal with and trying to
get answers reasonable answers or even
somebody to even return calls
has just been one of the most
frustrating processes i've ever been
through and probably has disillusioned
me about our
government all right sir thanks for
calling we've only got a couple minutes
left these are open phones here to hear
your response to what you've been
watching about vietnam revisited
tomorrow the subject is prosthesis
prosthetics
also agent orange
and the the
life surrounding ho chi minh and the
attention he gets in north vietnam and
and especially northern hanoi although
you see ho chi minh statues
in the park right across from the rex
hotel in the main square at kanto where
many of you probably were familiar with
from being over there and as a matter of
fact katie kelly was telling us
yesterday
that one of the big controversies while
she was there was their putting of a
statue of ho chi minh with a little kid
in the square right outside the rex
hotel because of the money that they
spent on that and also very
controversial was the money they spent
the only new building
in hanoi is the ho chi minh museum which
is right behind the mausoleum which
you'll see
tomorrow let's go to memphis tennessee
next go ahead please
uh yes uh i've been watching your
program um ever since it came on
memorial day and i'm enjoying it for the
second time
uh
and i'm just this is an emotional thing
and
you know would hope that this thing
would get behind us
i've just read a book about bobby
garwood and probably why we won't find
any other
live
people there is before they released him
they told mr garwood they uh i'm reading
from his book they said this is a very
foolish thing that you have done talking
about the note that he had slipped to
the
person in the hotel in hanoi and they
said you have been thinking only of your
own life and well-being naturally he was
wanting to his freedom
but he said you have jeopardized the
lives of many others but vietnam always
learns from experience and never makes
the same make the same mistake twice
that was from the
let's see the colonel that was in charge
of garwood all right sir thank you very
much for the call we had some video
there earlier of the rex hotel standing
up on the balcony of the fifth floor
looking out over the city those of you
who remember that area saw the
spires the twin spires of the cathedral
off in the distance let's go to provo
utah go ahead please uh thanks brian i
think you got an excellent show here
i wanted to get in when senator kerry
was there i wanted to kind of talk to
them about the
investigation that they had on pows and
the reports that i watched on c-span
when they were talking with um
h ross perot and i was kind of i wanted
to ask him
how come they didn't have lieutenant
colonel james bo grice
on their investigation since he was the
one that went to laos
and been working looking for mias and
pows
for years
how come you never hear about vogue
rides all right thanks for the call
phoenix arizona go ahead please
yes um
my question is uh would there be any
motivation of uh what would the
motivation be of the vietnamese holding
our soldiers what do you think
well
would there be a motivation
i really don't think so i mean i just
common sense tells me why would they
want to hold them well the motivation
that's talked about by others that
believe that they're being held is that
they want the ransom money
the reparations promised by president
nixon of 3.5 billion dollars
that's the reason often given but it's
been 20 years
they haven't gotten the money though
that's what they say the point is that
i don't have the answer but thank you
very much for calling rod chester
minnesota go ahead please
hi brian hi
i was in vietnam in 1970 i was a grunt
over there
and
i know
during one of our
we were rescuing a firebase
we killed i don't know at least 10
vietnamese
and we bulldozed them you know into the
ground and uh because the firebase a lot
of it was ruined
and i also know in the rear because when
we go to the rear i would see
you know dead a dead enemy vietnamese
and
i'm just wondering you know and i trust
me i feel for all of the families of the
pows mias and
uh have we have our government ever
given any information or did we just
throw them in a big burner or whatever
the kids that died from the other side
all right sir thank you
uh thursday the subject here is
economics and vietnam future relations a
lot of talk about what would happen if
the embargo were lifted should it be
lifted
i also talked to some vietnamese
as a matter of fact one of the names
that some of you might remember is the
jack owen interview i'm told that he was
not re-elected to the national assembly
that's not his vietnamese name he spent
15 years here in the united states now
deals with joint ventures over there and
there are a number of them cropping up
you'll also
we talked to the
manager of the metropol hotel
in hanoi the joint venture between the
french and the vietnamese the metropole
being the hotel that's just been
refurbished and it's the only hotel in
hanoi that i guess you'd call a
three-star let's go to maybe they call
it four-star for all i know that's uh
the schedule there on this on the screen
for wednesday ho chi minh mausoleum the
army museum in hanoi the tudor
obstetrics hospital visit in saigon
tucson arizona go ahead please
i'm a veteran and i returned 20 years
later to vietnam
in 89 and i did tour through
hanoi all the way down to saigon while
ho chi minh city the only place we
weren't allowed was in arizona territory
which was anwar but otherwise we got
cordial
greetings and
at the time in hanoi they released six
remains which turned out to be a boy
from
uh benson arizona of course uh they had
to negotiate with the
government and uh two weeks later they
were informed or they went up there
after them and like i say uh turned out
to be one of our boys down here in
arizona did uh did you find the trip
worth we're running out of time i gotta
grab one more call did you find the trip
worthwhile
very much so okay sir sorry to cut you
off we got last call from santa barbara
go ahead please hi brian uh
i was a veteran there from 65 to 69 and
i was working with the saw group over
there i sent a lot of personal
photographs that i had taken when i was
over the fence as well as maps and that
that were given to us
for coordinates reasons et cetera et
cetera arclight missions and i sent a
lot of this information to a very
renowned author
who has written quite a few books about
this special forces uh order of battle
and so on so forth
and the man sent it all back to me with
letters
saying that this is all classified burn
it bury it whatever i've never seen it
you've never sent it to me
i mean he was
terribly concerned about the the whole
situation and said this is all
classified and
i'm saying you know i thought it was 20
years and they declassified war material
and unfortunately
i thought it would do him some great as
well as the general public to show some
of these photographs and maps and that
but
he didn't want to see or hear of it all
right sir thank you for that comment and
call and i'm sorry we're out of time we
unfortunately don't have
any more time left to deal with uh what
your what your subject was
and this is the end of the second day
let's show you what the next three days
quickly are going to be like that's the
saigon river behind we just went through
this schedule ho chi minh mausoleum army
museum tour of the tudo obstetrics
hospital that's tomorrow
have a live call-in show at 4 30
then on thursday
james clyde from the carnegie endowment
and our discussion about southeast asia
which includes singapore and indonesia
and
other countries including thailand and
cambodia and what the future is
economically over there u.s vietnam
relations former navy secretary
james webb will be our guest and the
phones will be open all day then on
friday
that's the day we go back via videotape
to the mekong delta also a tour of the
hanoi prison and the army museum
and a chance to see the m-i-a-p-o-w
committee
behind us there is
saigon
floating hotel in the background on the
saigon river
and that's it for
this day six hours of vietnam revisited
thank you very much for joining us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
uh
okay
me
me
he's
[Music]
hmm
me
hmm
so
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
my dog
[Music]
yes
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
okay
so
[Music]
tv
[Music]
[Music]
okay